Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Bist du inzwischen bei Clubhouse?
Selbstverständlich nicht.
Na dann machen wir heute hier Clubhouse zu zweit. So, das ist er, der Januar. Du bist nicht im Clubhouse. Das ist natürlich tragisch.
Das wundert uns aber jetzt nicht. Wir wissen ja wohl oder wir ahnen ja hoffentlich auch, dass hier in Deutschland gewisse Leute, die ein bisschen was auf der hohen Kante haben, sicherlich jetzt schon geimpft sind, und zwar mit dem Besten, was es gibt.
Ich wollte das mal als Zitat vorlesen, weil auf Twitter immer so ein geraune ist. Malte Welding schreibt, ich wette sieben Euro, dass gewisse Kreise in Deutschland schon geimpft sind. Ja na hallo, natürlich. Also da braucht man nicht raunen und sonst irgendwas. Diese Menschen wissen, wie man sich was kauft. Und die Dosis kostet 15 Euro und kann für 45.000 Euro vertickert werden. Gibt es da ein Business für, das jemand dann auch wirklich macht? Na klar. Also in der Ansicht keine falschen Vorstellungen von, das geht schon alles an den geregelten Bahn. Wir wissen, wie es hier zu Länder abläuft. Wir fingen alle an mit, oh, da sind ja sechs Dosen drin. Das ist ja super cool. Also er hat bei Yontek weniger geliefert, weil sie ja mehr Dosen verkauft und nicht Fläschchen. Nur diese Spritzen, um die sechste Dose dann da rauszukriegen, die gibt es ja gar nicht überall. Also impfen wir gerade effektiv weniger, weil wir nämlich mit sechs kalkulieren, aber nur fünf aus den Dosen rauskriegen, weil viele Orte diese Spritzen fehlen. Also da hat man auch mal schön gesehen, wie man sich wieder selber auf dem Fuß steht. Hätte man einfach mal verschwiegen, denn die Ärzte in den Impfzentren, soweit ich das gehört habe, haben schon längst die sechs, sofern es ging, geimpft. Da musste man das gar nicht an die große Glocke hängen.
Aber wir wissen ja auch, wie groß die Ungleichheit ist bei medizinischen Behandlungen. Wenn man Kontakte hat, also wenn man jetzt wirklich was Gravierendes hat, zum Beispiel, man braucht eine Herzoperation, dann geht der normale Mensch in ein Krankenhaus irgendwo vor Ort. Vielleicht hat er noch das Glück, dass er in irgendeine Uniklinik kommt. Aber der kann sich jetzt nicht den einen Herz spezialisten, der das am allerbesten operieren kann. Und da geht es ja einfach nur darum, wer ist das, der fast nur diese eine oder die zwei Operationen macht? An den muss man rankommen. Und da geht es um Kontakt. Und dann kann man sich denken, dass natürlich Leute, die ein entsprechendes Vermögen haben, die die entsprechenden Netzwerke haben, ein bisschen telefonieren müssen. Und dann lassen die sich irgendwo hinbringen, wo dieser Halbgott in Weiß sie operieren wird. Und das ist einfach zu glauben, dass da so eine ganz große Gleichheit vorherrscht, ist verrückt. Und wir erleben das jetzt auch, du hast es jetzt gerade angesprochen, für ein bisschen billiger gibt es AstraZeneca. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie diese Debatte verlaufen wird. Denn sollte sich wirklich herausstellen, dass AstraZeneca eine Wirkung hat von 70 Prozent, BioNTech hingegen und Moderna von 95, manche sagen ja jetzt auch, na, ist eigentlich noch viel höher, 98, 99 Prozent, dann kann man nicht sagen, ja, das kriegen wir jetzt den jungen Leuten gut gespritzt, weil die ja oft eh nicht Intensivpatienten werden. Da ist es ja dann nicht so schlimm, wenn die das dann dennoch bekommen sollten. Und da gab es dann jetzt die Argumentation, ich hatte dazu auch was getwittert, dass dann manche schreiben, interessanterweise viele, die auch ganz oft über das 1, 5 Grad Ziel schreiben, da gibt es in meinen Augen einen Zusammenhang, die sagen dann, ja, aber epidemiologisch oder so drücken sie sich meistens nicht aus, aber statistisch ist das viel besser. Ist es gut, also ist es besser, AstraZeneca zu bekommen als keinen, was erstmal grundsätzlich stimmt, aber dann wird gesagt, ja, aber grundsätzlich geht es doch um Herdenimmunität und wir müssen den R-Wert runterdrücken und all das. Und das erreichen wir auch, wenn ein Impfstoff, selbst nur wenn er 50 Prozent Wirkung hätte, dann da wäre ja auch ein bisschen was mitgeholfen. Aus epidemiologischer Sicht ist das absolut richtig. Und so wird ja auch gerade Politik in Deutschland gemacht. Man guckt irgendwie auf Zahlen und sagt, ja hier, wenn wir das runterdrücken, dann fällt das auch und so weiter. Ich bin aber immer noch ein Individuum. Und ich bin nicht nur irgendwas in einer Statistik. Und als Individuum möchte ich mich gewissen Risiken nicht aussetzen. Ich finde es auch falsch, jetzt wieder so zu tun, als hätten wir das Ganze nur veranstaltet mit den Lockdowns, um Leute in Altenheimen zu retten. Wir wissen inzwischen, dass Corona wohl doch einige Folgen haben kann. Auch bei jungen Leuten eingeschränkte Lungenkapazität, Abfall von IQ und und und.
Frühere Demenze.
Frühere Demenze sind also solche Folgen. Und ich kenne viele Leute, die schützen sich, die sind jung, die haben keinen Kontakt zu älteren Leuten. Die schützen sich, weil sie sich selbst schützen wollen. Und ich schütze mich auch, weil ich mich selbst schützen will. Und ich will jetzt mal einen hinkenden Vergleich machen, aber nur, um das mal deutlich zu machen. Ich mache sogar zwei hinkende Vergleiche. Einmal muss man sich mal vorstellen, man würde jetzt sagen, ja, wer bekommt eigentlich jetzt AstraZeneca? Das ist so schwer in der Zuteilung. Das sollen mal Frauen und Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund bekommen. Da haben wir so eine Gruppe, da kommen die alle rein. Würde sofort jeder sagen, das ist ungeheuer diskriminierend. Das darf nicht sein. Hier sagt man jetzt aber, ja, das bekommen irgendwie unter 65-Jährigen, also da, wo es nicht so wild ist. Das ist auch eine Form der Diskriminierung. Das kann man als Altersdiskriminierung oder was weiß ich bezeichnen. Und jetzt noch einen anderen hinkenden Vergleich. Jetzt stellen wir uns mal vor, auch wenn das eine vollkommen andere Krankheit ist und ich will das nicht relativieren, irgendwas vergleichen oder so. Jetzt stellen wir uns mal vor, mit Kondomen kann man sich vor AIDS schützen. Jetzt würde jemand sagen, ja, die Kondome hier, diese Neuen, die helfen nur zu 70 Prozent. Also da ist ein 30 Prozent Risiko da, dass sie nicht vor AIDS schützen. Aber epidemiologisch gesehen ist das immer noch gut, weil das drückt ja die AIDS-Infektionen runter. Und epidemiologisch stimmt das auch. Würde man jetzt selbst sagen, na ja gut, die 30 Prozent Risiko, die gehe ich jetzt mal ein. Natürlich nicht. Und genauso, auch wenn es eine andere Krankheit ist, auch wenn der Verlauf nicht vergleichbar ist, nicht dass man mich missversteht, genauso sehe ich das aber auch bei AstraZeneca. Ich werde mich nicht mit einem Impfstoff impfen lassen, der immer noch ein solches Risiko birgt, dass ich mich infiziere, weil es auch mein Leben gar nicht verändern würde. Ich würde doch nicht, wenn ich damit geimpft bin, danach sagen, so, jetzt treffe ich mich mal wieder mit Freunden. Zu zwei Drittel passiert hier auch nichts.
Also wir haben hier nochmal Verweis auf den Salon. Da haben wir das letzte Mal ein paar gefragt, ob wir nicht diesen Aspekt da so veröffentlichen wollen. Ich habe darüber nachgedacht, ich habe gesagt, nö, es ist halt Salon. Man kann ja den Text selber lesen. Wir haben von David Wallace Wells. Mir fiel es in dem Moment, wo wir darüber sprachen, ich habe nur gesagt, den Namen kenne ich doch. Ja, das ist der Autor von Die Unbewohnbare Erde. Also von diesem sehr tollen Buch über, es wird hier übrigens alles mit 8 Grad mal berechnet und wie sieht dann eigentlich die Erde aus. Und er hat den Text geschrieben über, wir hatten ihn die ganze Zeit mit der Ausgangssachlage der Impfstoff von Moderna, von dem wir heute wissen, 95%, vielleicht sogar 98% Wirksamkeit, stand am 12. Januar 2020 zur Verfügung und musste danach durch die Evaluierungs- und Zulassungsprozesse mit der Pointe im Text, wir können noch RNA einfach mal als Basis nehmen und sagen, darauf bauen wir dann Impfstoffe auf, indem wir einfach den RNA-Strand, den wir halt brauchen, dann nutzen, geht jetzt bei diesen Updates auch wahnsinnig schnell. Wir haben irgendwie Angst vor einer zweiten Epidemie mit einem neuen Coronavirus und sagen dann, der Impfstoff muss nur geupdated werden. Da braucht man nicht nochmal einen neuen. Und das ist ja wirklich erstaunlich, weil wir es dann nämlich schaffen, schon nach drei Monaten, falls es ein ganz neuer wäre, beim Update geht es noch schneller. Da sagt der Biontech-Chef, also zwei Wochen, dann haben wir das fertig. Also man kann das wahnsinnig schnell updaten. Auch wenn das nicht jetzt als neue Impfgrundlage nimmt und sagt, Phase 1 und 2 zum Thema Schädlichkeit und so weiter haben wir schon absolviert, da passiert nämlich nichts. Wir spritzen ja nichts. Keine Proteine, nichts. Das ist einfach nur umhüllte RNA. Und der Körper macht dann alles andere selbst. Dass wir damit wahnsinnig schnell wären, das zu entwickeln und dann auch zu produzieren. Der Biontech-Impfstoff wird jetzt beispielsweise künftig auch hier in Frankfurt mit hergestellt. Ich könnte mit dem Fahrrad hinfahren. In Höst hat nämlich Sanofi, die Firma, die in Frankreich auch versucht hat, Impfstoff herzustellen, weil sie nicht gelangen mit den alten Technologien. Die haben Möglichkeiten, RNA-Impfstoffe herzustellen, also mit Tiefgekühltes und alles. Und das machen die dann auch. Und deswegen kann ich dir dann nur absolut zustimmen, wenn wir für alle Mercedes haben, warum soll ich dann in den Trappi steigen? Das macht da gar keinen Sinn. Und vor allem mit dem Argument, du bist ja jünger, du hast ja mehr Zeit, um anzukommen an dein Ziel. Deswegen steige ich jetzt in den Trappi, bei dem ich noch die Winterjacke brauche und der nur mit 80 km Haar fährt. Nee, bin ich auch absolut unzufrieden mit dieser Lage, denn wenn es der Staat nicht hinbekommt, dann sollen von mir aus vorher die Leute einfach 45.000 Euro für ihre BioNTech-Impfung ausgeben, das dem Unternehmen geben, und die bauen dann Kapazitäten auf. Dann muss ich der Staat da halt mal raushalten, wenn es der Markt besser schafft. Und man über Falschen oder sonstiges einfach nur zur Verzögerung führt.
Ja, ich meine, es ist ja lachhaft, dass Jens Spahn sich anfangs wirklich noch brüstete, dass man weniger bezahlt hat als andere Länder für den Impfstoff. Also wie peinlich muss man sein? Also wie wenig muss man die Lage begriffen haben? Also für mich wirklich der Versager dieser gesamten Krise. Also das ist ein Wunder, dass der noch da ist. Wahrscheinlich weil es sonst niemand machen will jetzt in dieser Situation. Aber das ist unglaublich. Unglaublich auch, dass das der CDU nicht auf die Füße fällt. Und ich finde es wirklich auch richtig respektlos gegenüber jungen Leuten. Als Corona begann, als wir im ersten Lockdown waren, hat man gesagt, wir müssen die Älteren schützen. Und jeder, der ein Herz hatte und jeder, der bei Verstand war von den jungen Leuten, hat sich dann daran gehalten und hat gesagt, ja, für mich ist das doch eigentlich ungefährlich, aber die älteren Leute. Inzwischen wissen wir für die Jüngeren, ist es aber auch eine gewisse Gefahr. Nicht so gefährlich wie für sehr Alte, aber auch gefährlich. Und jetzt kann man nicht plötzlich sagen, na ja, aber ihr müsst euch jetzt mal nicht so anstellen. Dann hätten die Jungen auch damals sagen können, ja Gott, im Altenheim, was juckt mich das jetzt? Ich möchte aber auch mein Leben leben. Ich habe gerade Abi gemacht. Und das haben die damals nicht getan. Und jetzt kann man nicht so respektlos denen gegenüber sein und sagen, na, ihr könnt euch auch mit dem 2. Klasse Produkt zufrieden geben.
Genau, dann muss eben jetzt produziert werden. Biontech, Moderna, Cure, wer kommt jetzt auch? Wahrscheinlich genauso viele Versprechen wie die anderen beiden. Und bleibt uns nur ein Ausweg bisher, um die Zahlen bis zur Impfung niedrig zu halten. Und das ist testen, testen, testen. Und es ist doch eine erstaunliche Sachlage, dass wir es hier auch mit einem unendlichen Preiskampf zu tun haben. Denn testen, testen, testen läuft bisher, da es verboten ist, dass die Hersteller von den Tests mir einfach einen Test verkaufen für 5, 6, 7, 8 Euro. Nein, es muss einmal durch die Mühle der privatwirtschaftlichen Wertschöpfungskette, in dem Falle des Medizinbereichs, gedreht werden. Was bedeutet, dass wir folgende Phänomene haben. Holgi, hier ein Bekannter in unserer Podcastlandschaft, hatte Corona, hat das durch Zufall festgestellt. Und er nennt mal den Preis, was es ihm gekostet hat, diese Feststellung zu erwirken.
Sicher ist sicher, klickt hier mal einen PCR-Test und habt mir dann eine Woche oder anderthalb Wochen vorher schon für Freitag, den 18. also um 48 Stunden ungefähr, bevor ich los wollte, einen PCR-Test geklickt.
Das heißt, geklickt heißt Termin.
Genau, du machst so einen Termin dann online und musst es auch direkt bezahlen und so, damit die sicher sein können, dass du auch kommst. War sehr teuer, 160 Euro hat der gekostet. Ja, weil ich habe gedacht, ja mein Gott, bevor ich meine Eltern umniehte.
160 Euro, wenn ich mich nicht ganz täusche, ist das einmal einen Monat lang Hartz IV essen. Das ist der Preis für, ich habe keine Lust, meine Eltern umzubringen. Ich teste mich mal lieber. Also als er losging, hat er sich einen PCR-Test geholt. Jetzt stellt sich die Frage, PCR-Test hätte das sein müssen. Kann man nicht einfach auch einen Schnelltest nehmen? Und die Antwort ist, und das fand ich wirklich überraschend, jetzt einfach noch mal die etwas älteren Ausgaben des Corona-Virus-Updates zu hören. Und beispielsweise fragen wir uns ja, wir stellen den Impfstoff her in Deutschland. CureVac, BioNTech, das sind alles deutsche Erhungenschaften, sozusagen in der deutschen Forschungslandschaft, wenn auch in der privaten. Das ist ein großes Problem, das ist nicht die öffentliche. Und trotzdem ist ja überall auf der Welt, außer hier bei uns, weil Politiker formal Blödsinn machen. Und die Schnelltests, wir haben doch den Drosten, wir haben doch den PCR-Entwickler hier in Berlin. Warum ist es nicht möglich, Tests für alle zu machen? Und stellt sich raus, Drosten ist ja nicht nur die Koryphäe beim PCR-Test, sondern auch noch beim Schnelltesten. Denn er hat sich die ganzen Herstellerprodukte mal genommen und hat eine Evaluierung gemacht. Und vergleich, wie gut funktionieren eigentlich diese ganzen Schnelltests, die man entweder mit oder ohne Hilfe medizinischen Personals zu Hause, jedenfalls ohne Labor machen kann. Das ist ja der Punkt. Man braucht dafür keine PCR-Maschine, sondern man macht die einfach selbst. Und da fand ich es ganz überraschend, dass schon am 24.11. uns Drosten auch so in seinem Podcast vorgestellt wurde. Man redet hier mal so über die Güte von PCR-Tests und so weiter, pipa po. Und dann wird hier es mehr so ein Halbsatz, der hier entscheidend ist. Wie sie darüber reden, wie bedeutsam diese Studie von Drosten ist zum Thema Vergleichen, Wirkung und Effekte von Schnelltests.
Der Harvard-Epidemiologe, den ich eben zitiert habe, hat gesagt, das sei ein Meisterkurs in Antigen-Tests-Validierung. Michael Mina. Sie haben sieben Antigen-Tests validiert, also im Labor überprüft, kann man sagen. Kurz zur Auswahl. Ich stelle mir vor, da stehen auch wirtschaftliche Interessen dahinter. Wenn jetzt also das Konsidiallabor für Corona-Viren von Christian Drosten meinen Antigen-Test für gut befindet, dann ist das ein ganz schönes Gütesiegel. Wie ist denn diese Auswahl der Tests zustande gekommen?
Also, die Auswahl ist ganz einfach pragmatisch zustande gekommen. Wir haben ja so Mitte September beschlossen, dass wir so was machen, nachdem erste Pressemeldungen kamen, erste Firmen haben verkündet, Ende des Monats gehen wir auf den Markt. Da haben wir gesagt, okay, sind wir dabei, probieren wir gerne aus.
So, aus eigenem Antrieb hat sich Christian Drosten, der die Koryphäe in der Corona-Forschung ist auf der Welt, gesagt, da gibt es jetzt Firmen, da nehmen wir mal die größten Werbeversuche, die es so gibt für die PRZs, und nehmen genau diese Firmen und sagen, wir testen das jetzt mal. Und dann macht er die größte Koryphäe für Coronaviren, der den PCR-Test dafür als allererst entwickelt hat, macht eine Studie zu Schnelltests, die wiederum weltweit Anerkennung erfährt, weil selbst in Harvard sagen sie, also das ist wirklich eine Masterclass in, wie man sowas macht. Also wenn irgendwer auf der Welt weiß, funktionieren diese Schnelltests eigentlich richtig, dann ist das unser Christian Drosten.
Aber gilt der Prophet was auch im eigenen Lande? Offenbar nicht.
Das ist genau der Satz der Prophet im eigenen Lande. Ich verstehe das auch nicht. Also wir haben hier, wir reden hier über den 10 Wochen alten Podcast Coronavirus-Update 66. Bevor wir wirklich jetzt mal deep dive in, wie funktioniert dieser Test, was sind die Anforderungen, kann man das zu Hause machen und so weiter. Das wurde nämlich alles besprochen. Bleiben wir mal bei den Resultaten, sozusagen bei den Pointen der eigentlichen Argumentationen. Wie gut ist die Aussagekraft für Antigen-Tests? Und Drosten fasst das hier mal gut zusammen. Ende November.
Das heißt immer wichtig dazu zu sagen, so ein Antigen-Test ist tatsächlich eine Momentaufnahme. Schönes Wort, das im Sport auch viel benutzt wird. Das heißt, wenn ich zum Beispiel, haben wir auch schon darüber gesprochen, an der Tür zum Pflegeheim mich teste mit einem Antigen-Test, dann kann ich vielleicht jetzt reingehen, aber sollte daraus nicht ableiten, ich kann morgen auch reingehen, weil dann könnte es schon anders sein.
Richtig, also solange man dieses Fenster kurz hält, ist das alles vollkommen in Ordnung. Und da ist es auch kein Problem, wenn man Asymptomatische testet. Da kann man dann schon bei einem negativen Ergebnis davon ausgehen, dass da einfach kein Virus ist, egal, ob Symptome da sind oder nicht.
Wer negativ über einen Antigen-Test sich selbst oder getestet wurde, weiß, ich bin jetzt bis morgen 8 Uhr negativ. Ich kann niemandem gefährlich werden. Ich bin nicht infektiös. Wie weit will er die Aussage treiben? Wir haben doch, hören wir nachher auch, darf man die AHL-Regeln aufheben, nur weil man einen negativen Antigen-Test hat und so weiter? Nein, natürlich nicht. Aber Christian Drosten hat hier gesagt, ja, wenn sie sich morgens negativ testen, können sie ins Pflegeheim gehen. Da spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen.
Findet die auch jetzt so statt?
Findet auch.
Hören wir gleich, ob das so stattfindet. Aber man muss dann zum Teil viel Geld ausgeben.
Genau, man muss den negativen Test nämlich selber mitbringen. Es ist nicht so, dass das andere eigentlich... Man muss das nicht selber organisieren. So wie weit treibt Christian Drosten das Argument hinsichtlich... Sie sind dann wirklich sicher, wenn dieser Antigen-Test negativ anschlägt. Und das, was ich jetzt hier rausgehört habe, in dem nächsten Clip ist, und da können wir alle überprüfen, ob ihr das auch so hört. Selbst wenn man gerade Corona hat und die PCR sogar noch positiv anschlägt, würde Christian Drosten als Arzt jemanden, der dann beim Antigen-Test ein negatives Ergebnis hat, aus dem Krankenhaus entlassen?
Das ist wirklich ganz schön. Man kann sich ein bisschen um die Ecke daraus ableiten. Das haben wir in der Diskussion des Papers auch erklärt. Dass eigentlich dieser Antigen-Test ein Test auf Infektiosität ist. Wer da negativ ist, der ist im Moment nicht infektiös. Wenn man beispielsweise Patienten hat, der einen milden Verlauf hat, der ist aber gerade frisch infektiös und der ist positiv im Antigen-Test. Und dann wird der nach ein paar Tagen negativ, dann kann man dem wahrscheinlich sagen, jetzt bist du nicht mehr infektiös. Mit allen Konsequenzen. Man könnte sogar sagen, jetzt darfst du wieder zur Arbeit. Wenn man da vielleicht als Sicherheit noch sagt, aber trag bitte einen Mundschutz zur Sicherheit. In vielen Situationen ist das nützlich. Beispielsweise im Krankenhaus, ein Patient soll entlassen werden. Jetzt ist er aber noch am Ende der Zeit immer noch mal PCR-positiv. Alle wissen, das ist nur noch ein bisschen Restvirus in der PCR. Aber das ist sicherlich nicht mehr genug, dass sich da jemand an dem infizieren kann. Jetzt könnte man einen Antigentest machen, und der ist eindeutig negativ. Dann kann man sagen, PCR noch restmäßig positiv, aber Antigentest ist schon negativ. Alles klar, bestimmt nicht mehr infektiös. Vor allem, wenn man weiß, das ist ein Patient, der ist schon einige Wochen in der Krankheit drin und der wurde schon behandelt.
Das heißt, unterm Strich kann man sagen, nach ihrer Validierung, das, was man sich erhofft von Antigentests, das können die möglicherweise einlösen?
Also ich glaube, dass diese Antigentests ein ganz wichtiges neues Werkzeug sind in der Bekämpfung der Pandemie. Und da muss man jetzt mit vereinten Kräften, also auf der politischen, regulativen und wissenschaftlichen Ebene jetzt vorwärtsgehen, dass man die in die Anwendung kriegt, dass man die auf die Straße kriegt. Sonst ist die große Winterwelle vorbei und dann haben wir am Ende, wenn es wieder besser wird, irgendwann auch Antigen-Tests. Das wäre nicht so gut, also man muss die jetzt benutzen.
So, 29. Januar, wir sitzen hier, noch immer sind sie nicht da. Und dann wird doch immer gesagt, dass Drosten doch einen guten Draht hat. Also er sitzt doch da auch dann mit Spahn bei Pressekonferenzen und so. Wie kann das sein, dass die Bundesregierung das derart ignoriert? Also deutlicher kann ja Drosten jetzt gar nicht werden. Beziehungsweise er könnte dann höchstens noch bei einer öffentlichen Bundespressekonferenz sagen, ja der Spahn schläft und verschlammt die Tests. Eigentlich müssten wir das längst machen. Das wäre das einzige Druckmittel, das er da noch hätte.
Genau.
Das ist ja erstaunlich, dass man auf diesen Expertenrat, und er wird ja nicht der einzige sein, der das fordert, überhaupt bislang nicht reagiert hat.
Ja, also irgendwas stimmt da politisch nicht. Denn wir haben jetzt hier festgehalten, der wichtigste Corona-Forscher Europas und Top 10 der Welt macht eine hoch angesehene Studie über die Wirksamkeit von Antigen-Tests und würde sogar Patienten entlassen, die noch Corona in sich tragen, aber im Antigen-Test zeigen, die Viruslast ist so gering beim Reden, beim Ausatmen, wie auch immer, kann man ruhig wieder zur Arbeit schicken. So, und der empfiehlt, wir sollten in die Welle, in die Winterwelle hinein. Ich meine, 24. November, da sehen wir gerade, der Lockdown funktioniert nicht so richtig, dieser soft Lockdown und so weiter, und Weihnachten ist noch weit weg. Und er empfiehlt im Grunde, wir sollten das jetzt mal machen. Es wäre ein bisschen blöd, wenn es erst am Ende der Winterwelle ist. Wir sind jetzt so mittendrin. So, und der einzige Ausweg, den er damals hatte, war dieser.
Das ist nicht ausgeschlossen, dass das mal kommt, sagt das Gesundheitsministerium auch, aber natürlich auch ohne Zeitperspektive. Da muss es dann staatlich überwacht werden?
Das ist eine regulative Frage. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass man im Moment als Arzt sich solche Tests kaufen kann. Das ist ebenso geregelt. Ärzte sind in ihrem Freundeskreis in diesen Tagen sehr beliebt. Aber jeder hat auch einen Hausarzt. Und das ist, glaube ich, die entscheidende Information. Ich glaube, man sollte da mit seinem Hausarzt drüber sprechen, wie man das organisieren kann, wenn man das so organisieren will. Das ist ja letztendlich auch irgendwie die Rolle von Familienmedizin. Dass man eben auch solche Dinge erleichtert. Ich sage das jetzt so ganz ungeschützt. Ich hoffe, dass Hausärzte mit mir in dieser Einschätzung übereinstimmen.
Das Problem der Lieferbarkeit bleibt ja aber trotzdem für diesen Fall.
Ja, ich denke aber, dass man da in den nächsten Wochen erhebliche Fortschritte sehen wird. Die Lieferbarkeit wird schon besser werden.
Also ich habe da herausgehört, es ist auch die Rolle der Familienmedizin, zu sagen, wir müssen jetzt mal am Verbot Jens Spahns vorbei Schnelltests in die Gesellschaft bringen. Und sei es, dass man bei seinem Hausnetz einfach sagt, ja, können Sie mal für mich und so 5 Grad sein lassen und mir die einfach so geben. Können Sie mal dem Verbot, trotz Verbot des Gesundheitsministers, mir einfach Schnelltests geben.
Ich kenne Leute, die das schon bekommen haben.
Ich auch.
Weil dann der Schwager oder so Arzt ist. Und da haben sie das dann bekommen. Ich habe noch keinen Test gemacht, aber von denen habe ich das gehört. Und was ist denn aber jetzt, muss ich nochmal nachfragen, diese wirtschaftliche Komponente bei der Sache. Also Ärzte verdienen natürlich damit momentan wahnsinnig viel Geld. Die können dafür Mondpreise nehmen, obwohl die Dinge eigentlich nichts kosten. Ärztevereinigungen, weiß man, sind sehr behutsam, wenn es irgendwie darum geht, dass man vielleicht das eine oder andere Privileg aufgeben müsste. Ähnlich ist es ja auch bei den Impfungen. Inzwischen wird in Großbritannien im Supermarkt geimpft. Da werden Leute angelernt, die das machen. Hier ist man da noch ganz anders, als ich das angesprochen hatte. Ich glaube, im vergangenen Podcast haben wir gleich eine sehr lange E-Mail bekommen, wie ich denn es wagen könnte. Das hätte doch alles seinen Sinn, warum solche Impfungen, wie solche Spritzen nur verabreicht werden dürfen von Medizinern usw. Dann würde ich sagen, ja, es mag alles sein. Diese Regelungen haben auch einen gewissen Sinn, sonst sind sie mal nicht getroffen worden. Wir sind aber jetzt in einem Ausnahmezustand mit 1.000 Toten am Tag. Jetzt können wir sagen, wir bleiben bei diesen Regeln ganz starr und fest. Dann haben wir vielleicht am Ende 50.000 Tote mehr, haben uns aber an alle Regeln gehalten. Und dieser eine Fall von jemandem, der mal eine Spritze daneben gegangen ist, der ist dann vielleicht ausgeblieben dadurch, wer weiß. Aber sonst haben wir halt 50.000 Tote mehr. Und hier frage ich mich auch, wer profitiert jetzt gerade davon, mit wem steckt Spahn da unter einer Decke, muss man ja fast fragen. Mit wem hat er sich da irgendwie gemein gemacht, dass er sagt, ihr könnt weiter das Privileg behalten?
Jonas Schmid-Ranassit vom Drogeninstitut an Hamburg, der hat ja schon bei Ilna letzten Sommer gesagt, es ist völlig unverständlich, warum man als, und das ist ja dann sozusagen Single-Payer-Sache, nur der Staat kann PCR-Tests beauftragen. Dafür gibt es keine Konkurrenz. Wenn der Staat zu einem Unternehmen sagt, der PCR-Test für 150 Euro ist uns zu teuer, wir würden eigentlich gerne nur noch 15 Euro bezahlen, dann kann das Labor sagen, nee, dann nehmen wir dich nicht mehr. Es gibt keinen anderen, der Corona-PCR-Tests bei dem Labor beauftragen kann. Da gibt es eigentlich ein gewisses Druckmittel, um zu sagen, klar, wir wollen euch jetzt nicht ausquetschen, aber wir sehen auch, dass es da eine Gewinnmarge von 500 % gibt. Das ist einfach Quatsch. Also nicht 500, aber Faktor 5. So ist es jetzt bei den Schnelltests auch. Du hast diese Pop-up-Center, wo du dich symptomfrei prophylaktisch testen kannst, wenn du am Wochenende verreisen willst und so was. So wie Holger das gemacht hat, nur eben Schnelltests und nicht mit PCR, der hat 160 bezahlt. Wenn du jetzt in Berlin oder in Frankfurt oder wo auch immer in Koblenz, da gibt es das ja auch. Ärzte machen das einfach, weil sie es dürfen. Da arbeiten dann drei Menschen, die das machen dürfen und die haben dann so einen Tagesumsatz von 25.000 Euro wie so eine Supermarktfiliale. Nur eben nicht mit Gewinnmarge 1%, weil die ganze Logistik und Herstellung usw. bedienen werden muss von dem Zeug, was da verkauft wird, sondern die kaufen die Roche Antigen-Tests 10 Stück für 100 Euro in der Apotheke und verhökern die dann pro Stück für 35 bis 65 Euro an diejenigen, die da halt vorbeikommen. Du kriegst dann eine SMS 10 Minuten später, testest positiv, negativ, wie auch immer. Und das war's ja im Grunde. Also da sind gewaltige Gewinnmargen auf so einem privaten Feld.
Aber wer profitiert jetzt davon so sehr, bzw. diese Profite sind mir einleuchtend. Nur, was hat jetzt jemand wie Spahn davon, dieses Geschäftsmodell zu schützen? Also wir wissen, die Bundesregierung ist dicke mit der Autoindustrie und würde alles dafür tun, dass da auch nicht eine Mark verloren geht. Aber was ist jetzt bei diesem PCR-Test? Das ist mir noch nicht so klar. Werden Ärzte geschützt? Also es werden ja nicht diese Pop-up-Stores da quasi geschützt, weil man sagt, das sind unsere Freunde.
Da würde ich sagen, wir lassen das als Frage stehen. Denn ich weiß auch nicht weiter. Vielleicht taucht da irgendwann in einem halben Jahr ein Bericht beim Monitor auf.
Da hat wieder irgendjemand anders eine Wohnung vermietet, um es mal so anzudeuten.
Ja, genau. Da sind wir mal gespannt. Die Aufrechnung wird es ja irgendwann mal geben, wo ist eigentlich dieses ganze Geld hin. Genauso gut, aber auch wirklich nur als Frage in den Raum gestellt. Deutschland hat jetzt diese Antikörper-Medikamente gekauft. Über die hatten wir auch schon mal gelesen, als ganz früher in dem allerersten Buch da Bill Gates meinte, bei der Impfung ist er skeptisch, aber es gibt wahrscheinlich diese Medikamente, die nimmt man einfach morgens in der Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es heute ist, dass man sich infiziert. Weil dann hat man die Antikörper in sich, dann wirkt das wie eine Impfung. Nur die bleiben halt nicht dauerhaft, sondern die muss man immer wieder, so alle zwei Tage, einfach morgens nehmen als Medikament. Und genau so wirken die jetzt gerade. Das hat man bei Trump gesehen. Er kriegt im Laufe der Woche die Diagnose, kriegt dann am Freitag die Krankenhauseinweisung, am Samstag die Antikörpertest, ruft dann den Fauci an. Das hat Fauci jetzt bei der New York Times noch mal beschrieben, wie das war. Und woraufhin dann Trump sagt, jetzt ist es so krass, ich habe mich wirklich krank gefühlt. Aber jetzt, wo ich diese Antikörper habe, alles sauber. Der Körper wurde einfach so richtig einmal durchgespült. Der Antikörper haben gewürgt. Und er konnte Montag wieder nach Hause und hat dann schon seinen Stunt, zwei Tage später seinen Stunt da gemacht, mit Maske ab. Und das war ja wie ein Gesundbrunnen für mich. Ich bin jetzt plötzlich, fühle ich mich 30 Jahre jünger durch Corona und so weiter. Und dieses Medikament haben die jetzt gekauft für...
Dr. Buster ist natürlich damals besser. Hat dann so getan, nein, der ist ja ganz kurzatmig und eigentlich ist der tot alt krank und so weiter. Stimmte natürlich alles nicht.
Er geht halt die Treppe hoch und ist immer kurzatmig. So ist das bei 75-jährigen Menschen mit 30 kg Übergewicht. Die gehen die Treppe hoch und sind kurzatmig. Jedenfalls, das kostet 2000 Euro pro. Also eine Impfung kostet 15 Euro. Das Antikörpermedikament kostet 2000 Euro pro Behandlung. Und eine Tag Beatmung auf deutscher Intensivstation kostet mindestens 5-stellig. Das wissen sehr viele Menschen nicht, deswegen will ich sie nur mal nennen. Für eine Tag Beatmung auf einer Intensivstation verwandern hier 5-stellige Beträge zwischen den Krankenkassen und den Krankenhäusern hin und her.
5-stellig?
5-stellig. Mindestens 10.000 Euro. Bis zu 20.000 Euro in manchen Krankenhäusern. Also in deren Sicht, falls ihr mal hört, da wurde jemand 7 Wochen lang inturbiert und ist dann trotzdem aus dem Koma wieder erwacht, da könnte man die Millionenbeträge durchrechnen, was Corona so insgesamt im ganzen Gesundheitswesen so hin und her schiebt.
Aber gut, dass wir nur 12, 50 Euro bei der Impfung zahlen und nicht 15, 50 Euro.
Die blöden Israelis kaufen das für 50 Euro pro Ladung. Die sind ja wohl blöde. Nee, nee, die haben es irgendwie richtig gemacht. Und diese Antikörper, das ist auch noch wahnsinnig billig. 2.000 Euro relativ früh in der Behandlungsphase geben und wenn man sich nur einen halben Tag inturbiert, also es ist keine halbe Tag Beatmung, aber so rechnerisch, wenn man sich damit, also das wäre damit aufgewogen, wenn man sich dieses Geld ruhig mal beobachtet, ohne jetzt, ja. Ich meine, auch keine Angst vor Verschwörungstheorien, aber man sollte sich diese Geldströme doch wirklich mal angucken, weil das ist auch interessant. Man kann jetzt ruhig mal wissen, wie teuer so eine Beatmung ist. Das sind zwei, also drei, ein Facharzt und noch zwei Leute, die sich da rund um die Uhr kümmern müssen. Bei Corona, das ist ziemlich aufwendig. So, also, gehen wir wieder ganz an den Anfang. Das billigste wäre ein Antigentest, den man einfach zu Hause macht. Fünf Euro jeden Morgen. Und dann weiß man, hat man heute Corona oder nicht. Und das würde ja die gesamte Inzidenz mal richtig senken, wenn man sich einfach drauf verlässt. Die Leute, die heute mit mir im Großraumbüro sitzen, die haben sich ja alle getestet. Da ist keiner dabei, der sagt, habe ich gemacht, und dann doch nicht oder so. Da könnte man das absichern. So, und wie wird das jetzt gemacht? Es gibt, und da sind wir wieder bei Drosten, hier im November, ja, im November, klar, das eine oder andere Problem, aber vielleicht kann man es ja auch lösen.
Da muss man aber auch dazu sagen, wir haben schon ganz schön viele Schulen. Und ich glaube, für ein pauschales Testen einer Klasse, wenn in der Klasse ein Fall ist, hätten wir im Moment auch nicht genug Antigentests in Deutschland. Das wäre zumindest relativ schwierig, diese Antigentests zu mobilisieren, also auszuliefern. Und eben dann auch die, sagen wir mal, entsprechenden Lehrer, die das dann einsetzen müssten, darin kurzfristig auszubilden. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das realistisch wäre im Moment. Also diese Tests sind schon noch bei medizinischem Fachpersonal im Moment in guten Händen. Aber es stimmt, man kann die dann natürlich perspektivisch auch sicherlich ausrollen.
So, und hier haben wir jetzt mal gehört, wie Konservative eigentlich argumentiert. Sollte man noch bei den Ärzten lassen und so weiter. Das ist aber eine These gewesen, die wir jetzt mal überprüfen. Da springen wir in den 15.12. Sandra Ciesek ist zu Gast im Corona-Virus-Update. Und sie beschreibt mal diese kleine Zäsur. Erstmals in Deutschland wurde Mitte Dezember dieser Ärztevorbehalt aufgerufen.
Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen rechtlich. Die Medizinprodukte-Abgabeverordnung sieht das ja vor, an wen die Tests abgegeben werden dürfen. Und diese Apotheken dürfen jetzt auch seit Neusten, seit dem 2. Dezember auch diese Antigen-Schnelltests an Schulen und Kindertagesstätten abgeben. Also es hat sich da schon was getan. Und es wurde auch erlaubt, dass Lehrerinnen und Erzieherinnen diese Tests sogar selbst an sich durchführen sollten. Aber die Einzelheiten der Testung, das liegt noch in der Verantwortung der Länder, das umzusetzen, inwieweit das durchführbar ist und wie dann genau so ein Prozess aussieht. Also an wen sich dann ein Lehrer, ein Erzieher, eine Erzieherin wenden kann, wenn der Test positiv ist. Und wer überhaupt den Test dann diesen Personen aushändigt, das ist alles noch nicht klar. Aber da hat sich was getan und, denke ich mal, ist auch eine gar nicht falsche Richtung, weil wir natürlich die Antigen-Tests, die wir haben, die sollen ja nicht in der Schublade verschwinden, die sollen schon eingesetzt werden. Aber um die richtig einzusetzen und niemanden zu gefährden, ist es ganz, ganz wichtig, dass man einfach die Schwächen dieser Tests und auch die Möglichkeiten genau kennt. Und das ist, finde ich, noch ein Problem beim Leyen, dass immer wieder dieser Gedanke kommt, ich teste mich frei, um dann irgendwas zu tun. Und das ist leider falsch, muss man sagen, weil diese Tests auch falsch negativ sein können und die einen, wie gesagt, nicht davor bewahren, die Regeln der Hygiene einzuhalten.
So, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Antigen-Tests sortieren die Positiven raus. Für die negativ getesteten heißt es aber weiter, auch für Lehrer weiter mit Maske in die Schule gehen usw. Und wir hören jetzt hier, sie ist sehr skeptisch. Schaffen das Lehrer, jetzt wo sie es dürfen, selber zu machen? Und dankenswerterweise hat sie die Studie selbst gemacht. Also, schaffen es die Lehrer, sich selber zu testen, ohne dass ein Arzt daneben steht und ihnen noch mal die Hand führt usw.?
Ja, also genau, das war eine Studie, die wir zusammen dem hessischen Sozialministerium und dem Kultusministerium in Hessen gemacht haben. Und wir haben, wie gesagt, über 700 Lehrer eingeschlossen. Die meisten waren aus Offenbach, Stadt oder Land, weil das einfach in Hessen eine der höchsten Fallzahlen hat. Und zum Teil über 300 war dort die Inzidenz. Was wir gemacht haben, wir haben den Lehrern ein Video zur Verfügung gestellt, wie sie den Abstrich machen sollen und wie sie auch den Test durchführen sollen. Und die hatten natürlich noch mal eine ausführliche, schriftliche Beschreibung des Tests, was wann zu tun ist. Und wir hatten natürlich einen engen Draht zu denen. Also die konnten sich 24 Stunden am Tag jeden Tag bei uns melden und die Ergebnisse besprechen. Da sind dann auch Fotos ausgetauscht worden. Ist das jetzt positiv oder nicht? Und auch diskutiert worden. Und man muss sagen, dass die Lehrer und Lehrerinnen sehr professionell waren. Also wir hatten da auch studierte Biologen mit Doktortitel dabei, die das dann, sage ich mal, versuchstechnisch aufbereitet haben. Also das ist sicherlich nicht die Normalbevölkerung, die wir da untersucht haben. Und die Lehrer und Lehrerinnen haben das, wie ich finde, sehr, sehr gut gemacht. Es gab eigentlich bei der technischen Durchführung kaum Probleme, also beim allerersten Mal eher Fragen. Aber das wird ja dann irgendwann Routine. Es dauert so 20 Minuten morgens. Und da gab es eigentlich kaum Probleme, muss man sagen.
Sandra Ciesek hat also diese Safe-Kids-Studie, sie hat ja schon in der ersten Welle eine gemacht. Da hat sie die Kinder in den Blick genommen. Zehn Prozent aner Kitas hier. Also wenn man das, sie hat 60 Kitas genommen. Das wären in Frankfurt, da wo es 700 Kitas gibt, ungefähr so zehn Prozent. Also eine richtig große breit angelegene Studie, wie infektiös sind eigentlich Kinder. Damals hat man glaube ich gar keine Kinder gefunden, die positiv sind. Jetzt hat man sich die Lehrer hier genommen, wo die Inzidenz ein bisschen höher war. Vor allem in Offenbach, wo ja zum Beispiel sieben Tage Inzidenz von 300 und so weiter waren. Also, Brennpunkt. Und sie hat aber jetzt hier schon gesagt, ja, also man hat das den Lehrern in die Hand gegeben und die waren eigentlich eher so interessiert. Die haben da richtige Versuchsprojekte draus gemacht, selber völlig engagiert und so weiter. Sie ist ja hier die Virologie-Chefin der Uni Frankfurt. Und ich weiß, wenn man in der Uni Frankfurt als Mitarbeiter den Betriebsarzt anruft und sagt, ich brauche mal einen Corona-Test, dann sagt der, ja, kommen Sie zu neun Uhr zu Hause, neunzehn oder so. Und dann geht man dahin und dann kriegt man so ein Package in die Hand. Und da ist gar niemand. Und dann muss man sich das kurz durchlesen. Und dann macht man das selbst. Also die Uni-Klinik, die übrigens auch sagt, lasst das mal mit den FFP2-Masken. Es reichten total die normalen OP-Masken, wenn nur alle sie aufsetzen. Und das ist ja hier so. Denn die FFP2-Masken, die werden dann doch häufig einfach nur so drauf und wie auch immer. Da vertraut man dann mehr den normalen Masken. Also den normalen im Sinne von nicht ganz luftabschließend, aber dafür halt, dass sie weicher sind, sitzen sie einfach gut. Also da gibt es so eine Erkenntnis und eben auch, ja klar machen die Leute den Test bei sich selber. Wir ordnen doch keinen Arzt ab, der die ganze Zeit die Mitarbeiter. Und da kommen Verwaltungsmitarbeiter, die gar nichts mit dem Medizinbereich zu tun haben, kriegen das Ding in die Hand und streichen sich dann ab und machen den Test. Und die Uni vertraut da vollkommen darauf, dass die das schon ordentlich hinbekommen. Also in deren Sicht große Zurückhaltung. Hier noch ein Podcast mit, ja die Lehrer haben das eigentlich schon ganz gut gemacht, aber aber aber, aber eigentlich weiß ich auch, ja das funktioniert hier super.
Ja und sie erwähnt hier etwas ganz Wichtiges. Man hat den Lehrern ein Video geschickt. Wir haben hier einen Fernsehen. Und wir wissen, die Rentnerrepublik sitzt abends um acht vom Fernsehen. Was wäre jetzt das große Problem zu sagen, wir senden jetzt mal eine Woche durch, immer fünf Minuten vor acht, auch auf den Privatsendern verpflichtend, wie Ranga Yogish war und Eckhard von Hirschhausen, für das Publikum diesen Abstrich machen und denen erzählen, wie das zu handhaben ist. Und jetzt machen sie das mal alle nach. Sie haben jetzt ihre Tests da. Oder vielleicht noch mal mit Jean Pütz ein bisschen Hobby-Tek-Flair ins Fernsehen bringen. Es wäre doch alles machbar, wenn man sich einmal ansieht, was Diabetiker so alles tun, sich selber therapieren, mit Spritzen, mit anderen Dingen, was sie überwachen müssen. Da ist ja zum Teil auch eine Cyborg-Ausstattung kann man da schon inzwischen haben. Aber auch das muss man bedienen können. Ja, da gibt es mal eine kurze Einführung in das. Und dann wird auch derjenige damit allein gelassen und kann das ganz wunderbar. Also wie man Menschen für so unmündig erklären kann, ist mir ein Rätsel. Also man fragt sich ja, wenn man das Menschen nicht mehr zutraut, was traut man eigentlich dann dem Wähler zu, der an der Demokratie teilnehmen soll?
Nimm dir aus irgendeinem Jahrgang eine matte Leistungskursabitur, Prüfung. Und dann überlege, ob man Leuten, denen man das abverlangt, nicht zutrauen kann, dass sie sich einfach mal einen Abstrich machen. Und da fällt es für mich in Deutschland immer wieder auseinander. Wir haben diese Megabyrokratie, die allen alles abverlangt. Und dann aber, nee, so ein Test, das kann man ja wohl unmöglich den Leuten abverlangen, dass sie das selber schaffen.
Denk an die Corona-Hilfen. Ich habe es ja gesehen bei Bekannten, die dann für ihr Geschäft so etwas ausfüllen mussten. Also da habe ich gedacht, gut, da muss ich ja erst mal VWL oder so studieren und BWL, um das ausfüllen zu können. Das mutet man Leuten zu. Steuererklärung ist fast, wenn man nicht ein ganz einfaches Business hat, ohne Steuerberater nicht möglich. Mutet man alles Leuten zu, alles hochkomplex. Aber hier das soll nicht möglich sein? Das ist doch ein Witz.
Vor allem wir wissen, dass die Motivation da ist, es ist ordentlich zu machen. Leute bezahlen 45.000 Euro für ihre Impfung. Leute bezahlen 160 Euro für einen Test. Die machen es nicht plötzlich schlampig zu Hause. Also diese Unterstellung, da liegt auch im Verhältnis Staat zu Bürger ein kleines Missverhältnis vor. Hier werden ganz viele Leute für ganz schön doof erklärt.
Und es erleichtert das Leben. Das fand ich auch nochmal gut, dass das jetzt hier betont wurde. Es geht nicht darum zu sagen, dann reiße ich die Maske runter und lebe wieder wie zuvor. Aber es macht gewisse Treffen möglich, die vielleicht sehr wichtig für einen sind. Auf einer persönlichen Ebene oder auf einer beruflichen Ebene. Ich hatte letzte Woche ein Fotoshooting. Da war ein Fotograf aus Köln da. Wir haben das draußen gemacht, eher mit Maske. Ich musste sie natürlich fürs Foto abziehen. Aber sonst sagte er, ich könne gerne ins Studio kommen nach Köln. Sie machen dort auch noch große Fotoshootings für Modezeitschriften mit mehreren Leuten. Wie sieht das aus? Da werden die Leute zweimal getestet, einen Tag oder zwei Tage vorher und an dem Tag selbst. Da habe ich gesagt, wer macht das denn? Das darf man gar nicht. Die haben Gott sei Dank in ihrem Team jemand, der eine medizinische Ausbildung genossen hat und der momentan den Fotoapparat links liegen lässt, sich nur noch auf diese Tests spezialisiert hat und den ganzen Tag dafür diese Tests zuständig ist und auch andere Maßnahmen ergreift. Das muss man sich leisten können, aber das könnte man sich ja leisten, weil die Tests nicht teuer sind. Das würde ganz viel erleichtern. Es würde auch einfach mal möglich machen, ich habe diesen Freund Ewigkeiten nicht gesehen. Wir wollen uns jetzt seit einem halben Jahr treffen. Jeder macht jetzt so einen Test und wir verbringen ein paar Stunden miteinander und gehen dann wieder auseinander. Und danach sind wir noch nicht in der Normalität angekommen, sondern dann ist wieder weiter Pandemie. Aber zumindest diese Stunden sind dann auch schon einmal genießbar.
So, jetzt hat man die Lehrer hier in dieser Safe-Kids-Studie getestet, also sich testen lassen. Die haben das sieben Wochen lang gemacht und es gab diesmal auch positive. Und jetzt, finde ich, kommt der Kicker, also einer der vielen Kicker. Denn man hat doch hier eine Erkenntnis, die vielleicht interessant wäre für den einen oder anderen.
Wir haben dann insgesamt fünf Lehrer, Lehrerinnen gefunden, die echt positiv waren und die korrekt erkannt wurden von dem Test. Davon, das fand ich besonders interessant, hatten vier bereits meist milde Symptome und nur einer war wirklich präsymptomatisch. Das heißt, er hat erst im weiteren Verlauf Symptome entwickelt. Aber was interessant war, ist, dass von den Vieren, die Mehrzahl gar nicht so typische Symptome hatten, also die sie davon abgehalten hätten, zur Schule zu gehen, sondern die meisten haben zum Beispiel angegeben, sie haben Kopfschmerzen oder Gliedermuskelschmerzen und wären gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen, einen Test zu machen. Und wären natürlich arbeiten gegangen mit diesen hohen Viruslasten. Nur einer hatte, sag ich mal, klassische Symptome. Und das fand ich schon beeindruckend, dass das doch so auch viel interpretiert wird oder gar nicht zu erkennen ist.
Man muss die Hürde für Tests sehr viel weiter senken, um Corona zu finden. Denn wenn die Leute immer erst Eier, Erkältungssysteme und Symptome und Fieber, dann mach ich jetzt mal einen PCR-Test. Dann geh ich jetzt mal zum Arzt, mach die ganze, worauf ich eigentlich keine Lust hab. Nee, man müsste sich eigentlich beim kleinsten Schmerz im Fuß, ist ja auch ein Glied, einfach mal morgens selber testen können, weil dann findet man plötzlich ganz schön viele Kopfschmerzen.
Hat sie angesprochen, wie viele Menschen haben Kopfschmerzen in Deutschland?
Also in der Ansicht, hier liegt doch ein Potenzial drin, dass über diese PCR-Strategie, die wir gerade haben, gar nicht aufgefangen werden kann. Also wir haben ja sozusagen noch einen Surplus in der Corona-Bekämpfung durch Antigen-Tests, die man bei sich selber macht. Gut, wie sieht es mit dieser legendären, sagenumwobenen, falsch-positiven Quote aus und was gibt es dazu zu sagen?
Dann gab es in der Studie auch noch positive Antigen-Testbefunde, die wir nicht bestätigen konnten, also über den gesamten Zeitraum 16. Und wir haben aber über 11.000 Tests machen lassen, die auch dokumentiert wurden, sodass die falsch-positive Rate insgesamt bei 0, 14 Prozent lag, also sehr niedrig. Trotzdem ist das natürlich über ein großer Aufreger, sage ich mal, wenn der Test positiv ist. Und die waren auch gar nicht unbedingt schwach positiv, weil das natürlich verunsichert. Das waren meist Leute ohne Symptome. Und dann haben wir im Labor geguckt, woran das liegen kann, und haben festgestellt, dass bei denen, wo wir geguckt haben, dass die einen Staphylococcus aureus in der Nase hatten. Das ist ein Bakterium der Normalbesiedlung, sage ich mal. Das haben viele in der Nase. Das ist nichts Schlimmes. Aber das kann kreuz reagieren mit diesem Antigen-Test. Und da haben wir dann diese Leute aus der Studie ausgeschlossen, weil die dann immer wieder positiv getestet wurden.
So, also ja, es gibt Falsch-Positive. Aber es waren nur 0, 14 Prozent, und sie ließen sich alle über dieselbe Ursache erklären. Das hieß, wir haben es also nicht mit dem Problem mit Falsch-Positiven zu tun, sondern wir wissen genau, bei welchen 0, 14 Prozent es nicht funktioniert. Wir wissen dadurch aber auch, dass es bei 99, 9 Prozent oder 8, 6 Prozent funktioniert.
Ja, und greifen wir noch mal das auf von den Impfungen. Da sagt man, ja, 70 Prozent ist doch schon viel. Und jetzt hier wird jetzt irgendwas von 0, 1 so und so erzählt. Ja, das ist aber bedenklich. Und dann gibt es ja diese Argumentation, die Spahn lange vorgetragen hat. Die Leute wiegen sich in einer falschen Sicherheit und dann werden sie übermütig. Also bitte, wir sind ja keine kleinen Kinder.
Also ich will hier schon mal so ein Zwischenfazit ziehen. Mit Schnelltests, und wir wissen, wie lange Corona braucht, von einem Symptomausbruch bis der nächste dann Symptomausbruch hat usw. bekämen wir innerhalb von vier Wochen diese Inzidenz auf unter fünf, wenn die nur ordentlich verfügbar wären. Die Leute wollen das machen, sie können das machen, sie sind in der Lage, die Dinger sind aussagekräftig. Ein Monat selbst im Winter und wir hätten das Ding wirklich gut im Griff. Und jetzt stellt sich die Frage, kann man es nicht noch ein bisschen einfacher machen? Ist es nicht dann doch tief in die Nase und so muss das sein? Nee, muss alles überhaupt nicht sein. Also das finde ich wirklich erstaunlich. Und wir sind hier beim 15.12.2020. Das ist auch schon wieder ewige, ewige sechs, sieben Wochen her.
Es gibt ja aber auch noch andere Alternativen. Ein Abstrich nur aus dem vorderen Teil der Nase zum Beispiel. Da gibt es eine Studie aus Heidelberg und Berlin, die wir hier in Folge 66 auch ganz kurz schon mal gestreift haben. Die haben im Prinzip Antigen-Tests in der Selbstanwendung ausprobiert. Und zwar auch mit einem solchen vereinfachten Abstrich. Wie genau ist das evaluiert worden?
Die haben halt bei Patienten, also es waren zwar 89 Studienteilnehmer, da haben die bei 39 davon mittels PCR-Testung eine SARS-CoV-2-Infektion nachgewiesen. Und die haben die Studienteilnehmer gebeten, sich erst mal selber abzustreichen. Und zwar statt das medizinische Personal daneben und hat Instruktionen gegeben. Und da haben die dann gesagt, dass die einen Tupfer so zwei bis drei Zentimeter tief in die Nase, in die Innenwände einführen sollten. Und dann 15 Sekunden kreisende Bewegungen an der Innenwand machen sollten. Dann hat das Personal von dem Studienteilnehmer einen tiefen Nasenabstrich gemacht. Und dann wurden beide Proben getestet auf einen Antigen-Schnelltest und mittels PCR der andere Abstrich. Und was man sagen kann, ist, dass die Ergebnisse ja gar nicht so schlecht waren. Also wie gesagt, 39 hatten mittels PCR eine Infektion. Und 31 davon, also 80 Prozent ungefähr, bei denen schlug der Antigen-Schnelltest an, wenn der Abstrich professionell ganz tief entnommen wurde. Und beim Selbstabstrich, da schlug es bei 29 an. Also 29 versus 31 finde ich jetzt gar nicht so schlecht. Dazu muss man aber sagen, dass die PCR natürlich sensitiver ist. Das heißt, die, die der Antigen-Test nicht erkannt hatten, das waren vor allen Dingen Menschen, die nicht so eine hohe Viruslast hatten, was ja auch wiederum passt. Und sie sagen dann, wenn man sich nur die anschaut, die eine hohe Viruslast hatten, dann schlug der Antigen-Test bei einem tiefen Abstrich immer an und bei Selbstabstrichen in knapp 96 Prozent der Fälle. Das finde ich gar nicht schlecht.
So, wir haben ja vorhin von Drosten schon gelernt, PCR-positiv, da kann man schon Leute aus dem Krankenhaus entlassen, wenn der Antigen-Test negativ ist. Genau das liegt hier gerade vor. Wir wissen ja, 20 Prozent sind für 80 Prozent der Infektion. Es ist auch dieses Superspreader-Phänomen. Es ist nicht der allgemeine R-Wert, sondern es ist auch dieses Phänomen. Und man kann vorne zwei, drei Zentimeter tief in der Nase, also da kommt man mit dem Taschentuch noch hin, einfach 15 Sekunden im Kreis und dann Abstrich machen. Und der ist aussagekräftig über diese Infektiosität. Die Superspreader kriegt man damit alle eingefangen und bei den Rest auch noch ziemlich alle. Also es ist noch diese 20-Prozent-Lücke zu. PCR würde doch anschlagen in der 35. Umdrehung oder so. Aber eigentlich sind wir hier ziemlich auf sicherem Grund, was mit Abstrichen vorne in der Nase. Und wenn jetzt noch jemand behauptet, also dafür bräuchte man aber einen Arzt, um sich vorne in der Nase irgendwas... Dann muss Jens Spahn auch vorbeikommen und uns die Nase putzen, weil das kriegen wir dann auch nicht allein hin. In deren Sicht muss man sagen, das ist ein ganz schön krasser Vorteil, den wir hier mit Antigen-Tests haben. Und neben, wir können noch Symptome einfach mal schnell testen, die wir ansonsten nie in den aufwendigen PCR-Prozess gebracht hätten, gibt es noch einen anderen Vorteil.
Das muss der Labormediziner dann erkennen, dass die anderen gehen.
Hier geht es noch kurz um PCR-Mutation. Da muss der Labormediziner dann genau gucken. Das hat man ja in England. Man hat auf drei Sachen, Teile im Spike-Protein getestet. Und dann schlug einer nicht mehr an. Da hat man gesehen, hier liegt eine Mutation vor. Wie ist das bei den Antigen-Tests?
Nachweisbar sind und muss sich entsprechend anschauen und bewerten. Da sehe ich jetzt keine großen Probleme hier. Und bei den Antigen-Tests, da gibt es Daten aus Großbritannien, die sich vor allen Dingen die N-Gen-Mutationen in der Variante angeguckt haben. Die sich am N-Terminus, an einem bestimmten Ende befinden. Und wie gesagt, die sind ja oft Nukleokapsid, dass sie das nachweisen. Und die haben sich fünf verschiedene Antigen-Schnelltests angeguckt, die auch hier auf dem deutschen Markt zum Teil sind, also die häufig benutzt werden. Und die haben dort gesehen, dass das keinen Ausfall bewirkt hat. Also dass die noch sehr gut funktioniert haben. Dass, wenn man mit den Varianten infiziert ist, hier kein Problem sieht.
Das heißt, Schlagzeilen, die es dazu gab, die hatte ich zwischenzeitlich gelesen, dass ein dort verwendeter Antigen-Schnelltest eine hohe Fehlerquote bei der neuen Variante hat. Die sind einfach Quatsch.
Also so, wie es jetzt von der britischen Regierung verkündet wurde, ist das nicht der Fall. Es gibt natürlich vielleicht einen einzelnen Test, den das betrifft. Aber die, die hier angeschaut worden haben, haben kein Problem. Und für Südafrika, für die Variante, da fehlen uns diese Daten. Ich denke, da wird es aber auch bald in den nächsten Tagen oder Wochen Daten zu geben. Aber bisher liegen die für Südafrika nicht vor.
Ja, das war am 12.01. Mittlerweile liegt das alles vor Jahren. Da verändert sich das Spike-Protein, das am Körper ansetzt, weshalb das ja infektiöser wird. Aber die Antigen-Tests gehen ja gar nicht auf den Spike. Sondern die gehen ja wirklich nicht in das Virus. Und da liegt kein Problem vor. Also wir finden damit auch die Mutation. Wir erkennen zwar nicht, dass es die Mutationen sind, aber wir sehen trotzdem, dass es Corona. Also SARS-CoV-2, das müssen wir hier mal aussortieren. Also in der Hinsicht ganz erstaunliche Sachen. Nur, und das ist eben der Punkt, epidemiologisch macht das alles super Sinn, zu sagen, wir machen jetzt nicht einen Monat langen Siro-Covid-Super-Hard-Lockdown oder so. Sondern wir sagen einfach, alle testen sich einfach morgens mal. Sodass wir die Positiven rausfallen, ohne für die Negativen den bisherigen Lockdown zu verändern. Also keine Rammstein-Konzerte jetzt. Auch den nächsten Monat nicht, ja? Ist eh Winter. Sondern einfach nur die Positiven mal raussortieren und die Infektionsketten, bevor sie losgehen, wie bei den Lehrern, unterbrechen. Denn vier von den fünf Lehrern, die positiv getestet wurden, haben ja gesagt, sie wären nur noch zur Arbeit gegangen, weil es waren ja keine Corona-Symptome. Und da muss man rausfinden. Und das ist der ganz wichtige Punkt. Deswegen hören wir uns das auch noch mal kurz an.
Wir haben viel mit Antigentests jetzt versucht einzuführen in den Pflegeheimen. Es reicht halt nicht. Ich glaube, eine Gefahr ist einfach immer, dass man denkt, wenn man einen negativen Antigentest hat, dass dann vielleicht doch man die anderen Regeln, also die Abstand, Hygienemaßnahmen und andere Regeln vernachlässigen kann und leichtsinnig wird. Und ich denke, hier muss man besser aufklären, dass das auf gar keinen Fall der Fall sein darf, dass man da einen Kompromiss eingeht und dass die Hygienemaßnahmen einfach unersetzlich sind, auch wenn man einen negativen Test hat. Das würde ich sogar auch so sehen, wenn man einen PCR-basierten negativen Test hat.
Sie sagt sogar bei PCR negativ, trotzdem Aha-Regeln. Ist ja alles richtig. Und deswegen, hier der Punkt. Es geht hier nicht darum, dass die ganze Gesellschaft frei getestet wird, sondern dass das Ziel Zero-Covid nur über die Verfügbarkeit von Schnelltests zu machen ist. Denn wir haben gesehen, was in Spanien Zero-Covid-Lockdown gebracht hat, gar nichts letztes Jahr. Da hat man die Kinder einfach 5 Wochen eingesperrt. Die durften wirklich nicht aus dem Haus. Und es hat genauer zu gar nichts geführt. Zweite Welle kam, es war alles genau wie vorher. Man braucht halt diese Schnelltests. Die Lösung ist eine technische Lösung in dem Falle. Und nicht die härtere Lockdown-Maßnahme. Sondern der Lockdown, wie jetzt, sehen wir ja, da funktioniert schon. Aber man kann das halt rasant beschleunigen, indem man einfach sagt, und die Positiven ziehen wir jetzt einfach mal raus.
Das heißt aber, wenn wir jetzt alles so gemacht hätten, wie wir es gemacht haben, plus Schnelltests. Also wir reden ja jetzt gar nicht um diese ganzen Lockerungsübungen, die dann auch immer für Empörungen sorgen in den sozialen Medien. Was, wollte ich wieder alles öffnen? Nein, also wir hätten jetzt alles genau so gemacht. Hätten aber auf dich zum Beispiel gehört, ich glaube, du hast das im April oder Mai schon geschrieben, Schnelltests. Wir haben auch hier schon immer wieder vom Sport. Genau, Kekole hat das, glaube ich, als einer der ersten überhaupt gesagt. Das heißt, hätten wir dies noch gemacht, dann wären wir jetzt vielleicht gar nicht mehr im Lockdown. Zumindest wären wir jetzt nicht bei solchen Zahlen, sondern würden irgendwo gucken, wo sind noch 300 Fälle.
Ja, wir hätten wahrscheinlich taiwanesische Verhältnisse. Und ich will es jetzt mal ganz ausdrücklich sagen, wir sind ja ansonsten nicht so ein politischer Podcast und so. Aber wir besprechen hier gerade ein Thema, mit dem Die Neuen Zwanziger so richtig einmal auf die Bremse getreten sind. Und wir fragen uns, hätte das denn sein müssen? Und wir wissen, mit welchen zwei Argumenten Alexander Kikolä und Hendrik Streeck in die Argumentation gegangen sind, und zwar seit April letzten Jahres. Kikolä mit diesen Schnelltests hat an jedem Podcast erwähnt, wir brauchen diese Schnelltests. Die Firmen wundern sich auch, wieso ist das verboten? Wieso wird das nicht gekauft? Die Lager sind doch voll. Hendrik Streeck hat gesagt, wir brauchen ein Ampelsystem. Wir dürfen nicht immer erst warten, bis die Inzidenz bei 200 ist. Dann sagen wir, brauchen wir es eine Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz an, die dann irgendwas entscheidet, was dann in zwei Wochen gilt. Sondern wir müssen vorher festlegen, bei Inzidenz 100 sind die Schulen zu. Und wenn die Meldung da ist, Inzidenz 100, wissen alle Eltern, heute keine Schule. Weil bei Inzidenz 100 gibt es keine Schule. Also die Entscheidung sozusagen vorwegnehmen. Nicht erst warten, bis das Problem da ist, und dann den politischen Prozess, und dann den Überzeugungsprozess, und dann den medialen Diskurs, und dann irgendwann funktioniert das mal. Das kann man beschleunigen. Und die beiden Sachen funktionieren noch ganz wunderbar zusammen. Denn wie hoch wäre denn die ganz private, intrinsische Motivation zu sagen, dass mit dem Schnelltest nehme ich jetzt mal echt ernst, wenn meine Nachbarschaft in Sippenhaft genommen wird, und es heißt, bei Inzidenz 100 ist hier die Schule zu, und es gibt keinen Vereinssport. Also da passt auch irgendwie Motivation und Regelwerk ganz wunderbar eigentlich zusammen, um Corona zu managen, während wir jetzt diese sinnlosen Diskussionen haben. Also wirklich absolut sinnlose Diskussionen, die zu nichts führen, die auf dem Prinzip Hoffnung basieren, auf dem Prinzip pseudo-autokratischem Handeln. Söder macht ja keine richtigen Ansagen. Der tut ja nur so, um medial gut dazustehen. Er blustert sich auf. Genau, der schickt ja dann nicht die Polizei los und sagt, aber jetzt ist Bergisch-Gladd... äh, hat ein Kirschen da nirgends so, oder wie auch immer, immer richtig akkuri-ge Tirschenreut. Das macht er ja alles nicht. Das ist alles nur pseudo für die Medien, damit sich die Leute zu Hause gut fühlen. Na, das ist mein Mann irgendwie. Da haben wir halt echt ein bisschen Pech, dass, das hat ja Habeck noch mal darauf hingewiesen, dass nun leider gerade Söder Ministerpräsidenten-Konferenz-Vorsitzender war, als das alles losging und er deswegen die Bühne genutzt hat. Aber das hätten wir uns alles sparen können, wenn wir einfach auf Kikolé und Hendrik Streeck mal ein bisschen mehr gehört hätten.
Und jetzt müssen wir nochmal etwas aufgreifen, was wir im Salon schon angesprochen haben. Da war deine These, vielleicht kannst du das nochmal ganz kurz mit Luhmann erklären, dass es ja die Wissenschaft und die Wirtschaft gibt und dass es aber auch den Staat und das Recht gibt. Kannst du das nochmal ganz kurz aufgreifen?
Wissenschaft und Wirtschaft sind kognitive Funktionssysteme. Luhmann hat diese Unterscheidung zwischen kognitiven und normativen selber später mal verworfen. Ich finde sie trotzdem heuristisch hochinteressant, denn wir lernen, was Profit ist und wissenschaftlich war, durch uns selbst. Wir machen ein Geschäft auf dem Markt und stellen fest, geil, es sind ja noch drei Euro übrig. Ich habe heute besser das Marktgeschehen bewältigt als letzte Woche, wo nur 1, 50 Euro durch waren. Ich weiß jetzt, wie das geht mit dem Profit. Nächste Woche drehe ich mal an diesen. Man muss darüber nachdenken, die Schlüsse daraus ziehen und kognitiv daraus lernen. Aha, das bringt mir Profit. Das ist in der Wissenschaft genauso. Ich kann meine Operationalisierung nicht bestechen. Ich kann meine Maschine nicht aufzwingen, bringen sie mir dieses Ergebnis, denn ich mache einen PCR-Test, und das ist entweder positiv oder negativ. Also auch hier haben wir es mit einem kognitiven Lernen zu tun. Ich muss die Maschine durch Lernen so gestalten, dass sie für mich arbeitet. Und das Recht und die Politik daneben sind keine kognitiven, sondern normative Funktionssysteme. Da gilt der Zwang. Da ist egal, welche Meinung ich habe und wovon ich überzeugt bin, sondern da gilt einfach, was von außen an mich herangetragen und notfalls physisch in mich reingeprügelt wird, weil wir haben ein Gewaltmonopol beim Staat. Und das trifft ja auch gerade so ein bisschen aufeinander, dass nämlich Menschen, die so Corona-Leugner sind, kognitiv einfach sagen, es gibt kein Corona. Und dann treffen die aber auf einen Staat, der sagt, ja doch, gibt es schon, und notfalls muss es halt in der Gefängniszelle aussitzen. Also deine kognitive Überzeugung, die hilft uns hier gerade nicht weiter. Meine Frau hat das mal erzählt. In der ersten Welle sind noch Eltern von Patienten in die Uniklinik Frankfurt gegangen und haben gesagt, ja, guten Tag, und dann kam die alle, wollen sie mal eine Maske aufsetzen? Und dann haben Menschen, Privatleute, den Klinikpersonal gegenüber gesagt, wieso glauben sie an Corona? Weißt du, wo du denkst, hey, sie sind hier in einer Klinik. Das ist doch keine Glaubensfrage. Es gibt Corona und wir schützen uns hier. Und da treffen so kognitive und normative Prinzipien aufeinander und da sieht man, das passt nicht gut zusammen. Und das passt gerade nicht gut zusammen. Also diese Kognitive, wir wissen, wie ein Schnelltest anzuwenden ist, wir sind motiviert und wir können das mit dem Ergebnis auch umgehen, passt irgendwie nicht zu diesem normativen, wir verbieten euch das und sagen dafür, macht mal das und das, nämlich Kontaktsperre und so weiter, auch nach zwölf Monaten noch.
Und so kommen dann noch mal motivierende, emotionale Reden. Also so ist ja die Kommunikation. Die funktioniert ja dann genau nicht, über das Kognitive adressiert werden soll. Ein Gefühl, wir haben über diese bescheuerten Werbespots gesprochen, besondere Helden, bleibt zu Hause, diesen Kram. Also man versucht auch tatsächlich dann gerade das Kognitive nicht zuzulassen. Das sind ja Spots, die rein dazu gedacht sind, dass man nicht denkt, dazu werden sie produziert. Und jetzt war dein Ansatz, der mich natürlich als Marxisten ein bisschen herausfordern sollte, dass du sagtest, hätte sich der Staat nur mal rausgehalten, bei den Impfungen zum Beispiel, und genauso könnte man ja jetzt auch sagen, bei den Schnelltests, dann wären wir schon sehr viel weiter. Als Marxist bringt mich das nicht um, denn es gibt ja sehr wohl die marxistische Lesart der Geschichte, dass durch Technik sich die Gesellschaft verändert, dass durch Kapitalkonzentrationen Umwälzungen stattfinden, die auch gewisse Werte über Bord werfen, alles stehend und ständisch verdampft. Insofern ist Marx ja niemand, der sagt, und das soll nur alles der Staat lenken. Die Frage ist nachher natürlich, dass der Staat die Oberhand erhält bei der Sache, aber das tut er ja auch dann, wenn er sagt, liebe Wirtschaft, ihr habt jetzt die Möglichkeit, ganz viel Geld zu verdienen mit Schnelltests. Wir drosseln zwar den Preis, ihr könnt jetzt hier keine Mondpreise verlangen, aber ihr könnt pro Schnelltest 10 Euro nehmen.
Darf ich mal kurz einhaken? Ja. Hinzudrich Konkurrenz. Bei PCR ist klar, das ist monopol. Das braucht medizinisches Personal, das sind Labore, das sind wirklich teure Geräte. Bei den Schnelltests führt das Bundesinstitut für Arzneimittel und Medizinprodukte eigens eine Liste über verfügbare Schnelltests am Markt, die in Deutschland alle verboten sind, in privaten Händen. Und diese Liste hat derzeit 332 Einträge. Allein 24 Tests davon werden in Deutschland hergestellt. Und sie haben durchweg eine Spezifizität von über 90%, Spezifizität über 98% und eine Sensitivität von 90% sind. Also absolut brauchbar, was die Fragestellung, Inzidenzen und superinfektiöse Leute herausfiltern angeht. Also wir haben es hier nicht damit zu tun, dass jetzt plötzlich, wenn der Staat sich daraus hält, ein Monopolis, der uns alle aussaugt und so weiter. Ich glaube, es ist nicht so, dass man so weiter da steht und sagt hier kauft bei mir den Antigen-Test für 25.000 Euro in Dubai oder so, sondern wir haben unglaublich viele Unternehmen, die unglaublich viele Produkte, die alle miteinander in Konkurrenz stehen und auch alle herstellen können.
Das wäre also meine Marktwirtschaft, das wäre Mittelstand.
Es wäre absolut mega Mittelstands-Marktwirtschaft.
Ja und man hätte dann als Start gesagt, macht produziert, ihr könnt die verkaufen und wir müssen nur sehen, dass wir auch dann erfahren, wer hat es, dass wir noch mal in anderer Weise Daten nehmen können. Das kann man ja alles regeln. Da ist aber auch immer noch der Markt da. Also der Markt ist nicht dann frei vollkommen, sondern der Staat setzt den Markt diesen Rahmen genau das zu tun, weil der Staat erkennt, dass er in diesem Punkte, dass sehr viel sinnvoller machen kann, der Markt als der Staat selbst. Und das ist auch eine Erkenntnis, die man bei Lenin finden kann, die aber auch bei anderen ist. Also war immer die Frage, würde eine Planwirtschaft funktionieren, ganz ohne Marktwirtschaft? Und die Antwort muss ehrlicherweise lauten Nein. Und das hat es auch nie gegeben. Insofern widerspricht sich das keineswegs. Und warum nicht diese Kapazitäten nutzen, die man hat? Warum das Ganze verkomplizieren? Also Kapitalismus meint ja auch, dass man Produktivkräfte freisetzt. Und ein Sozialismus baut ja nicht darauf auf, dass er sagt, wir zügeln den Kapitalismus in der Form, dass wir den jetzt wieder zurückbauen, versuchen wieder in feudale Zeiten zurück zu gelangen. Sondern die sozialistische Idee ist ja, der Kapitalismus schafft erst ein Fundament, ein fortschrittliches Fundament, von dem aus ein Weg in den Sozialismus möglich ist. Wir werden ja im Salon auch über Grace Blakelys Buch gemeinsam sprechen. Sie sieht sich ja ganz klar als Sozialistin, wo das, glaube ich, auch noch mal sehr deutlich wird. Das heißt, wir müssen hier ganz klar begreifen, dass es nicht darum geht, das jetzt auf so eine ganz merkwürdige, primitive Weise gegeneinander auszuspielen, dass man jetzt sagt, ja, die böse Wirtschaft jetzt gerade. Nee, das ist jetzt mal nicht die böse Wirtschaft. Und da müssen auch manche linksliberalen Reflexe mal aufhören.
Es bietet sich noch eine Niklas-Luhmann-Heuristik an, nämlich die zwischen, da kommen wir auch später noch mal drauf zurück, es gibt so Steuerungs-Fantasien, ja. Wenn es die Politik, die Politik muss es doch nur richtig machen. Und dann wäre doch allen geholfen. So im Sinne von, kann die Politik überhaupt in fremde Funktionssysteme eingreifen im Sinne von wirklich Steuern? Und da gibt es bei Niklas Luhmann diese Unterscheidung, die ist also ein ganz einfaches Argument, das gibt es auch überall, er hat sich da einfach nur bedient, zwischen konditionaler und zielorientierter Programmierung. Denn der Staat macht derzeit, er soll sich nicht komplett zurückziehen, aber er macht derzeit zu viel konditionale Programmierung und das heißt zu viele Wenn-Dann-Regeln. Wenn du aus dem Haus gehst, darf nur eine Person neben dir laufen. Das ist eine ganz klare Wenn-Dann-Regel. Die Politik sagt, wenn du aus dem Haus gehst, darf nur eine Person neben dir sein, ganz egal was sonst ist. Er hätte auch sagen können, wenn du außer Haus bist, darfst du niemanden infizieren. Das ist das Ziel, den Weg davon dahin, die Wenn-Dann-Regeln, die kannst du dir selber geben. Zum Beispiel, ich setze eine Maske auf, machst einen Antigen-Test und sage auch allen anderen, die mit dir sind, macht mal einen Antigen-Test. Und zack, könnten auch zehn Leute zusammen durch den Wald spazieren. Ohne dass der Staat sagt, aber ihr sprecht doch hier meiner Wenn-Dann-Regel. Ich habe doch gesagt, wenn du aus dem Haus gehst, dann nur eine Person. Und die sagen dann, aber das Ziel ist keine Infektion. Und das schaffen wir gerade ziemlich gut, wenn wir haben den Drosten-Podcast gehört. Ich will noch mal darauf hinweisen, wir haben jetzt kein magisches Untergrundwissen oder so, sondern es ist der meistgehörte Podcast Deutschland, über den hier null diskutiert wird. Alle jubeln über Drosten und wie geil das ist. Tolle Wissenschaft, aber null politische Forderungen. Hinsichtlich, der Drosten hat auch gesagt, dass mit den Antigen das funktioniert. Und der Typ in Harvard auch, übrigens.
Wie erklärst du dir das? Also du hast jetzt wirklich die ganz Populären hier vorgespielt und du könntest noch weitere Populäre vorspielen.
Das versendet sich alles.
Ja, aber es hört doch...
Wenn Philipp Amthor im Drosten-Podcast wäre und dort das Pommellied singt, das wäre überall. Wenn Drosten sagt, ich habe übrigens die weltbeste Studie zur Antigen-Test gemacht, vor zehn Wochen schon vorgestellt, und da habe ich empfohlen, wir sollten mal in den Winter einen Antigen-Test vorstellen, hat er ja nicht gesungen. Also ich sage es polemisch, aber es versendet sich unglaublich viel.
Hier funktioniert dieses Prinzip von Interpassivität, das Robert Faller kreiert hat. Er sagt, wir delegieren unseren Genuss oder das, was wir so tun. Also du hast das Konservenlachen eben mal angesprochen. Da lacht jemand für uns, da muss ich das selbst nicht tun. Und ich glaube, diese große Drosten-Verehrung, die man so bei Twitter erleben kann, die ist nicht eine Verehrung, mit der ein wirkliches Erkenntnisinteresse verbunden ist. Also so etwas, was du jetzt gerade vorgeführt hast, was man für Erkenntnisse dort gewinnt und welche Schlüsse man draus ziehen kann, sondern es ist eher so toll, dass das jemand so macht mit der Wissenschaft. Es ist so, wie man früher dem Pastor fünf Euro gab und sagt, beten sie auch für meinen lieben Mann, der schon im Himmel ist. Und der betet dann für einen, aber man muss es selbst nicht machen.
Ja, sehr guter Vergleich. Da habe ich auch gerade so dran gedacht, das tut über Spaß. Das ist so, wie wenn man zu seinem Köchenmenschen geht und er sagt, er könnte sich bitte mal für mich Kontakt zu Gott halten. Danke, dass sie es machen. Ciao, ich bin dann mal in der Kneipe und besaufe mich und krebsche danach Frauen an und Sündige den ganzen Tag. Und so ist das hier auch. Das ist toll, dass der Drosten so gut mit der Merkel reden kann. Aber reden die überhaupt miteinander? Hören die sich zu? Also was ist hier? Sollte man nicht selber mal aus dem Drosten sozusagen eine eigene politische Forderung, die man dann an die Politik stellt? Nee, findet nicht statt. Das ist ja alles schon stellvertretend über unsere tollen Virologen gemacht, denen sich kein Vorwurf an Drosten an der Stelle errs, sondern was ist mit den Hörern? Was ist hier eigentlich los? Wozu haben wir denn diesen tollen öffentlich-rechtlichen Podcast, der uns hier und so? Naja, denn das will ich noch kurz abschließen, denn wir müssen hier nochmal auf die Politik draufhauen. Es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie wenig in der Politik passierte. Es ist, es fühlt sich ja fast an, wie März 2020 gerade politisch gesehen. Es ist ja null Fortschritt in irgendeiner Linie da. So und die Lisa Federle, auch so ein übersehendes Geschöpf, muss man ganz traurigerweise sagen. Denn ja, wir haben alle gefeiert als Drosten und Mai am gleichen Tag von Frank-Walter Steinmeier das Bundesverdienstkreuz bekam. Und wir haben irgendwie nicht mitbekommen, dass da auch eine Notärztin die selbe Auszeichnung bekam, damals im November, glaube ich, nämlich Lisa Federle, die in Tübingen unter Boris Palmer, und zwar zuerst auch gegen den Widerstand von Boris Palmer, dieses Wir schützen ja mal die Pflegeheime in Tübingen organisiert hat. In Tübingen sind es grandios gute Zahlen. Das muss man hier noch mal ausdrücklich sagen, denn es kam, nachdem die Story erst aufkam, Ende des Jahres, so ein bisschen, ne, das stimmt ja alles gar nicht, da Boris Palmer Quatsch erzählt. Da muss man immer ganz genau unterscheiden. Das gilt übrigens auch für Rostock gerade. Es gibt immer die Stadt und dann gibt es den Landkreis und der Bürgermeister ist nun mal nur für die Stadt zuständig. Ja, auch in Tübingen gibt es einen Landkreis, in dem es genauso scheiße zugeht wie überall, sonst in Deutschland. Und es ist in Rostock auch so. Da gibt es auch einen Landkreis Rostock, in dem der Bürgermeister nichts zu sagen hat, wo es schlecht läuft. Aber in der Stadt Rostock und in der Stadt Tübingen läuft es richtig gut. Also da gibt es diese ganzen Todesfälle nicht und da hat man auch die Pflegeheime abgesichert bekommen. Und jetzt stellt sich hier die Frage, wie ist denn das gelungen? Gegen welche Widerstände eigentlich? Und Lisa Federle war hier im Fernsehen bei Lanz am 6. Januar und hat das mal berichtet. Wir hören uns mal zwei Clips davon an. Zum einen reflektiert sie, wie war das eigentlich damals, im März, als noch keiner Bescheid wusste und sie trotzdem schon gehandelt hat.
Das ist ganz genauso gemein, wie ich es gesagt habe, dass die Politik einfach viel zu lange gebraucht hat. Zum Beispiel mit den Impfdosen keine Frage. Sie haben zu lange gebraucht, um sich zu entscheiden und dann einzukaufen, aber auch mit Tests. Ich habe im März angefangen zu testen und im April habe ich gekämpft, dass wir die Altersheime testen dürfen. Ich habe die Antwort bekommen, klipp und klar, die Kosten werden nicht erstattet bei Patienten, die keine Symptome haben, und sie können dann ja vor das Sozialgericht gehen.
Von wem haben Sie diese Antwort bekommen? Von Herrn Lucha?
Das habe ich vom Sozialministerium bekommen. Aber auch von der Kassenärztlichen Vereinigung. Damals gab es noch keine Lösung dafür.
Also die Politik ist zu ihr hin gesagt, ich helfe ihr nicht. Sie können ja versuchen, die Hilfe einzuklagen, aber viel Spaß, Rechtswege dauern lang. Das ist sozusagen Verweis auf März 2020. Jetzt spülen wir mal die Zeit nach vorne. Es ist Januar 2021. Was hat sich eigentlich getan? Wer hilft ihr denn heute?
Ich kann es Ihnen zeigen, ich habe X Anmeldungen von Leuten, die sagen, wir würden gerne helfen. Ein Beispiel, es muss ja nicht immer ein Mediziner sein. Die Band von Dieter Thomas-Gun, die begleitet uns seit Ende November. Die machen die ganze Administration, die schreiben die Namen auf bei den Schnelltests, sie bauen uns das auf, kostenlos, unentgeltlich. Sie sagen, sie haben das Gefühl, sie haben Sinn im Leben gerade. Sie hocken zu Hause, haben nichts zu tun. Und da gibt es massig Menschen, die so denken. 100 Prozent. Man muss die nur herholen. Und man muss mit ihnen reden und man muss sie einbinden. Und deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass das das riesige Problem ist. Man hätte es noch viel früher beginnen müssen. Und das ist das, was mich so ärgert.
So neun Monate später kriegt sie von Lanz die Frage, wer hilft ihr denn heute? Der Staat? Nee, die Band von Dieter Thomas-Gun.
Tja, das lässt das Schlagerherz höher schlagen.
Richtig.
Zum einen, zum anderen wissen wir, wie viele Menschen arbeitslos geworden sind, wie viele Studenten ihre Mini-Jobs verloren haben. Also es ist keineswegs so, als würden sich nicht gerne Leute für so etwas engagieren und etwas Geld verdienen auch dann dadurch. Und auch das ist ein extremes Versäumnis, dass man das nicht macht. Und dass man auch damit, wie sie das sagt, etwas Sinnstiftendes gibt, Leuten, die jetzt gerade wenig zu tun haben, die einen Lagerkoller bekommen. Hier in diesem ewigen Lockdown. Und das ist einfach ein kolossales Politikversagen. Man kann das nicht anders sagen. Das weiß ich auch nicht, wie man das schönreden soll. Und wenn man das wirklich jetzt auf diese Perspektive sieht, neun Monate, es lässt natürlich auch vermuten, wie wir mit anderen Krisen umgehen werden. Also das ist ja jetzt...
Das ist ja offenbar.
Ja.
Was ist, wenn wir eigentlich alle politischen Felder gerade super ackern, wie Corona? Nicht nur den Flughafen in Berlin, sondern wirklich grundsätzlich mal alles. Was ist, wenn eigentlich alles gerade so schlecht läuft? Und es führt allerdings zu witzigen Momenten, denn bei Anne Will treffen sich üblicherweise Politiker, die dann miteinander im Streit sind. Und das läuft immer sehr nach Drehbuch und so weiter. Sehr formal ab. Da weiß jeder genau, wo er den anderen pieksen muss. Und dass sich die Moderatorin mal selbst einmischt und sagt, ne, also jetzt haben sie wirklich Quatsch erzählt, ist schon besonders. Volker Bouffier hat sich hier diese Klatsche abgeholt.
Wir haben längst bei uns die Tests. Jeder, der ins Alten Heim als Besucher will, wird getestet. Nein, das ist leider nicht so. Diejenigen, die dort arbeiten, werden zweimal in der Woche getestet. Das machen wir alles. Vielleicht kann man noch viel mehr machen. Aber ich glaube, man muss wenigstens anerkennen, was geschieht. Aber zurück zu diesem, worum es jetzt eigentlich geht.
Man muss das auch wirklich... Volker Bouffier sieht, spricht und denkt, wie... Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll. Ich habe mal den 103-jährigen Juppe Hestas auf der Bühne erlebt. Er wirkte frischer.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen... Es hat einen gewissen Stil, aber man sieht sich auch schnell satt daran. Das ist bei Winfried Kretschmann... Man denkt immer, das kostet so viel Arbeit, nur zu reden. Ich traue dir nichts zu. Die rangehensweise meine zumindest. Christiane Wopen als vorletzter Clip. Christiane Wopen ist die Vorsitzende des Europäischen Ethikrats, der die EU-Kommission berät, wie der Deutsche Ethikrat die Bundesregierung usw. Sie hat dieses Testproblem aufgegriffen bei Illner am 21. Also vor wenigen Tagen.
Es gibt beispielsweise differenzierte Teststrategien, auch Schnellteststrategien, die zu Hause angewendet werden können, die nicht ein diagnostisches Testen sind. Das ist dieses Missverständnis, weswegen dann immer kommt, die sind ja nicht genau genug oder so. Das ist kein diagnostisches Testen, das ist ein epidemiologisches Testen. Das heißt, möglichst viele zu finden, die infektiös sind. Nicht nur alle die, die infiziert sind, sondern vor allen Dingen die, die infektiös sind, damit die dann natürlich idealerweise auf der Grundlage auch von Vereinbarungen mit dem Arbeitgeber etc. sofort zu Hause bleiben können. Und damit Infektionsketten überhaupt nicht erst losgehen oder jedenfalls rechtzeitig abgebrochen werden. Und davon haben wir zu wenig? Davon haben wir massenweise zu wenig. Diese ganze Strategie wird seit Monaten propagiert, aber geblockt. Also die kommt in der Politik nicht kraftvoll an, sagen wir mal so.
Massenweise zu wenig ist natürlich sehr schön, denn es stimmt. Es ist massenweise zu wenig. Also es gäbe kein Problem, Europa mit 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Milliarden Schnelltests zu versorgen. Das Herstellen ist kein Problem, das Verschicken, ja, ok. Aber da muss halt, ich meine, die Briefkästen sind...
Und auch da hatten wir neun Monate Zeit. Das ist auch ganz amüsant, wenn man manches dann so liest, auch von Journalisten, so als seien das jetzt unglaubliche Produkte, die ganz, ganz schwer herzustellen. Also ich würde sagen, massenweise Rolex-Uren würde schwierig werden. Ja, da gibt es eine Limitierung, und die sind deswegen auch dann in Krisenzeiten schnell ausverkauft. Also die könnten jetzt auch sagen, wir produzieren ein bisschen mehr. Die wollen das natürlich aus Gründen nicht. Aber die könnten jetzt nicht sagen, wir machen mal eine Million Rolex-Uren. Das wird nicht möglich sein. Aber man kann das doch einfach mal übertragen auf andere Tests, auf andere Produkte dieser Art, die wir haben. Schwangerschaftstests. Genauso auch, wie man bei den Masken immer sagte, ja, ist so schwierig zu produzieren. Wie viele Millionen Windeln werden in Deutschland täglich vollgemacht? Und da gibt es nie Lieferengpässe. Das heißt, wir sind ja in einer hochmodernen Wirtschaft, wo das überhaupt kein Problem ist, so etwas dann innerhalb von neun Monaten zu ermöglichen. Hätte man auf Frau Federle gehört, dann hätte man das ab Mai schon in großen Stile und wahrscheinlich ab Juni dann wirklich massenhaft haben können.
Ja, man kann sich hier auch, ich sag's nochmal, keine Angst vor Verschuldungstheorien, aber es gibt auch Corona-Profiteure. Die CDU liegt gerade bei 40 Prozent und Apple bei zwei Milliarden Euro. Und wir sehen alle, wie die Bitcoin, äh, Bitkom, Bitcoin auch, aber Bitkom, wie die Propaganda gerade läuft mit hinsichtlich Homeoffice und so weiter. Also hier ist einiges in Bewegung, und da sollte man sich das ruhig mal genauer anschauen.
Und ich finde, sollte die Opposition das alles mal erkennen. Also wenn noch irgendjemand, wenn noch irgendjemand Rot-Rot-Grün wirklich möchte und forcieren möchte, dann würde ich sagen, hier sind die Themen. Da sind die Themen, da sind auch die Vorwürfe, die zu machen sind. Und das kann ruhig auch drastisch werden. Fleischhauer hat das in der Kolumnie ja sehr stark gesagt mit den Impfungen. Man darf auch noch mal dran erinnern, Aufgabe von Politikern Schaden vom Volk abzuwenden und so weiter. Also das könnte man wirklich einmal, wenn man denn möchte, politisieren. Passiert natürlich nicht so stark, weil man auch in Koalitionen in Bundesländern ist. Und dann hat man dann jemanden wie Winfried Kretschmann da. Oder hat jetzt auch hier zum Beispiel in Rheinland-Pfalz natürlich auch eine große Desorganisation. Wäre dann sogar noch von den Pressereferenten angeschrieben, wie ich mir das dann erlauben könnte, so kritisch zu sein. Es läuft doch alles gut und sie würden wirklich viel arbeiten.
Ja, dann schiebe ich jetzt noch einen neuen vorletzten Clip ein. Opposition. Christian Lindner gefällt mir gerade ziemlich gut. Auch weil die Grünen gerade ausfallen, muss man echt sagen. Die Grünen fallen gerade aus, Christian Lindner versucht zumindest rhetorisch noch mal so den einen oder anderen Punkt zu landen. Hier bei Anne Will am 70.
Die beklagenswerten Sterbefälle und wir sind da noch nicht weitergekommen. Teststrategien, FFP2-Masken kamen zu spät. Deshalb haben wir da die hohe Zahl von schwersten Krankheitsverläufen Sterbefälle. Das ist der erste Punkt. Der zweite Punkt. Insgesamt die Testkapazitäten auszuweiten. Also beispielsweise hätte ich nichts dagegen gehabt, vor Beginn dieser Sendung einen Schnelltest zu machen, um Handlungssicherheit zu haben für alle Beteiligten. Ich habe ihn gemacht, unsere Fahrer, unser Team und so. Ich wäre bereit gewesen, wieder dieses Schreckliche da oben in die Nase gehabt zu haben. Das ist aber nur ein Beispiel, das ist kein Vorwurf. Da haben wir, um Handlungssicherheit im Alltag zu bekommen, noch etwas nicht ausgeschöpft.
Das ist kein Vorwurf, aber ich finde auch, man kann da mal ordentlich draufhauen.
Und da kann man ja auch sehen, es gibt ja Tests. Also Anne Will sagt, sie hat eingemacht, die Fahrer haben eingemacht. Und da kommen wir halt auch in eine Zwei-Klassen-Gesellschaft rein, wenn es dann für solche Leute natürlich jederzeit möglich ist, irgendwas zu verwirklichen. Lanz, erzähl doch auf, was macht da gerade, dreht eine Doku auf Schweden oder so, in Schweden. Und jetzt versucht man, irgendwas von, wir sind alle gleich zu erzählen. Nein, wir haben bereits eine Zwei-Klassen-Gesellschaft produziert, dadurch, dass Leute einen Zugang haben zu diesen Schnelltests und andere haben ihn nicht, müssen auf wichtige Geschäfte verzichten, haben große Umsatzeinbußen plus die ganzen psychologischen Folgen, die das hat, während andere, nämlich das elitäre 2-3%, die können sich weiterhin mit diesen Schnelltests durchwurschteln. Und da bin ich jetzt auch soweit zu sagen, die kriegen auch den guten Impfstoff.
Die kriegen auch den guten. Und das erinnert mich nur, ich will es jetzt nicht nochmal spielen als Clip, aber weil wir uns im Fernsehpodcast schon maßlos darüber aufgeregt haben, die CDU in Person Paul Ziemiak hat gerechtfertigt, dass sie einen Parteitag in der Halle machen, wenn auch nicht mit allen Delegierten, aber es war trotzdem ein Parteitag in der Halle mit Präsidium und so weiter, dass sie ja alle geschnelltestet wurden, wo man sich fragt, ja wieso durftet ihr denn? Wieso darf denn nicht das Museum Ludwig, die Schirn und das Städel sagen, wir wollten alle geschnelltestet, also machen wir hier CDU-Parteitag Schiffre, also machen wir hier halt eine Ausstellung. Also in der Ansicht, die nehmen sich da ganz schön was raus, weil das ist die Partei, die es verbietet, die es allen anderen verbietet und dann selber einen CDU-Parteitag durchführt. Gut, Opposition ist, wir haben es vorhin schon gesagt, vor allem auch Aufgabe von uns Bürgern. Entsprechend, und das mache ich nachher noch mal, sage ich, gebe ich das letzte Wort hier, Serdar Samuncu, denn wenige Lichtblicke in unserem traurigen Pandemieleben finde ich dann doch ab und zu mal ein guter Podcast, zum Beispiel von ihm.
Ich habe ihn ja auch angefangen zu hören.
Und wie ist heute dein Eindruck?
Und ich bin sehr überrascht. Also ich bin wirklich, also positiv überrascht. Ich höre das durch, bin sehr froh, wie schön freiweg von der Leber da gesprochen wird, aber auch wie klug und reflektiert. Und es macht großen Spaß. Ich hatte zuletzt dann irgendwie Samuncu noch mal erlebt, dass er irgendwie anfängt zu singen. Und dann dachte ich, oh Gott, das muss aber wirklich nicht sein. Aber dieser Podcast liegt den beiden, glaube ich, sehr.
Ja, genau, also sehr, dass Samuncu immer im Dialog mit Florian Schröder. Er macht auch so Monologe irgendwie beim Radio, Blaustunde und sowas. Das meine ich jetzt nicht, höre ich auch nicht. Aber dieser, dieser, dieser, wie soll man sagen, Samuncu Monologe im Gespräch mit Florian Schröder. Und da fielen hier diese 44 Sekunden raus.
Warum geht da auch nicht der Staat hin und sagt so, wir versorgen jetzt alle flächendeckend mit den notwendigen Masken, mit den Schnelltests. Heute kostet eine Packung mit Schnelltests, Florian, 200 Euro. Und da sind 20 Schnelltests drin. Warum ist das so teuer? Warum schreitet der Staat dann nicht ein und sagt, pass mal auf, Freunde, wir machen das jetzt so, dass jeder 50 Schnelltests zu Hause hat, die meinetwegen 50 Cent kosten sollen. Oder wir bauen Corona-Zentren auf, Schnelltestzentren, wie das in Köln zum Beispiel unterhalb der Langsess Arena ist, wo man kostenlos, nicht für 29, 90 Euro, die man dann dem Hersteller der Schnelltests in die Tasche erwirtschaftet, sondern kostenlos jedem Bürger anbietet, der es möchte, einen Schnelltest zu machen.
Punkt.
Das Gleiche gilt für Nahverkehr.
Ganz richtig.
Ganz richtig. Es ist ein Drama. Es ist wirklich ein großes Drama. Wir hätten hier überhaupt weder so viele Tote noch diesen ganzen Lockdown und so weiter. Es hätte uns alles erspart bleiben können, wenn wir nur die Möglichkeit hätten, uns morgens neben dem Zeilen Nase putzen, einfach mal kurz eine Diagnose selbst geben zu können.
Aber gut, ich will noch zwei Gedanken äußern. Man fragt sich ja, warum wird das auch journalistisch erst so spät oder so wenig aufgegriffen? Auch mit den Impfungen. Da kam erst der Spiegel. Dann hat die Bild, muss man ja fast sagen, dankenswerterweise auch gesagt, wir müssen darüber berichten und haben das größer gemacht. Das sind ja eigentlich Hauptstadtjournalisten, die das doch täglich alles mitbekommen. Auch diesen Wahnsinn mit den Schnelltests. Diese ganzen Debatten darum. Die hören ja auch alle den Podcast. Und wieso sind sie nicht in der Lage, auch das Ganze einmal dann im Großen zu sehen und dann auch solche Forderungen mit einfließen zu lassen, in ihre Kommentare und so weiter? Und ich glaube, wir haben es hier mit etwas zu tun, was man aus der Filmrezeption kennt. Erstmal haben wir es damit zu tun, was es generell immer häufiger im Hollywoodfilm zu beobachten gibt, aber generell im Film, die Nahaufnahme. Wir sind immer mehr dicht dran, treten immer seltener zurück. Das heißt aber, wenn man nur dicht dran ist, dann kann man den Kontext nicht sehen, dann verliert man das große Ganze aus den Augen. Und das braucht man eben, um zu erkennen, es geht jetzt nicht darum, 15 Kilometer regel, zwei Leute raus, drei Leute dürfen miteinander spazieren gehen, sondern man müsste tatsächlich die großen Linien erkennen. Und die eine Linie wäre Schnelltest, die andere wäre FFP2-Maske und, und, und. Plus Impfungen sicherlich der größte Procken. Und dann muss man sich ein bisschen aus diesem Tagesgeschäft gedanklich auch mal verabschieden, auch wenn man das täglich rezipiert, und mal einen Schritt zurücktreten und sagen, ja, aber was bedeutet das denn eigentlich, wenn da jetzt ein schlechterer Impfstoff kommen soll? Oder wenn es jetzt doch noch mal drei Monate dauert? Ich glaube, dass ganz viele Medienleute und auch viele Politiker dazu nicht in der Lage sind, auch sehr viele Talkshow-Moderatoren, ich gucke das wirklich gar nicht, weil ich das überhaupt nicht aushalte, da kriege ich sofort die Kratze. Also, die kriegen das nicht hin. Etwas anderes, was man aus dem Film kennt, ist, dass es Narrative gibt, die wiederholt werden. Es gibt immer so ein paar Geschichten, die funktionieren immer. Und wenn sich ein Narrativ mal eingeschliffen hat, dann wird es reproduziert und auch vom Publikum gotiert. Und das große Narrativ der Krise im Sommer war, hat die Bundesregierung nicht toll gearbeitet. Sparen, der könnte auch Kanzler, wir sind super aus der Krise gekommen. Das mag damals auf dem Kenntnisstand, den man hatte, richtig gewesen sein, vielleicht sogar. Zumindest wusste man es nicht besser. Man hätte es aber eigentlich auch schon damals besser wissen können. Nur jetzt funktioniert dieses Narrativ an keiner Stelle mehr. Und jetzt muss man mal in einen neuen Film übergehen und sagen, ich gucke mir jetzt nicht immer nur die Fortsetzung an, sondern wir brauchen jetzt einen neuen Film. Und dazu ist man momentan nicht bereit. Das ist mein dritter Gedanke dazu. Ich glaube, dass wir in der Opposition momentan so wenig Kritik erleben und dass wir auch in der Gesellschaft so wenig Kritik erleben, haben wir den Covid-Ioten zu verdanken. Die waren nämlich wirklich nützliche Idioten insofern, als Kritik an der Bundesregierung momentan ganz stark mit, ja, das sind Corona-Leugner und so weiter, immer noch verbunden wird und immer noch viele Linke auch glauben, wir müssen uns jetzt schützend vor die Bundesregierung stellen und alles beklatschen, weil die ja von den Rechten so böse angegriffen werden. Nein, man kann auch von einer anderen, zum Beispiel von einer vernünftigen Position, wie wir sie hier ein bisschen jetzt ausgebreitet haben, Kritik an den politischen Prozessen und Maßnahmen üben. Und das hat man sich so ein bisschen vom Leib gehalten. Dann auch in gewisser Weise können Spahn, Merkel und Co. dankbar sein, dass es die Covidioten gab. Sonst würde nämlich mal der Blick auf das gelenkt werden, worum es hier eigentlich geht. Und dann sehen die sehr, sehr schlecht aus mit dem, was sie getan haben. Wir blicken jetzt zunächst mal auf das große Ganze. Und dann gehen wir zu etwas Kuriosem Kleinen, das sich aber dann doch als etwas sehr viel Größeres herausstellt. Das klingt jetzt alles sehr verklausuliert, aber es soll um Handel gehen. Es soll um Wirtschaft gehen, um E-Commerce. Und wir steigen aber mal ganz hoch in den Bergen an. In Davos gab es das Weltwirtschaftsforum in diesem Jahr nur digital. Das heißt, man traf sich dort nicht. Da saß nur Klaus Schwab und schaltete sich sehr namhafte Regierungsführer zu. Zum Beispiel Präsident Macron sprach da. Und das ist dann in der Regel ja so, dass die Oberhäupter, sage ich mal, sich dort vorstellen, mit einer 20- 30-minütigen Rede ein bisschen so vermessen, wo geht die Weltwirtschaft hin, was ist passiert? Und danach gibt es dann noch so ein kleines Frage-Antwort-Spiel. Und das hören wir uns jetzt mal ganz kurz an. Nämlich wird da Macron von Schwab gefragt, wie ist denn das jetzt mit der Digitalisierung? Und ich habe das absichtlich gewählt als kleinen scherzhaften Einstieg. Denn wir wissen ja, was passiert, wenn man bei einer Online-Konferenz nach der Digitalisierung fragt. Ja, da ist der Präsident dann mal kurz weg. Er kam allerdings dann wieder. Also sehr schön, man spricht Digitalisierung an und schon versagt das Ganze. Ansonsten hat das aber sehr gut funktioniert. Aber man muss sagen, die Reden waren nicht übermäßig interessant. Also das ist schon nochmal etwas anderes, wenn einfach jetzt ein Präsident oder eine Kanzlerin vor einer Webcam sitzt und da irgendetwas vorträgt. Oder ob man wirklich dort ist und auch in einer ganz anderen Weise im Licht der Öffentlichkeit steht. Denn diese Reden haben sich natürlich nur ganz wenige Leute im Internet überhaupt angesehen. Das war jetzt ein Event, damit man es irgendwie gemacht hat. Aber tatsächlich viel, viel Wichtiges gab es da nicht. Eher dann auch erschreckendes zu hören. Oder es gab sehr viel Selbstlob. Aber diese Frage beantwortet Macron natürlich trotzdem. Was ist dann jetzt mit der Digitalisierung? Und was ich interessant finde, ist jetzt, dass er da schon mal einen ganz großen Schritt in die Zukunft tut und über Quantencomputer spricht.
Und neben der AI-Revolution, wird es auch eine quantum revolution geben.
Und durch die Computerspürung wird unsere Industrie sehr viel verändert, indem wir die Industrie der Sensoren in der Aeronautik, der Zivilen Industrie und so weiter machen.
Die current pandemic, zum Beispiel.
Die Floskeln, die seit 15 Jahren da immer kommen. Ich frage mich, hat Frankreich überhaupt da skin in the game, wie man so schön sagt? Denn die scheinen ja ganz schön abgemeldet zu sein, auf sehr vielen Feldern. Die ganze Impf-Blamage jetzt mit Sanofi scheint sie auch sehr mitgenommen zu haben.
Ja, es war auch eine sehr blasse Rede von Macron, sicherlich auch, weil er überhaupt keinen Rückhalt erfährt für seine Europa-Idee. Wir haben die im Salon mal vorgestellt mit diesem sensationellen Interview. Man muss aber sagen, was er hier erzählt, ist doch ziemlicher Unfug. Das Problem war ja jetzt gerade nicht die Technik. Das haben wir jetzt in der vergangenen Stunde herausgearbeitet, sondern es lag nicht daran, dass man nicht genügend Daten hatte und dass alles deshalb nicht schnell genug ging, sondern es lag an einem fehlenden politischen Willen. Und das ist so eine schöne Sache, dass man jetzt immer mit der Technik sagt, dann können wir das lösen. Also das ist wirklich, wie Morozov meint, so ein Solutionismus. Und da würde ich sagen, nee, auch mit Quantencomputern werden wir keinen Schritt weiter, wenn politische Entscheidungen so ablaufen, wie sie das gerade tun. Dann haben wir zwar die Daten, aber die Daten haben wir ja. Du hast ja jetzt Beispiele gebracht, das wissen wir seit zehn Wochen, das wissen wir seit drei Monaten, und trotzdem passiert nichts. Das heißt, wenn die Quantencomputer da noch schneller sind und wir haben dann Daten innerhalb von Millisekunden, ja, solange aber Volker Bouffier einfach drüber redet, auch auf Einwände der Moderatorin Anne Will überhaupt nicht mehr eingelten, und ich habe das immer so gemacht, und außerdem lasse ich mich jetzt hier nicht von einer Frau unterbrechen, solange der Modus so ist, hilft uns auch kein Quantencomputer. Also, dass man nur so zum Einstieg, aber er spricht auf jeden Fall etwas an. Es gibt natürlich eine unglaubliche Beschleunigung, und wie wichtig diese Beschleunigung ist für ein Thema, das wir jetzt am Ende dann besprechen, das behalten wir mal so im Hinterkopf. Hören aber jetzt noch mal ganz kurz, Merkel. Merkel hat sich auch eigentlich keinen Millimeter wegbewegt. Sie hielt, glaube ich, die Rede genau an dem Tag, als sie mal so einen Testballon durch Helge Braun starten ließ, ist die Schuldenbremse vielleicht doch etwas, was man jetzt mal so ad acta legen sollte, obwohl er dann danach auch gleich wieder bekannte, nein, nein, ich liebe die, ich will die eigentlich nur noch besser machen. Aber hier Merkel noch mal ganz auf dem schwarze Nulltrip. Das erklärt sie noch mal in ihrer Rede in Davos.
Wir haben ein gutes Fundament in Deutschland gehabt, das sind die soliden Finanzen. Und so konnten wir doch entschlossen handeln, unseren Unternehmen helfen, den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern helfen.
Also sagt sie noch mal, wir haben viel gespart, deswegen können wir jetzt viel ausgeben.
Also was sie ja gerade behauptet, ist ja, wir leben von unserer Substanz, die wir uns vorher so toll gearbeitet haben. Nur die EZB hat eben 1, 8 Billionen Euro Pandemiehilfe und die EU-Kommission hat ja dann mit Merkels Hilfe noch mal 750 Milliarden draufgelegt. Da hätte man jetzt auch die 100 Milliarden oder wie auch immer. Das ist ja auch aus diesem Geld. Also es ist ja nicht wirklich die deutsche Substanz oder sowas. Sondern ja, man hat halt eine Schuldenquote von irgendwie 65 auf 71 oder so. Aber es hätten ja auch genauso gut 81 auf 85 oder wie auch immer. Das ist so sinnlos, überhaupt noch so darüber zu sprechen.
Und noch mal ein kleines Selbstlob an die eigene Politik jetzt von Merkel.
Wir fühlen uns bestätigt in unserer Forschungspolitik. Seitdem ich Bundeskanzlerin beginnt, haben wir beständig unsere Forschungs- und Entwicklungsausgaben gesteigert.
Ja, leider ist das Geld da nicht abgeflossen, weil die Bürokratie und wie auch immer, sie hat Geld zur Verfügung gestellt.
Und thank God, dass wir das Paul-Ehrlich-Institut auch noch haben und dass Drosten auch hier bei uns noch im Land ist, muss man ja fast sagen. Nicht, dass er woanders auch, da hätte er auch woanders noch einen Job gefunden.
Genau, wenn sie sagt, die wurden irgendwelche Finanztöpfe vergrößert und so weiter. Seit sie im Amt ist, das meint seit 2005, also die letzten 16 Jahre, ist jeder einzelne Ministerhaushalt mindestens um 100 Prozent gewachsen. Da hat sich alles verdoppelt. Jürgen Lauber hat es die Merkelrampe beschrieben. Wir haben ein Absenken von allen möglichen Spitzensteuerbeträgen. Es wird alles, überall Einkommenssteuer wurde krass hochgefahren. Und damit wurden vor allem die Ministerien krass aufgebläht. Also wenn sie jetzt sagt, die sind jetzt sehr viel leistungsfähiger, also die Forschung ist leistungsfähiger, weil mehr Geld. Hätte man auch vermuten können, die Bundesregierung ist jetzt sehr viel leistungsfähiger, weil sie doppelt so groß ist, was Personal und Budgets in der einzelnen Ministeriumshäuser angeht, als 2005. Nur diese eins zu eins Effekte sehen wir nicht.
Sprechen wir dann jetzt über den Handel und da gibt es erstmal eine These von Merkel.
Und wir haben jetzt eine große Frage zu diskutieren und das ist die Frage, die die Welt sich stellen muss. Das Wort der Souveränität ist wieder in aller Munde. Lieferketten haben sich nicht bewährt in Zeiten der Pandemie zum Teil, sind zerbrochen.
Stimmt das so ganz? Also ja, am Anfang gab es da große Probleme, aber haben wir dann nicht gesehen, dass die Lieferketten eigentlich relativ gut funktioniert haben und auch schnell zum Beispiel FFP2-Masken uns herbrachten. Und auch heute sind ja noch die meisten FFP2-Masken, die wir so in Händen halten, eigentlich gefertigt in China. Also das ist momentan, glaube ich, etwas, was häufig behauptet wird. Aber ich werde da doch erstmal skeptisch. Also klar hat man es versäumt, gewisse Vorsorgen zu treffen, die einfach da sein müssten. Aber grundsätzlich hat ja der Handel relativ gut funktioniert für das, was da eigentlich der Fall war.
Vor allem muss man sagen, ja, es könnte sein, dass man jetzt nachblickend sagt, in den letzten Monaten sind viele deutsche Lieferketten, also von deutschen Firmen aufgebaut, die Lieferketten kaputtgegangen. Trotzdem ist ja die Versorgung in Deutschland nicht zusammengebrochen. Dann haben halt chinesische Firmen angebotsseitig auch Lieferketten aufgebaut, so dass es dann doch wieder funktioniert. Also hier springen doch relativ zügig dann doch Akteure in Lücken rein, die sich anbieten. Und ich glaube, sie hätte es hier ein bisschen spezifizieren müssen auf deutsches Schicksal, das hier betroffen ist, aber nicht so sehr Lieferketten allgemein. Also da redet sie ein bisschen zu abstrakt.
Warum macht sie das? Sie macht das wahrscheinlich auch, um ein bisschen doch auf Distanz zu China hier zu gehen, obwohl sie es ja war. Darauf kommen wir gleich. Die das Abkommen beschleunigt hat, damit Europa und China nun endlich auch ein Abkommen haben, bevor Biden im Amt ist. Und sie spricht jetzt mal hier doch etwas kritisch über Chinas Idee von Multilateralismus.
Der chinesische Staatspräsident hat ja sich gestern, und da sind wir auch einer Meinung, für den Multilateralismus ausgesprochen. Allerdings ist dann eine Frage, wo wir vielleicht noch nicht gleich übereinkommen, die Frage, was bedeutet es, wenn man unterschiedliche gesellschaftliche Modelle hat, wie weit darf man sozusagen sich das, was man einmischen nennt, wann beginnt Einmischung? Und wann beginnt sozusagen das Eintreten für elementare und nicht teilbare Werte? Und wenn der chinesische Präsident sich ja auch zu der Charta der Vereinten Nationen bekannt hat, dann spielt natürlich dort auch die Würde jedes einzelnen Menschen eine Rolle.
Ja, das ist eine Reaktion auf die Kritik, die es auch an Merkel direkt gab auf das Abkommen zwischen EU und China, dass man wieder einmal, wir kommen da gleich zu, die Fragen der Menschenrechte doch irgendwo in eine Fußnote verbannt hat. Ja, will man sich demnächst auch mal drum kümmern. Und hier versucht sie noch mal krass zu machen, ja ja, Multilateralismus heißt eigentlich auch, dass man einer universalistischen Idee verpflichtet ist. Und auf die lässt sich aber Präsident Xi nicht ein. Man kann natürlich auch wieder von chinesischer Seite sagen, na ja, wie universalistisch haben die USA reagiert, da und dort. Also da kann man auch natürlich sagen, dieser Universalismus findet da auch eher in Reden statt und dann doch nicht im Handeln. Aber das ist so ein bisschen, wo sie jetzt mal, glaube ich, versucht, die Wogen zu kletten wiederum, weil sie doch einige Kritik erfahren musste durch das Abkommen mit China jetzt.
Ja, man muss eh. Also da geht es jetzt um dieses, also du sprichst dieses Investitionsabkommen an, das bisher China sicher so abgekoppelt hat, im Sinne von wenn ihr bei uns auf dem Markt tätig sein wollt, dann müsst ihr aber auch Technologie mitbringen, hierher transferieren. Also geforscht wird dann auch hier. Und übrigens gehört immer auch ein Teil dieses Unternehmens dann uns, also irgendeine chinesische Firma muss damit rein. Und das haben sie jetzt so ein bisschen gelockert. Man kann jetzt auch so auf dem chinesischen Markt tätig sein, ohne dass man da gleich eine eigene Forschungseinrichtung und noch einen zweiten chinesischen Chef dabei hat und so und abgekoppelt davon. Und das war der Vorwurf Menschenrechtsstandards und so weiter. Und da muss man aber auch immer wieder sagen, die Amerikaner wollen diese ILO Arbeitsschutzstandards auch nicht. Da gibt es ja von der ILO, der Internationalen Labor Organization, also die so ein bisschen weltweit, ich glaube sogar UN-Deckmantel, Arbeitsschutz betreibt. Also wirklich so im Sinne von der Arbeiter, der Mine und so weiter. Und die haben Arbeitsschutzstandards wie zum Beispiel freie Gewerkschaftsbildung, keine Kinderarbeit und so weiter. Und da hat sich China mit mehr Punkten einverstanden erklärt als Amerika. Und das ist in Amerika als Gesamtkatalog immer noch, dass als am allerlängsten im Senat zur Ratifikation vorliegende, aber nicht ratifizierte Dokument, das liegt da seit 60 Jahren oder so, unbehandelt vom amerikanischen Senat, gilt dort also nicht wirklich. Und da hätte man sich schon immer mal fragen müssen, bei allen möglichen Freihandelsversuchen, wieso machen wir das mit Amerika so leichtfällig, ja, so CETA und der ganze Kram, und warum fällt uns das bei China immer wieder so schwer, oder umgedreht, warum fällt es uns in Amerika so leicht, auf Arbeitsschutzstandards zu verzichten, während wir in China immer diese Pseudo-Keule rausholen, bis wir dann doch die Abkommen machen, ohne Rücksicht auf irgendwas.
Ja, und Präsident Xi hat auch gesprochen in Davos und sagt hier mal was zu dieser Idee, jetzt Corona macht das ganz anders mit dem Multilateralismus.
Es hilft niemanden, die Pandemie als Entschuldigung dafür zu nehmen, um die Globalisierung zurückzudrehen und sich wieder abzuschoppen.
Ja, nochmal ganz klar gegen die Abschottungspolitik. Da hatten die es natürlich leicht mit Trump. Das wird jetzt unter Biden anders werden. Aber was ich jetzt sehr interessant fand, das war eigentlich das wirklich bemerkenswerte an Merkels schwachem Auftritt, ist, dass sie einmal ganz, ganz stark gegen die USA schießt. Nämlich zum Schluss dieses Gesprächs.
Aber ich sag mal zum Beispiel jetzt gar nicht China, sondern jetzt zum Beispiel die Vereinigten Staaten haben ein War Act in Kraft für die Export von Impfstoffen. Im Zweifelsfalle auch von wichtigen Zulieferkomponenten für Impfstoffe. Und das wird schon auch in Europa sozusagen unseren Urreflex stärken zu sagen, naja, also wenn dir dann irgendwas fehlt, was du jetzt noch brauchst in der Lieferkette für Medikamente oder Impfstoffe, dann wirst du schon gucken, dass du das auch bei dir zu Hause hinbekommen kannst.
Aber wir drohen doch auch gerade mit Exportbeschränkungen.
Ja, ja, aber sie macht das nochmal so deutlich. So jetzt gucken wir aber auch mal, wo wir bleiben. Also das war doch ein etwas anderer Ton gegenüber den USA. Das hätte man nicht erwartet, dass es jetzt mit beiden so kommt. Also sie hat sich natürlich sehr gefreut und von der Leyen strahlte ja regelrecht an. Sie in ihrer Davos-Rede über beiden sprach, aber man ist da vielleicht dann doch ein bisschen vorsichtiger. Und wir haben dieses Investitionsabkommen jetzt zwischen der EU und China. Und da können wir erst mal eine kurze Einschätzung hören von Mikko Huu-Otari, der sprach in der Tagesschau 24 darüber.
Nach fast sieben Jahren Verhandlungen haben sich die EU und Peking grundsätzlich auf ein Investitionsabkommen verständigt. Es sieht einen besseren Marktzugang für europäische Firmen in China vor und gleiche Wettbewerbsbedingungen für Unternehmen beider Seiten. Beim Klimaschutz soll das Abkommen für eine nachhaltigere Entwicklung sorgen. Darüber hinaus wurden auch grundlegende Standards der internationalen Arbeitsorganisation ILO beschlossen. Ich vertiefe das Thema an dieser Stelle mit Mikko Huu-Otari vom Mercator Institute for China Study. Wie bedeutsam ist denn diese Vereinbarung zwischen der EU und China?
Das ist ein wichtiges Abkommen. Das ist lange verhandelt worden. Die Fortschritte kommen mit Kosten und mit Risiken, aber es ist trotzdem erst mal anzuerkennen. Sie wissen, dass Marktzugang in China schwierig ist. China war und bleibt auch eine der geschlossenen Volkswirtschaften international. Da wurden jetzt neue Verpflichtungen eingegangen. Die versprechen, dass europäische Unternehmen mehr Zugang bekommen, auch wenn sie vor Ort dann gleichberechtigt operieren können. Da geht es um die Abschaffung von Technologietransfer. Da geht es auch um die Frage, ob man bei Subventionen beispielsweise gleichgestellt ist mit chinesischen Staatsunternehmen.
Ja, also erst mal ein wichtiges Abkommen. Ich glaube auch, und das ist auch nicht von der Hand zu weisen, dass ein engeres Agieren zwischen China und der EU notwendig ist, damit das überhaupt für Europa eine Zukunft hat. Also das ist total verrückt, dass jetzt viele sagen Nein, nein, wir hätten da jetzt Maximalforderungen stellen müssen und hätte China, die nicht anerkannt, dann hätten wir das halt nicht bekommen. Und jetzt gibt es natürlich Kommentare dazu, die sagen, na ja, China macht da zwar gewisse Zusagen, aber die sind eigentlich auf dem Papier nichts wert. So war das zum Beispiel zu hören im SWR von Steffen Wurzel, China-Korrespondent.
Obwohl China im November einen Freihandelspakt mit Australien unterschrieben hat, hat die Führung in Beijing zuletzt einen Handelskrieg gegen australische Unternehmen angezettelt, weil die Regierung in Canberra eine unabhängige Kommission zum Ursprung der Covid-19-Krise fordert. Auch das zeigt, Chinas Führung schert sich nicht um internationale Verträge, wenn die Politik eines anderen Staates ihren eigenen Interessen widerspricht. Deswegen ist das Abkommen zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt ein Fehler. Das ausgerechnet Deutschland das Abkommen so vehement vorangetrieben hat, gegen den Willen der künftigen US-Regierung und auch gegen große Zweifel aus Frankreich, Polen und dem EU-Parlament zeigt, wie wenig Rücksicht die Bundesregierung mit ihrer china-freundlichen Politik nimmt.
Ja, kann man natürlich so sagen, aber ich meine, wir haben ja im Salon über Shenzhen ausführlich gesprochen, was das da für eine Region ist. Und das spielte sich in den letzten 15 Jahren irgendwie dann ab. Und das sind diese 15 Merkel-Jahre. Und Merkel hat auf ihrem eigenen Parteitag bei der CEU nochmal darauf hingewiesen, als ich ins Amt kam 2005, da gab es noch kein iPhone und China war noch kleiner als wir volkswirtschaftlich. Und heute sind sie viermal so groß. Und jetzt muss man die Uhr noch ein bisschen nach vorne drehen.
Als Amerika. Und du hast es eben schon angesprochen, Amerika missachtet solche Standards auch. Und wir sind da noch gar nicht dabei, was die EU in Afrika macht. Du hast es ja mal sehr schön aufgeschlüsselt, was die Agrarsubventionen anbelangt, wem die eigentlich helfen. Und dass es keineswegs so ist, dass wir so moralisch guten Europäer, die Welt ernähren, sondern dass das aus anderen Gründen gemacht wird und die ihr Zeug nicht losbekommen, weil wir die EU haben. Also das so zu tun, als sei da jetzt einfach nur der Feind zu sehen, ist für mich absolut absurd. Aber das wird dann nochmal besonders stark gemacht von Reinhard Bütykhofer, von dem ich gar nichts mehr gehört hatte. Ich dachte, er sei einfach eingeschlafen in Brüssel. Aber hier ist er sehr munter und ist sehr gegen dieses Abkommen.
Also wir wollen uns andauernd weiterhin bemühen, das Ziel der Ratifizierung zu verfolgen. Das ist eine diplomatisch-höfliche Form zu sagen, ihr könnt uns mal kreuzweise, wir machen, was wir wollen. Und sie können irgendeinen Diplomaten fragen, der sich jemals mit solchen Fragen beschäftigt hat, er wird ihnen genau dasselbe sagen. Warum sagt man nicht, wir ratifizieren bis zum 1.1.2022? Wir haben mit Vietnam das selbe Problem gehabt und dort haben wir einen Stufenplan verabredet. Die Konvention muss sofort ratifiziert werden und die andere bis spätestens 2023. Das macht Sinn, das sind Nägel mit Köpfen. Das, was wir hier haben, ist ein wertloses Gerede.
Jetzt sagt die EU-Kommission allerdings, wenn sich Peking an diese Zusage nicht hält, dann kann das mit Strafzöllen, mit Sanktionen beantwortet werden. Also insofern hat Europa ja schon ein Machtmittel in der Hand.
Nein, das stimmt nicht. Das ist einfach nicht wahr.
Woraus schließen Sie das?
Das steht nirgends in diesem Vertrag.
Das heißt, an dieser Stelle ist diese Auskunft, die aus den EU-Kommissionskreisen kommt, unrichtig?
Ja, nichts genaues. Ich weiß mal nicht, was da los ist. Es ist aber sehr schön, dass er Vietnam da mit ins Spiel nimmt. Da würde ich sagen, da ist aber auch ein anderes Ungleichgewicht da. Vietnam hat da doch wahrscheinlich ein größeres Interesse, irgendwie mitspielen zu dürfen bei der EU, als wir das jetzt bei China haben. Und was einfach bei diesen ganzen Fragen so ausgeblendet wird, zumindest dann, also nicht intern, da wissen die das natürlich sehr genau, aber was gerne ausgeblendet wird in der Diskussion ist, es geht da einfach um das Ausspielen von Macht. Und wer mehr wirtschaftliche Macht hat, ist der Stärkere. Das sind die Gesetze, die dort vorherrschen. Und das geht hier nicht um irgendwelche tollen Werte, die vertreten werden. Es war auch ganz schön in der Tagesschau, wurde nochmal über Nord Stream 2 berichtet. Dann hatte erst Baerbock sich dagegen ausgesprochen. Und danach war dann irgendjemand von der CDU, glaube ich Hinterbänkler, der sagte dann auch, dass er dagegen sei. Und sagte dann diesen Satz, letztlich geht es um Werte. Und das stimmt halt nicht. Es geht um Geopolitik und man kann dieser oder jene Auffassung sein. Aber es geht nicht darum, dass hier tolle Menschenrechte oder so vertreten werden. Wenn man das auch noch mitbekommt in den Vertrag, dann nimmt man das gerne. Aber da macht sich die EU auch ständig schuldig. Und da braucht man mit sowas wie Werten eher nicht zu kommen. Also da stimmt schon der Carl-Schmidt-Satz, dieser ganz, ganz böse, wer von Menschenrechten sprechen will, betrügen.
Na, Werte spielen immer nur eine Rolle in den Gesprächen über Werte.
Ja, exakt. Und wir hören aber noch einmal Bütikova. Also er legt noch mal los.
Die Zugeständnisse fingen an, als China feststellen konnte, in Amerika ist Joe Biden zum Präsident gewählt worden. Und als sie anfingen, ernst zu nehmen, dass es vielleicht tatsächlich in Zukunft wieder zu einer vernünftigen transatlantischen Kooperation gegenüber China kommen wird. Da brach da eine gewisse Sorge aus, dass das vielleicht die eigenen Handlungsmöglichkeiten beschränken würde. Denn China hat es wunderbar ausgenutzt, dass Trump auf Bündnisse und Kooperation nichts gegeben hat. Und da wollte man einen Spaltkeil reinsetzen. Und dann hat man angefangen, den Europäern ein paar Angebote zu machen. Wenn das die Dynamik ist, warum nutzt man die Dynamik nicht weiter? Und sagt, dann reden wir jetzt erstmal auch mit beiden, sehen, wo wir gemeinsame Politik machen.
Aber das ist schon ein interessanter Punkt. Bisher hatten wir ja immer so diese, oh nee, Trump, das ist so viel Irrationalität, was will er als nächstes und so weiter. Jetzt sitzen die Chinesen genauso da, oh nee, jetzt arbeiten die wieder zusammen, was kriegen die wohl auf die Beine?
Und das ist jetzt, finde ich, aber sehr offen, ob das die richtige Entscheidung war, von der EU das jetzt zu machen, um beiden zu sagen, guck mal, wir können auch mit denen. Oder ob man jetzt China sagt, nee, wir warten jetzt, dann guck mal, wir können auch mit beiden. Also das läuft aufs Gleiche raus. Also das heißt, es ist immer so ein abwägendes Spiel damit. Und es kann, glaube ich, auch sehr viele Gründe geben, dass man dieses Abkommen jetzt geschlossen hat, um beiden unter Druck zu setzen, um zu sagen, guckt, sonst gehen wir dann noch weiter auf den asiatischen Raum zu. Und dann seid ihr abgehängt. Das heißt, man kann auch jetzt wieder Druck gegenüber der USA.
Was ich sehr gut finde.
Genau, und das ist einfach sehr wichtig. Und das ist natürlich für jemanden wie Bütikova überhaupt nicht denkbar, dass die EU auch in eine Verhandlungsposition kommt, wo sie der USA mal sagen kann, nee, machen wir so nicht mit. Und gerade da kann so etwas wichtig sein. Also man sieht, es ist, wie wir das schon häufig hatten, wenn wir über solche Abkommen sprachen, eine Gemengelage, in der es nicht ein einfaches Gut und Böse gibt. Und dort sind es eigentlich nur strategische Entscheidungen, es ist nur Taktieren. Und oft stellt sich dann erst im Nachhinein heraus, wie gut war was eigentlich. Ich erinnere daran, Amerika wollte unbedingt, dass China Teil der Welthandelsorganisation wird. Einige Jahre später, als China dann nicht mehr Junior-Partner war, sondern mächtiger wurde, hat man gesagt, ach du je, warum müssen die jetzt hier Mitglied sein? Das ist ja furchtbar. Was haben wir hier nur gemacht? Ja, so sind dann eben Entwicklungen. Die hat man dann nicht antizipiert, sondern man hatte in diese Allmachts-Fantasie geglaubt, dass man ewig der große Bruder für, die alle sein wird. Und dass die Chinesen selber so mächtig werden, haben sie nicht bedacht. Und das kann man aber jetzt nicht später den Chinesen vorwerfen. Ja, also das ist ja wirklich ungeheuer, dass eure Wirtschaft sich so gut entwickelt hat.
Ganz genau. Sehr gut. Darf ich noch von der Leyen kurz einschieben, bevor wir zu denen? Du hast mich ja darauf hingewiesen, dass Ursula von der Leyen dort auch eine Rede hielt. Und ich habe sie mir angehört, auch gedacht, wieso bin ich schon wieder der 3000er, der das runterlädt bei YouTube? Interessiert das denn niemanden, was die da diskutieren? Also scheint ja wirklich auf kaum Resonanz gefallen zu sein. Aber es, ich habe mich erinnert, wir haben letztes Jahr angefangen hier mit Ursula von der Leyen Screen Deal, großes Projekt, irgendwie sie neu im Amt, Pipapo. Jetzt ist ja ein Jahr rum. Sie hat alle ihre feierlichen Reportagen bekommen. Ein Jahr Ursula von der Leyen. Und ich war doch ein bisschen beeindruckt, wie unbeirrt sie jetzt einfach dabei geblieben ist, zu sagen, meine Damen und Herren, liebe Weltgemeinschaft, lieber Klaus Schwab, ja, wir haben Pandemie, aber wir haben auch nicht...
Ich rede übers Klima. Er hat wirklich fast nur übers Klima geredet.
Genau, und das fand ich doch ganz gut, denn wir haben auch dieses Jahr wieder, wir haben das im ersten Salon schon besprochen, Larry Fink's Black Rocks Brief an die CEOs dieser Welt und dieser Brief dreht sich wieder nur ums Klima. Also wir haben hier doch eine große Schiene an Klimawirtschaftspolitik oder Politikwirtschaft, die auch immer. Und es wird weiterhin übersehen. Ich könnte jetzt genau den gleichen Vorwurf wieder machen, wie letztes Jahr schon. Liebe linke Blase, liebe Klimaforscher, liebe Klimaschützer, schaut euch doch mal an, was die Politiker mit den Wirtschaftsbossen zusammen beim Klima gerade machen. Denn ihr verpasst da irgendwie was. Klar, man kann immer moralisch daneben stehen und auch tolle Ideen haben, aber es gibt eben auch eine Realität und die sollte man mitgestalten. Sonst ist das nämlich alles rendite Hoheitsgebiet von Black Rock. Aber gut, jedenfalls. Sie macht es genau auf dieser Larry Fink Linie. Es ist ganz erstaunlich, wie deckungsgleich die sich da mittlerweile sind, die großen riesigen größten Unternehmen und eben die großen politischen Einheiten.
To those who prefer the business case, here it is. More than half of global GDP is dependent on high functioning biodiversity and ecosystems. And it is from food to tourism, you just name it. And in the last World Economic Forum Global Risk Report, the top five global risks are all related to the environment.
Also die EU-Kommission, BlackRock und das World Economic Forum sind sich hier eigentlich. Wir brauchen jetzt ein neues Wirtschaftsmodell, eine neue Wirtschaft, neue Profitmöglichkeiten hinsichtlich. Ja, und das haben wir letztes Jahr besprochen. Genau die gleiche Argumentation kann man heute wieder aktualisieren. Es ist Richtung Klimaschutz und Umweltschutz und so weiter. Ansonsten bleibt nichts mehr zum Investieren da. Das ist die große Drohung, die hier für alle im Raum steht. Und sie hat das hier, sie hat es eben schon gesagt. Ich mache jetzt mal den Business Case. Ich bin zwar Politiker, aber ich rede euch jetzt mal das Wort. Und das hat sie hier nochmal vertieft.
Die zweite Frage ist interessant, weil du deine Initiative heute Abend erwähnt hast. Das ist sehr interessant für uns. Und wir tun das in zwei Wahlen. Erstens, wir erwerben grüne Bonds. Und das ist ein Rahmenwerk für Investitionen, das den Investoren helfen würde, die wissen, ob ein Projekt entstand, oder ob es mehr oder weniger grün-waschig ist, oder ob es sogar mit dem Umfeld verletzt.
Also in dieser Nullzinslage, in der wir gerade sind, in der Deflation droht und in Deutschland sogar schon da ist und die EZB sagt Zinsen, nie wieder, sagt sie hier einfach ja, also wenn ihr Zinsen haben wollt, erstens Green Bonds. Ihr kriegt zugesicherte Rendite. Wann hat es das schon mal gegeben? Vom Staat sozusagen, von der EU zugesichert. Dann wird es Steuermodelle geben, die ganz wo ihr ganz klar kognitiv lernen könnt. Das bringt jetzt Steuererleichterung, wenn man einfach mal die Umwelt nicht zerstört. Und als dritte ist CO2 wird bepreist. Also dieser ganze Zertifikatehandel und so weiter als wirkliche Renditequelle. Ich finde, das muss man sich in der deutschen Fridays for Future Blase und so weiter dann mal anschauen. Nicht immer nur die Forderung, ja, es ist noch nicht zu spät, blablabla, wissen wir alles, aber was die da gerade machen. Und da müsste man mal durchsimulieren. Hinsichtlich der Pandemie hat sie dann ein Bio-Defense-Programm vorgestellt, wie man sich politisch gegen diese Einflüsse der Natur, auf unser Leben währt. Das kann man natürlich irgendwie, klar ist das mal auf Viren und so, Bio-Defense fand ich irgendwie ein bisschen, und das, also Amerika macht Space Force und wir machen jetzt Bio-Defense. Jedenfalls kommt sie dann am Ende in der Fragestunde, also als dann Klaus Schwab noch mal die eine oder andere Frage hat, kommt sie noch mal darauf zu sprechen. Wer arbeitet da jetzt eigentlich wie miteinander? Und da sollten alle mal aufhorchen.
Meine Damen und Herren, von der Verteidigung unserer Demokratie bis zur Verteidigung unserer Natur, Europa hat alles zu gewinnen von dieser neuen Form der internationalen und sektralen Kooperation. Und wir werden uns von unseren Partnern aus der ganzen Welt, von Foundations-
Ja, das war ja der Punkt, der dich da auch getriggert hat. Public-Private-Partnership. In dem Sinne, dass man sich langsam fragt, wenn Unternehmen in der Bilanzsumme mehr auf die Waagschalen werfen als irgendwelche Länder auf der Welt, Apple oder so, die so tief verstrickt sind, da gibt es jetzt auch wieder Studien, wie viel, also sie hat ja eben aufgeschlüsselt, die Hälfte der volkswirtschaftlichen Wertschöpfung hängt von der Natur ab. Also ist Grund und Boden in gutem Zustand, hat man auch Flächen zur Verfügung und so weiter. Und wie ist das mit der Biodiversität, hinsichtlich Nahrungsmittel und Pipapo? Wie viel GDP oder BIP hängt eigentlich gerade davon ab, dass Google funktioniert, dass Google-Suchen zur Verfügung steht und so weiter. Und die Verstrickungen sind mittlerweile so tiefschöpfend, dass für sie es völlig normal ist zu sagen, also mit den CEOs dieser Welt bin ich auf Augenhöhe. Ich komme halt als Regierungschefin von Europa und dann treffe ich den Sundar P. Jai als Regierungschef von Google. Und dann vereinbaren wir irgendwas miteinander. Also da ist Davos schon das richtige Forum gewesen, weshalb Klaus Schwab so, ja cool, klingt irgendwie ganz gut.
Ich denke, dass das Geschäft heute ein Teil ist, wie die Regierung unserer Gesellschaft ist und in öffentlichen und privaten Partnerschaften arbeitet, um all diese Probleme zu beantworten.
Public Partnerships, das funktioniert, das ist gut, findet er gut, weil er vermittelt ja genau zwischen diesen Unternehmen und den Staaten. Das meint natürlich hier etwas bisschen anderes als das, was wir jetzt unter PPPs verstehen, wenn es mal wieder darum geht, irgendeinen Unsinn zu privatisieren.
Genau, wenn wir, was weiß ich, Denkmäler schützen.
Wenn Herr Ramsauer dann irgendwie sagt, da müssen wir nochmal hier private ranlassen.
Hier geht es um die große Linie. Und jetzt hören wir mal von der Leyen Macht ein Beispiel, wie man das Klima schützt mit neuen Privat, Public und so weiter zusammenarbeiten. Und wir hören uns das mal an und fragen uns, ist das noch Marktwirtschaft oder hat man sich hier in China orientiert?
Hydrogen. Und das Investieren in Hydrogen wird in der nächsten Generation EU vorgelegt. Wir haben eine europäische H-Wallien-Allianz eröffnet. Und mit dieser Allianz wollen wir den ganzen Hydrogen-Wallien-Kreis schauen. Also von der Produktion bis zur Distribution. Und wir sind die Investitionen in der Anzahl und auf der Wandel und bringen zusammen die Demande und die Anzahl auf europäischer.
Also während wir hier immer so, wir sind kapitalistisch, wir machen das marktwirtschaftliche, tritt man einfach auf auf den Markt, guckt man sich eine Lücke aus, bedient die. Und jetzt hat man aber in China gesehen, nee, man kann durchaus da zehn Windräder und wie auch immer hin stellen, so dass man irgendwie fünf Gigawatt Strom hat, also so im Verhältnis, was weiß ich, mehrer Atomkraftwerke. Braucht man aber eigentlich 3000 Kilometer weiter im Osten, also bauen wir einfach mal eine Stromleitung. Aber da bräuchte man Unternehmen für, soll man das jetzt ausschreiben oder gucken uns einfach mal an, wer zur Verfügung steht und sagen, ja, wir machen hier mal so private public irgendwas, könntet ihr mal uns, das Projekt sieht übrigens so und so aus, dann sagen die, ja klar, sind wir dabei. Also in der Ansicht, so wird das jetzt ja auch organisiert. Man hat halt so eine Angebotsseite, eine Nachfrage-Seite, dazwischen irgendwie tausend Unternehmen, die das so bedienen können, was da eine Lehrstelle noch da ist und dann die EU-Kommission, die dann so ein bisschen organisiert, die dann einfach so Puzzleteilmäßig dieses Ding zusammenbaut. Und man fragt sich ehrlich, was ist, wenn da jetzt jemand auf dem Markt auftritt, der vielleicht noch nicht in diesem Konglommarat drinne ist, aber dort zählt ein cooles Angebot, ja, das ist dann draußen. Da kann er dann nicht teilnehmen. Also in der Ansicht ist das schon eine ganz interessante Entwicklung, gegen die ich gar nichts habe. Also ich finde das schon...
Die interessant ist und zumindest ist es irgendeine Perspektive, denn dieses Gespräch zwischen Schwab und Merkel, das plätschert ja so aus und für Schwab ist ja ganz wichtig, dieser Stakeholder-Value-Ansatz. Und das ist ja auch eine Langfristigkeit und das kann man natürlich auch mit Ideen der Nachhaltigkeit verbinden. Ich bin da eher skeptisch, was das anbelangt zumindest, aber ist das mal irgendein Ansatz, der sagt, gut, so wie es jetzt gerade ist, ist es nicht gut? Und er spricht dann auch Merkel darauf an und Merkel weiß eigentlich gar nichts darauf zu sagen, außer dass sie sagt, ja, wir glauben ja an die soziale Marktwirtschaft und dann hilft er ihr noch quasi so, ja, aber Stakeholderansatz ist ja soziale Marktwirtschaft. Ja, also wenn das so ist, dann ist das ja schön und so, aber sie kann das gar nicht einordnen und will es auch gar nicht einordnen und will da gar keine Perspektive mal drauf bieten. Und das ist ja dann schon erfrischend, was hier mal geschieht, wie das nachher dann für die Kapitalfraktionen besonders gewinnbringend ist und uns eher wieder am Ende schadet. Das wird sich noch zeigen, aber zumindest ist das, glaube ich, ein Ansatz, mit dem man arbeiten kann und der nicht einfach nur so ein abstraktes Ziel sieht und sagt, da müssen wir hin und dann sieht man aber auch nur noch das Ziel. Das ist so ein bisschen das 1, 5 Grad Ziel und der R-Wert. Das sehe ich jetzt inzwischen so parallel, weil ich merke, dass dann gar nicht mehr so auf das konkrete politische oder auch auf die konkrete Situation eines Individuums gesehen wird, sondern man schaut dann nur noch, ist da irgendwie ein Wert eingehalten oder nicht? Und wir hatten, glaube ich, im ersten oder zweiten Salon einen Text, den hatte ich mitgebracht aus dem Merkur, wo auch gesagt wurde, na ja, Umweltschutz ist schon ein bisschen mehr als nur zu gucken, kommen wir da mit diesem 1 Grad Ziel, 1, 5 Grad Ziel hin, sondern das bedeutet noch sehr viel mehr, wenn wir das andere ausblenden und nur dieses Ziel vor Augen haben, dann verlieren wir ganz viel Natur. Und ich glaube, das kann man hier auch bei der Wirtschaft sagen. Man kann natürlich irgendein Maximalziel verfolgen. Und das ist ja auch gut, ein fernes Ziel zu haben. Aber dann die konkrete Ausgestaltung, die ist ja entscheidend. Und die bietet überhaupt erst die Möglichkeit der Mitgestaltung. Wenn sie auch NGOs ja zum Beispiel direkt mit anspricht.
Ja, sehr wichtiger Punkt. Klimaschutz und Naturschutz, die können sich ganz schön auf den Füßen stehen. Und jede Solarplatte braucht eine versiegelte Fläche. Also da geht manchmal nicht ganz einher. Sie will das alles miteinander verbinden. Wir sind mal gespannt. Das letzte Jahr war ja schon hochinteressant, ehrlich gesagt, was das so angeht. Mal gucken, was jeder dieses Jahr so zaubert, wenn jetzt auch so ein bisschen Erwachen aus Covid wieder mit reinspielt. Okay, Trollschuhe habe ich hier.
Wir bleiben bei der Wirtschaft. Also ich will das schon in, also das ist jetzt nicht einfach ein Bruch, sondern es ist eher jetzt eine Assoziation. Das lässt ja einen Podcast auch zu, dass man jetzt ein Thema mit dem anderen assoziiert und Themen assoziiert, die gar nichts miteinander erst einmal zu tun, haben scheinen. Ich habe dann aber gestern noch einen Aufsatz gelesen in den Plättern für deutsche und internationale Politik von Sven Hilbig. Alle gegen China, fragt er da, sehr lesenswert. Und ich will nur einen Absatz vorlesen. Und zwar heißt es da, wie sehr die Handelspolitik inzwischen vom Kampf um die Herrschaft in der digitalen Welt geprägt wird, zeigt sich bei den Auseinandersetzungen um die Gestaltung des E-Commerce in Handelsabkommen. Dieser über die Zukunft entscheidende Themenbereich erfährt bisher zu Unrecht viel zu wenig Aufmerksamkeit, was unter anderem auch fehlender Transparenz geschuldet ist. Dabei verhandeln schon seit zwei Jahren 86 WTO-Mitglieder, die sogenannten Freunde des E-Commerce unter immensem Zeitaufwand, aber fernab der Öffentlichkeit einen Entwurf für die Standards des digitalen Handels auf multilateraler Ebene. Freunde des E-Commerce, wenn man das googelt, findet man nur noch ein paar andere Aufsätze von Hilbig. Friends of E-Commerce, da findet man schon mehr. Und ja, die gibt es tatsächlich. Und da gibt es auch einige Dokumente, die man einsehen kann. Aber so genau ist einem dann gar nicht klar, was wird da verhandelt. Ich habe es dann mal bei YouTube eingegeben. Das ist sehr lustig, was dann passiert. Dann kommen nicht irgendwelche Sitzungen, die die dort abhalten, sondern dann sind lauter YouTuber, die sagen, ich habe hier einen ganz tollen Dropship-Store, so kannst du reich werden. Mach auch einen Online-Shop auf und dann kaufen bei dir Leute Waren, die du selbst nicht besitzt. Die sind irgendwo in China oder sonst wo. Die machen bei dir die Bestellung automatisiert. Wird das dann an das Lager gegeben und von dort wird es dann an den Kunden verschickt und du machst dann einen Gewinn von 80 oder 180 Prozent. Das ist ja etwas, was momentan bei YouTube floriert. Du bekommst auch immer Werbung zu angezeigt. Und wenn man jetzt mal darüber nachdenkt, also E-Commerce, da wird jetzt gerade schon verhandelt. Man sagt, das ist extrem wichtig. Man verhandelt natürlich auch immer auch, weil die Wirklichkeit sich schon anders gestaltet. Weil man einfach sieht, okay, es wird hier schon ganz viel hin und her verschickt. Klar, wir haben Amazon oder wir haben auch Alibaba. Kann man ja hier auch nutzen. Und wir haben andere Möglichkeiten, jetzt auch aus dem asiatischen Raum uns was zu verschicken. Aber Handel bedeutet so viel mehr als das, was wir so an den großen Plattformen sehen, die natürlich auch da alle mitverhandeln und ihre Interessenvertreter dort haben. Und dann bin ich und deswegen sage ich assoziativ, nachdem ich das hier über die Investitionsabkommen und so weiter mir angehört habe, auf eine Doku gestoßen, die 2020 im Sommer vom WDR ausgestrahlt wurde. Da gibt es ja diese Reihe Die Story. Und hier hat man eine Story gemacht zum Thema Sneaker, also diese Turnschuhe.
Trägst du welche? Nur wenn ich wirklich Sport mache, ansonsten nicht.
Ja, ich auch gar nicht. Ich trage ja Lederschuhe und keine Sneaker. Aber mir ist schon aufgefallen, Sneaker sind extrem wichtig. Das sehe ich, wenn ich durch Düsseldorf gehe, nämlich dort, wo früher meine Lederschuhe standen. Dort stehen jetzt Sneaker zu horrenden Preisen. Zum Teil waren es nicht verrückt und absurde Modelle. Die werden zum Teil immer größer, immer knalliger. Dann habe ich Sneaker gesehen. Da ist nicht nur ein Preisschild dran, sondern da ist noch so ein weiteres Etikett dran. In neongrün oder gelb. Ein paar Zentimeter groß. Und ich dachte, das muss man ja dann wohl auch abmachen. Aber was hat das eigentlich für eine Funktion? Und dann erklärte mir die Verkäuferin, nein, nein, das gehört ja mit da dran. Man geht mit diesem Etikett. Das macht diese Schuhe ja so besonders. Kosten dann 7, 800 Euro. Total absurd, diese Sneaker-Welt. Und jetzt gab es diese WDR-Doku und habe ich gedacht, na ja, Sneaker gucke ich mir mal an. Und jetzt sehen wir plötzlich, wie wir vom Kleinen wieder ins große Ganze kommen. Erst mal ein Einstieg. Wir sind jetzt vor einem Schuhladen, der diese Sneaker hat. Und jetzt wird da so eine Limited Edition an diesem Tag veröffentlicht.
Weniger als 100 Para hat der Laden vorrätig. Der Plan? Um 15 Uhr geht eine Mail an alle registrierten Teilnehmer raus. Darin erfahren sie, wo sie den Schuh erhalten. Ein Ort irgendwo in Berlin. Wo genau, ist bisher geheim. Zwei Stunden später. Wir sind einmal quer durch die Stadt gefahren, bis zu einer kleinen Galerie. Die bisher eigentlich geheim gehaltene Location. Doch wir sind nicht alleine. Die ersten warten bereits. Sie haben den Store-Manager mit dem Auto verfolgt.
Der erste in der Schlange zu sein, aufs richtige Pferd oder die richtige Idee gesetzt zu haben, ist geil. Ein geiles Gefühl.
Also das Schuh kaufen wird zu Challenge. Du kannst natürlich normale Sneaker im Geschäft kaufen, aber alle großen und auch kleinen Hersteller, und es gibt sehr viele kleine Hersteller, also nicht nur Adidas, Nike, Puma und Co. die geben Limited Editions raus, oft dann versehen mit dem Namen eines berühmten Stars. Sehr, sehr berühmtes dann Kanye West, die sind auch besonders begehrt. Oder diese Hersteller geben legendäre Schuhe noch einmal heraus, also den Schuh von Michael Jordan, dann wirklich in der Farbe, die er getragen hat bei diesem historischen Spiel oder so. Und man macht daraus dann eine Challenge, dass dann Leute, die diese Schuhe haben müssen, morgens um vier Uhr aufstehen müssen, irgendwo sich anstellen, dann bekommen sie einen Code und dann können sie wieder woanders hin und holen was ab. Ja, jetzt entsteht dadurch aber nicht nur so ein privater Run auf die Sneaker, sondern da wird dann auch sehr schnell ein Geschäftsmodell draus, wie wir jetzt hören.
Als ich aus dem Laden rauskam mit meinem Papa, weil er natürlich dabei war, wurde mir direkt 500 Euro geboten von einem und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, also mein Papa kam dann aus dem Rückhalt, hat sofort gesagt, okay, wir machen das. Dann habe ich ihm gesagt, ey Papa, glaub mir mal, ich stelle da lieber noch mal auf Ebay eine Anzeige hoch und dann gucke ich mal, was ich da noch bekommen könnte. Auf der Rückfahrt habe ich dann eine gemacht und dann kam auch sofort die Anfrage, okay, für 620 Euro komme ich ihn sofort abholen. Dann hat er ihn letztendlich dann noch gekauft.
Mittlerweile kauft Amre jeden Monat neue Schuhe, um sie anschließend weiter zu verkaufen. Die meisten davon über Kleinanzeigen im Internet oder soziale Medien.
Das Geld, was ich mache, finanziere ich dann halt wieder natürlich in Schuhe. Und das ist halt so ein Kreislauf.
Sehr schön. Das ist ja, er hat eigentlich den Kapitalismus sehr gut begriffen. Also das ist Definition von Kapitalismus. Man investiert Geld, hat dann eine Ware, mit der man mehr Geld erwirtschaftet. Mit dem mehr Geld kann man wieder mehr investieren, um wieder mehr Geld rauszubekommen. Exakt so haben wir das hier auf einer kleinen oder fast, würde ich sagen, kleinsten Unternehmer-Schiene. Aber das gibt es dann auch sehr viel größer. Also wir haben hier die Konzerne, die sagen, wir müssten immer wieder solche Hypes produzieren. Und wir haben jetzt hier mal den kleinen Kunden, der sagt, okay, eigentlich finde ich die Schuhe ganz cool, aber wenn ich jetzt das Dreifache dafür bekomme, mache ich das mal über eBay kleiner zeigen. Aber das, jetzt sind wir noch ganz am Anfang. Also das ist ja noch so Schwarzmarkt. Ich habe ein Ticket für die Rolling Stones und na ja, fürs doppelte Verkaufreich wollte ich doch, dann kaufe ich mir lieber die CD dafür. So geht aber noch sehr viel weiter.
Dann kamen die alle angerannt, von allen Ecken haben ihre Autos auf der Straße stehen gelassen, nur um sich anzustellen. Die standen ja hier bis zur Warschauer Straße vor, in zweiter Reihe. Die Straßenbahn kommt gar nicht mehr durch.
Diejenigen, die hier in der Schlange stehen, können es kaum erwarten, den limitierten Schuh endlich anzufassen.
Kommt direkt an meinen Fuß, direkt. Ich will ihn sofort anziehen.
Doch damit muss er noch warten. Diejenigen, die am Nachmittag am schnellsten vor Ort sind, erhalten erst mal nur ein Bändchen. Sie müssen sich den Schuh anschließend bei einer extra geplanten Veranstaltung abholen. Der Höhepunkt des Tages.
Also man gibt das Geld schon mal aus und kriegt dann erst mal nur ein Bändchen.
Ja, dann gibt es schon mal aus und dann muss man den nachher noch ausgraben. Das erspare ich uns jetzt, dass sie das dann auch noch machen. Und hier haben wir jetzt aber jemanden gehört, der will den wirklich haben. Der will diesen einen Schuh haben. Deswegen macht er das alles mit.
Zum Anziehen. Was ist denn das für ein Banause?
Ja, und die meisten wollen das aber eigentlich nicht, ihn dann anziehen, beziehungsweise die, die bei diesen Hype mitmachen, gibt es natürlich die, die den unbedingt tragen wollen und auch bereit sind, dafür Geld auszugeben. Aber die stehen vielleicht da gar nicht so an. Jetzt hören wir erstmal jemanden vom Adidas Marketing, was der zu dieser Strategie da sagt.
Für uns ist natürlich die sogenannten Limiteds, also die Limited Releases und die limitierten Schuhe, sind natürlich auch ein Stück weit Marketing-Wertzeug, weil wir natürlich auch genau wissen, dass es eine sehr große Nachfrage gibt, die man vielleicht auch gar nicht bedienen möchte, um natürlich auch ein Produkt weiter heiß zu halten, weiter interessant zu halten, um natürlich auch dann den Konsumenten, ja auch, ich will nicht sagen, zu konditionieren, aber natürlich auch so ein bisschen was zu geben, worauf man sich freuen kann.
Konditionieren will er nicht sagen, aber was zu geben, worauf man sich freuen kann. Und er hat es natürlich gesagt. Also was die Absurdität ist ja hier, man könnte ja so viele Schuhe produzieren, wie man möchte, aber man macht eine künstliche Verknappung, damit das einen Hype ergibt. Und jetzt hören wir wieder in die DVD-Doku, wie das jemand ein bisschen einordnet, was da eigentlich diese großen Konzerne machen.
Noch vor rund zehn Jahren waren Sneaker zwar Sammlerobjekte, aber eher was für richtige Turnschuhfans. Heute ist der Hype um Sneaker so groß wie nie zuvor, befeuert durch Adidas und Nike. Die arbeiten mit Stars wie den Rappern Kanye West oder Travis Scott zusammen, damit ihre Schuhe noch beliebter werden, vor allem bei Jugendlichen. Zusammenbringen es beide Konzerne auf einen Umsatz von knapp 36 Milliarden Euro, nur mit Schuhen.
Was gibt es denn Besseres für ein großes Unternehmen, dass Leute vor einem Laden anstehen für Schuhe? Also die stehen nicht für Brot oder Essen an, weil sie hungrig sind, sondern sie stehen an, um ein Produkt zu kaufen für viel Geld, weil sie es geschafft haben, ihre Marketingaktivitäten so hochzuschrauben, dass ein Produkt dafür sorgt, dass Menschen durchdrehen.
Ist das eine Folge von Modern Monetary Theory oder mit was haben wir es hier zu tun?
Inwiefern Modern Monetary Theory?
Dass einfach zu viel Geld da ist. Und man weiß nicht so richtig wohin. Plötzlich ist jeder der reichste Mensch der Welt und es wechselt jeweils.
Naja, wir kommen gleich noch dazu, wo diese Schuhe noch überall vertrieben werden. Zunächst mal kann man, glaube ich, festhalten, dass wir ja kein richtiges hohes Wirtschaftswachstum mehr seit Jahrzehnten im Westen haben. Und man versucht alles, um irgendwie Begehrlichkeiten wieder zu wecken. Und da ist eine Möglichkeit, mit diesen Limited Editions das zu machen. Denn erst einmal könnte man sagen, gut, heute teure Tornschuhe, 200 Euro, die halten auch eine Weile, wenn man sie nicht über Östra passiert. Das heißt, da ist der Bedarf schnell gedeckt. Aber so schafft man natürlich einer ganz anderen Weise Begehrlichkeiten. Da werden dann Leute gezeigt, die haben hunderte Paare zu Hause. Übrigens reden wir hier von einem sehr männlichen Phänomen. Also es gibt natürlich auch Frauen, die Sneaker tragen und die dafür anstehen. Aber die haben natürlich auch nochmal andere Sachen, die sie eher tragen als jetzt Sneaker, zum Beispiel Manolo Planix oder so. Auch dort gibt es ja einen Sammlerhype. Das ist ja bei Sex and the City immer schon ein großes Thema gewesen. Hier sind aber jetzt auch einfach die Männer als Zielgruppe entdeckt worden, dass man sagt, gut, hier haben wir eigentlich ganz, ganz viel Kundenpotenzial. Das müssen wir nur irgendwie zu wecken versuchen. Und bei Männern geht das sehr gut über Limited Edition. Das kennt man von Uhren, das kennt man auch von Münzen. Das sind Sachen, die Männer immer sehr anziehend finden, wenn irgendwas Limited Edition ist. Aber wie gesagt, das ist ja eine künstliche Verknappung. Wir haben hier nicht irgendwas Seltenes.
Ja, meinst du, wenn wir neue Zwanziger T-Shirts machen würden, aber nur 50 Stück und die sind durchnummeriert auf dem linken Ärmel, da könnten die für 500 Euro das Stück verkaufen?
Wir nicht. Und das ist ja das Interessante jetzt. Also Adidas verkauft natürlich auch diese Schuhe schon mal für teurer und auch die anderen. Also die kosten mehr als die üblichen Sneaker. Und wir könnten jetzt die T-Shirts sicherlich nicht nur für 30 Euro, sondern auch für 70 Euro verkaufen. Aber das andere, was danach passiert, also dass die für 500 Euro gehandelt werden, das kommt nicht mehr bei uns an. Das machen dann die Reseller. Die sagen dann, okay, wir investieren jetzt da. Und darum geht es jetzt. Wir haben jetzt eben gehört, hier Handelsabkommen. Und da denken wir jetzt an Unternehmen direkt, die das machen. Aber was ist eigentlich mit so einem sekundären oder tertiären Markt, der da sich auftut? Jetzt sprechen wir mal über die Reseller.
Vor allem Profis machen auf dem Markt aber viel Profit. Der Umsatz wird für den Wiederverkauf von Turnschuhen auf rund 5, 5 Milliarden Euro geschätzt.
Großhändler, sogenannte Bulkbuyer, kaufen riesige Mengen und verkaufen sie wieder. Oder sie haben Deals mit Sneakerläden und bekommen die Schuhe vor allen anderen. Backdoor, also durch die Hintertür. Und nochmal andere benutzen spezielle Software und kaufen Sneaker im großen Stil im Netz. Sie heißen Botter.
Von den Bottern habe ich schon gehört. Das finde ich wahnsinnig faszinierend.
Ja, da haben wir jetzt einen Botter. Und wir denken nochmal gerade an Macron, der schon von den Quantencomputern sprach. Die gibt es jetzt noch nicht, aber das wäre für die Botter eigentlich interessant. Die Beschleunigung des Handels, die erleben wir hier. Denn natürlich kann man sich nicht nur anstellen und warten auf den Schuh, sondern man kann auch sagen, heute Nacht um 0 Uhr wird dieser eine Schuh released. Ich gehe zu Zalando und versuche, den zu erwerben. Und oftmals, ich kenne Freunde, die das tatsächlich schon versucht haben, scheitert man daran. Und das liegt wahrscheinlich nicht nur daran, dass viele Leute da gerade händisch klicken, sondern an Leuten wie Max.
Max-Geschäfte laufen gut, sagt er. Sein Jahresumsatz sei 7-stellig. Als Beleg zeigt er uns seine Kreditkartenumsätze.
Es sind schon 1, 5 bis 2 Millionen Euro, die da immer rein und rausgehen. Ich versuche immer so viel wie möglich, bis zu 100 Schuhe meistens. So in die Richtung geht das. Sobald es dann losgeht, habe ich meine Bots und lasse die laufen.
Also der schickt seine Computerprogramme los, um möglichst zeitnah vor allen anderen das schnell wegzuklicken.
Genau, Algorithmen testen dann alles durch und das wird dann so ein bisschen eingeblendet, wie das geht, versteht man ja doch nicht so ganz. Wir hören dann mal weiter, wie er dann dann...
Das ist High-Frequency-Trading.
Ja, das ist Hochfrequenzhandel.
Botta Max verkauft seine Schuhe an einen sogenannten Balkbuyer, also einer Art Großeinkäufer. Der kauft Schuhe von mehreren Wiederverkäufern auf. Je größer die Menge, desto besser. Balkbuyer zahlen je nach Modell einen Aufschlag. Häufig sind das 20 bis 30 Prozent. Sie verteilen die Ware wiederum noch teurer weiter, meistens nach Asien, wo die Nachfrage besonders hoch ist und auch hohe Preise gezahlt werden.
Und irgendwann am Ende kommt das dann an bei 800 Euro pro Stück und vergraben im Wald mit einem ordentlichen Event und so.
Ne, das ist ja noch, wenn es aus dem Geschäft geht, also mit Verkramung im Wald. Hier das, was jetzt die Balk-Bayer für ein Publikum haben, ist eines, das sagt, ich will den Schuh, ich stelle mich doch nirgends an, ich habe auch gar keine Zeit dafür, aber ich habe sehr viel Geld, weil es eine Vermögenspreisinflation gibt. Also da oben ist tatsächlich das Vermögen gewachsen und gewachsen und da kann man sagen, es ist mir doch egal, ob der jetzt 2.000 Euro kostet, dieser Schuh, ich kaufe den einfach, wir hören da mal rein.
Das sind alles Industrienationen geworden, die sehr, sehr viel Geld verdient haben an unseren westlichen Dingen, die wir denen im Prinzip sozusagen da produzieren lassen haben. Jetzt haben die richtig viel Asche und wir reden von wirklich viel Asche und das holen die jetzt alles nach.
Und so landen die Schuhe wieder dort, wo sie ursprünglich kostengünstig produziert wurden und jetzt teuer verkauft werden, in Asien.
Der Herr, der am Anfang sprach, hat übrigens auch einen Podcast. Der heißt Die Talk Shoe. Die sprechen jede Woche über Sneaker. Und ja, also die landen jetzt wieder da. Das heißt Lieferkettengesetz nochmal ganz neu gedacht. Und wir sehen, wie absurd eigentlich dieses System des Kapitalismus hier geworden ist und auch, was das für die Umwelt natürlich bedeutet, wie diese Schuhe durch die Welt geschickt werden. Das ist ja auch nicht zu vernachlässigen. Und wir kommen jetzt aber nochmal auf diesen Pota Max zu sprechen, denn er wird jetzt auch gefragt, ob er denn nicht vielleicht ein schlechtes Gewissen hat bei dem, was er da tut.
Dass auch hierzulande Sneaker-Fans die Schuhe gern getragen hätten, ist Max egal.
Ein schlechtes Gewissen habe ich nicht wirklich. Die Leute leben auch von dem Hype. Würden wir die Schuhe nicht wegkaufen, würde es diesen ganzen Hype um diese Schuhe nicht geben. Dann wäre der Preis nicht da. Dann würden die die auch nicht so gerne tragen. Dann wären die auch nicht so limitiert. Also ich glaube, jeder profitiert von jedem. Wir vielleicht ein bisschen mehr.
Muss ich absolut sagen, das stimmt. Diese Logik überzeugt mich total.
Er hat absolut recht. Das ist so schön herausgearbeitet. Also man kann sagen, dieser Hochfrequenz-Hande, den die da betreiben, der pusht die Preise, ein hoher Preis bedeutet für viele Leute, das muss aber was Begehrenswertes sein. Und man kann das sehr schön sehen in der High Fashion, wenn man mal durch so ein Luxus-Kaufhaus wie Breuninger geht. Man hat dort die Sneaker, die natürlich zum größten Teil einfach Plastikschuhe sind oder da ist da mal vorne ein bisschen Kalbsleder drauf. Aber was kann das kosten? Was kostet ein bisschen Kalbsleder? Wir haben es also da eigentlich mit einem billigen Produkt nach wie vor zu tun, aber man hat dann durch das Design, durch die Limitierung, durch die Stars, das Marketing es geschafft, solche Schuhe abstrus teuer zu machen. Das ist also nicht vergleichbar mit dem rahmengenähten 600 Euro Lederschuh, wo man sagen kann, okay, da steckt aber wirklich auch sehr viel Arbeit, Handarbeit nämlich drin, sondern wir haben es hier mit einem Industrieprodukt zu tun, das produziert werden kann ohne Ende. Man macht das nur über Marketing, schafft man diesen Hype. Und er hat absolut recht, was er da erzählt. Und jetzt gehen wir mal noch mal zu so einem deutschen Laden zurück, nämlich Reseller kann man auch auf andere Weise sein.
Laut dem US-Unternehmen ist die Anzahl von Resellern im vergangenen Jahr in keinem anderen Land der Welt so stark gestiegen wie in Deutschland. So manch ein Reseller hat sogar ein richtiges Ladengeschäft, wie Steppan Timoschin aus Berlin. Obwohl er seinen Laden erst vor rund zwei Jahren eröffnet hat, ist er sich sicher, das, was er bietet, bietet sonst niemand. Mehr als 400 verschiedene Sneaker-Modelle habe er ständig vorrätig, alle streng limitiert und offiziell schon lange vergriffen. Das hat seinen Preis.
Der MoMA preislich bei 7500 Billionaires Boys Club, 2500 Euro.
7000 Euro für die Tornschuhe?
Und wie gesagt, wir haben es nur mit einem Halbzeitraum, das heißt, es ist nicht mehr an realwirtschaftliche Zusammenhänge gekoppelt. Also natürlich gibt es in der Haute Couture übertrieben teure Preise und natürlich sind da ganz andere Gewinnspannen. Aber wenn man jetzt sagen würde, ich kaufe mir ein Kleid von Chanel, dann hast du dort Arbeitsstunden ohne Ende drin. Das kann man so Chanel-Dokus sehr gut nachsehen, wie da gearbeitet wird in Paris, diese Näherinnen, die seit Jahrzehnten in dem Unternehmen sind. Da kann man immer noch sagen, es ist absurd und irgendwie auch nicht richtig, dass so viel Geld für Kleidung ausgegeben wird. Aber wir haben hier noch eine direkte Verbindung zur Realwirtschaft. Die ist hier vollkommen losgelöst. Wir sind hier im Reich der Spekulation angekommen. Und wenn wir im Reich der Spekulation sind, sind wir, wir machen erst einen Schritt noch zurück. Also hier haben wir jetzt einen deutschen Laden gehabt. Jetzt müssen wir uns das erst mal nochmal global vordenken von den Käufern. Nämlich auch die Käufer sind jetzt Teil dieser Globalisierung, indem sie zum Beispiel als Touristen jetzt unterwegs sind, um Sneaker abzugreifen.
Rund 150 wartende Kunden. Sie alle warten hier bereits seit zwei Tagen für einen Nike-Turnschuh. Einige sind sogar extra aus dem Ausland angereist, wie Derrico aus Belgien.
Wir haben uns ein Hotel genommen, die sind hier wirklich günstig. Wir schlafen hier mehrere Nächte zu einem Top-Preis. Ihr bleibt hier jetzt drei Tage nur für den Schuh? Ja, drei Tage nur für den Schuh. Wir sind aus Belgien, aber ich bin mit meinem Freund Hamza in der ganzen Welt unterwegs, um Schuhe zu kaufen. In Polen, Frankreich, einfach überall.
Aber wenn es so viele Schuhe gibt, woran erkennt man denn diese Einzigartigkeit? Nur weil da noch so ein kleines Schildchen dran hängt, oder?
Nein, es gibt einfach Sondereditionen. Dann wird gesagt, Kanye West hat einen Schuhdesign, den gibt es 20.000 Mal auf der Welt.
Das ist aber auch erkennbar, also die Leute, die sich da auskennen?
Die kennen den. Also die Distinktion geht jetzt da über die Sneaker. Also das heißt, man erkennt, okay, das ist von diesem berühmten Sportler der Schuh, weil der irgendeine rote Linie noch drin hat.
Weil bei Schmuck oder Mode lässt man es ja immer so ein bisschen im Unklar an. Also ist das jetzt ein Kleid für 5.000 oder für 25.000 Euro oder so bei Schmuck, wo man nämlich nicht ganz genau weiß, ist es jetzt 7.000 oder 70.000 Euro?
Das ändert sich jetzt auch. Also es gibt die diskrete Mode nach wie vor. Also man sieht ja Anzügen nicht unbedingt an, was sie kosten. Man kann das, wenn man den Blick ein bisschen schult, dann kann man das sehen. Also man sieht auch schon einfach, welcher Politiker wahrscheinlich Maas trägt. Oder, also ich würde jetzt mal zum Beispiel mal sagen, Konstantin Kuhle von der FDP trägt sehr gute Anzüge, glaube ich. Ich glaube auch Peter Altmaier trägt ziemlich gute Anzüge. Bei anderen habe ich nicht den Eindruck. Es ist aber so, dass man es da nicht wirklich so sehen kann. Da liegt man eigentlich die Diskretion, diese vornehme Zurückhaltung. Man erkennt sich vielleicht so untereinander. Okay, weiß ja, das muss schon ein guter Stoff sein, aber mehr nicht. Was wir aber jetzt haben, ist eigentlich so eine Hinzuplakatierung zum Logo. Und das Logo allein reicht aber nicht. Also Nike kann ja auch sich jeder leisten, quasi. Sondern wie schaffen wir wieder eine Exklusivität? Und das ist interessant. Man schafft hier eine Exklusivität, die aber ganz sichtbar ist. Das heißt, jemand, der sich ein bisschen auskennt, weiß, okay, diesen Sneaker finde ich sonst nirgends. Das war diese besondere Edition damals. Und das gibt es aber jetzt auch immer mehr, auch bei der Mode. Also es gibt auch Reseller, Ladengeschäfte, die inzwischen nicht nur Sneaker vertreiben, sondern dann auch limitierte Mode. Das kann vom BH bis zum Abendkleid alles sein. Und bei Uhren haben wir das auch sehr stark. Und wir haben auch so eine neue Diskussion darüber, also Distinktionen über Uhren. Und wir tragen, was war auch bei beiden das Gespräch, welche Uhr trägt er dann? Er trägt eine Rolex Datejust, also gar nicht das teuerste Modell. Und darüber wird aber sofort dann gesprochen. Also das ist eine generelle Tendenz, denke ich. Und ja, wie gesagt, es ist ein Spekulationsobjekt. Und was liegt da? Was lege da näher, als zu sagen, machen wir doch eine Börse draus? Und es gibt es auch.
Wir stoßen auf StockX, die weltweit größte Online-Plattform für Reseller. Hier werden Sneaker wie Wertpapiere gehandelt. Wie bei Aktien wird die Preisentwicklung des Tonschoes grafisch dargestellt.
Wenn du auf die Produktseite gehst, sagen wir von einem Yeezy oder einem Air Jordan, siehst du alle Verkaufsangebote und auch alle Kaufangebote. Als Käufer gibst du dort dann an, wie viel du für einen bestimmten Schuh bezahlen würdest. Und als Verkäufer, wie viel du dafür verlangst. Passt beides zusammen, wird der Kauf automatisch abgeschlossen. Genau wie an der Börse.
Einfach ein bisschen strukturierteres eBay, würde ich sagen.
Genau. Kommen wir jetzt gleich noch zu, was vielleicht der Unterschied zu eBay bei der Sache ist. Erstmal, was sagt der Marketingmann von Adidas dazu?
Ich persönlich gucke schon, welchen Resale Value meine Produkte oder die Produkte von Adidas haben da draußen, weil es natürlich auch irgendwo eine Indikation ist für den Erfolg des Produktes und vielleicht auch sogar, wie heiß eine Marke ist. Und man muss halt jetzt einfach sehen, wie man halt coexistiert.
Ja, das ist jetzt der Indikator, um zu sehen, war die Kampagne erfolgreich? Ist das Unternehmen gut bewertet? Also das zeigt sich jetzt nicht nur an der Aktie, sondern das zeigt sich auch an dem Schuhkurs, den man jetzt gerade mit dem neuesten Sneaker hat. StockX heißt diese Börse, die inzwischen nicht nur Sneaker, sondern auch noch andere limitierte Dinge anbietet. Josh Luba heißt der Erfinder dieser Geschichte. Und ich sage jetzt gerade Erfinder. Und da könnte man ja sagen, das liegt doch alles auf der Hand. Und ja, da ist auch nicht jetzt Josh Luba wahrscheinlich als einziger drauf gekommen. Und ich habe dann so einen kurzen Talk mit ihm gehört, habe ich bei YouTube gefunden. Da sagt er mal generell was den Gründern. Wenn die immer so von ihren Ideen schwärmen, beziehungsweise ihre Ideen nicht verraten wollen.
Sie denken, dass jemand ihre Idee stehlen wird.
Das stimmt.
Das haben wir auch in Shenzhen gesehen. Also die haben dann auch vielleicht gerade die Idee mal aufgeschnappt. Und dann wird gesagt, die kopieren uns ja. Ja, aber in der Ausführung, wie gut das gemacht ist, da entscheidet sich der Erfolg dann. Und natürlich kann man auch andere Plattformen frequentieren, aber StockX hat sich wohl gerade sehr gut durchgesetzt, weil es offenbar gut ausgeführt ist. So und Josh Luba war dann zu Gast bei dem OMR Podcast und hat darüber gesprochen, wie denn diese Börse sich auch verändern könnte. Denn noch ist es ja so, wir haben da das Reseller Modell, aber könnte man nicht auch sagen, na ja, wenn wir doch diese Börse haben, dann kann doch Adidas direkt mit Produkten auf diese Börse gehen, also quasi Shares austeilen für alle.
Du weißt, jetzt ist StockX, ich weiß nicht, was die neuesten Statistiken sind, aber wir haben mehr Web-Trafik als alle in der Sneaker-Industrie, z.B. Footlocker und Finish Line und alle anderen Retail-Marketing-Channels.
Also Schuhe zu verkaufen wie Aktien in so einem Offering, dass man einfach sagt, jetzt machen wir es. Das geht schon ziemlich mit so einem allgemeinen Trend der eventhaften Gamifizierung einher, wie wir es jetzt auch bei Gamestop und so weiter sehen. Das ist einfach ein Event, an dem man halt teilnimmt. Und klar, umso größer das dann wird. Also da werden so Netzwerkeffekte, das wäre auch so ein Thema für die Neuen Zwanziger, gerade für dieses Jahr, ob jetzt mittlerweile so Netzwerkeffekte sichtbar sind, die stärker sind als Organisation. Also die stärker sind als hierarchische Entscheidungsfindung, Mitgliedschaftsregeln und so weiter. Das sehen wir auf jeden Fall, wenn Reddit gegen diese Millionäre, die ihre durchorganisierten Hedgefonds und so weiter haben, da schlägt sich das gerade schon ziemlich auf die Seite der Netzwerke. Und hier wieder, ob man einfach das Publikum so einen Netzwerkeffekt aussetzt und gar nicht sagt, da ist ein Laden, da ist ein Mitarbeiter, der berät dich, dann kaufst du das an der Kasse und so, sondern das einfach wirklich sich so organisieren lässt. Weil am Ende sind die alle nur an so einer Preisfindung interessiert und nicht an, dass der Schuh voll gut passt im Vergleich zu anderen. Und man deswegen, also es ist doch ein anderes Einkaufserlebnis, dass die da so wollen. Und ich glaube echt, das kann so eine Börse sehr viel besser bieten, als wenn jetzt Foodlocker wegen Pandemie auch noch ein Online-Business aufmacht, neben vielen anderen, wo du auch nur wieder so ein Katalog durchklickst, einen Standardpreis wählst und dann kaufst. Weil das ist ein langweiliger Kauf. Also ich kann das sehr gut nachvollziehen.
Und wir sehen, wie auch die Finanzialisierung eigentlich noch mal eine neue Mauer durchbricht. Ja, wir hatten immer gesagt, na gut, das sind irgendwelche Aktienpakete, die da geschnürt werden. Das ist alles ganz virtuell. Und hier wird aber quasi die Finanzialisierung, also dass alles an den Finanzmärkten stattfindet, wirklich mal mit einem realen Produkt auch noch möglich gemacht. Und das ist noch mal eine neue Ebene, die ja eigentlich nichts Gutes verheißt und auch zeigt, wie wichtig dann auch für Menschen der Konsum ist, zur Distinktion wirklich, also dass wir gar nicht bei diesen Fragen sind, die häufig jetzt so gestellt werden. Ja, brauchen wir dann überhaupt das alles? Nein, also das ist jetzt alles nur Spekulation. Das sind Begehrlichkeiten, das sind Zaubertricks, auf die man reinfällt. Und jetzt noch mal, um das Ganze abzuschließen. Also wir sind ja eingestiegen mit Davos, mit China, mit diesem Abkommen. Und wir wissen also schon, jetzt gibt es ganz, ganz viel Handel da schon zwischen denen. Ja, also es ist jetzt gar nicht so, dass man sagt, gut, wir müssen jetzt mal gucken, wie regeln wir das dann gerade, sondern über diese ganzen Kleinhändler. Shopify bietet lange, lange Erklärungen an, wie man jetzt so einen Dropship-Store eröffnet. Das heißt, die sind alle sehr daran interessiert. Also dieser Markt ist schon ganz nah. Da müssen wir jetzt noch mal zum Schluss hören, wie Josh Luber das mit China einschätzt. Welche Rolle eigentlich China da gerade spielt?
Das sind einfach chinesische Menschen, die überall auf der Welt schauen, um das zu bekommen, weil sie so influential und so stark sind, in den Termen der Fahrtverwaltung.
Also ich meine, diese Influenzerei, ihr habt ja das Buch dann bald, ich bin sehr gespannt. Wir hatten, kann man ja auch mal sagen, wir machen ja hier ein Podcast, jeden Monat findet hier ein Podcast statt für zehn Jahre und wir reden jetzt in der vierten Stunde mal kurz darüber, dass wir auch einen neuen Präsidenten haben in Amerika. So weit ist dieses Thema schon nach hinten gedrängt. Und dieser Präsident hat ja an seiner Rede, wie vorhin schon mal kurz angemerkt, die Leute dazu aufgehalten zu sagen, Leute, pass mal auf, nur weil jemand eine andere politische Meinung hat, ist das nicht gleich eine Kriegserklärung an dich. Wir müssen nicht alles in einem zivilen Bürgerkrieg klären. Wir können auch einfach mal was diskutieren. Und am Ende entscheidet die Mehrheit. Und dann ist das nächste Thema dran. Tagesordnungspunkte abwickeln. Während wir gleichzeitig nicht mal mehr beim Schuhekauf drum rumkommen zu sagen, also das ist der wichtigste Schuh der Welt. Wenn du den nicht kaufst, dann verpasst du hier alles. Ja, schnall dich an, nimm dir drei Tage Zeit, kauf dieses Schuh und fragt, okay, wie soll denn Joe beiden...
Klapphaus. Das ist ja auch das Formofenomen.
Genau, da verpasst man einfach Sachen, glaubt man. Diese ganze Erlösungsfantasie, diese Neomythiologisierung. Wie soll denn Joe Biden dem Anspruch nachkommen, einige Mal das Land und so weiter, während alle nur noch ausrasten und so einen Scheiß machen? Also da muss man sagen, sind auch wirklich alle ein bisschen verloren. Und klar, hier kann man jetzt einfach Geld machen, das tut wahrscheinlich niemandem weh, wobei man auch nicht die negativen Schicksale hören will, die da vielleicht so drinstecken. Aber das ist schon alles brutaler Alltag, muss man nicht mal sagen.
In der Tat, aber wir müssen hier festhalten, wenn jetzt jemand wie Bütiko versagt, die hätten sich mal mehr Zeit lassen müssen. Es läuft schon ganz viel. Also klar, da gibt es jetzt nicht das Investitionsabkommen, darauf sind die jetzt nicht so angewiesen. Aber der Handel, der läuft schon auf so vielen Wegen, wo wahrscheinlich die meisten Politiker nicht einmal einen Schimmer von haben, was da schon alles hin und her transferiert wird. Und das ist nicht nur Amazon und Alibaba, sondern das sind irgendwelche kleinen Stores, Nebenplätze über Social Media wird akquiriert. Wo kann ich neue Schuhe wieder erwerben und dann wieder offerieren? Das ist ein absurder Markt, bei dem natürlich ein China, das immer mehr Milliardäre hat, ein großes Interesse daran hat, zu sagen, ja gut, wir haben das Geld, dann lassen wir die mal da irgendwo in Berlin anstehen, in den Shops, bis die die Schuhe bekommen. Und dann lassen wir uns die von Berlin schicken und dann tragen wir die hier.
Ja, ich meine, wir haben jetzt so viele Sorgen, Nachfrage und Angebote zum Koordinieren, beispielsweise in der Pandemie, Masken, Impfung, Schnelltests. Bei den Masken geht das ja so weit der Wahnsinn, dass wir die Bundesdruckerei beauftragt haben, fälschungssichere Gutscheine zu drucken, um sich dann Zellstoff in der Apotheke zu kaufen. Das könnte man natürlich auch ein bisschen besser organisieren.
Da sind ja noch nicht angekommen, dieser Gutschein.
Das kommt noch dazu.
Mein Vater hat zum Beispiel immer noch keinen Gutschein bekommen.
Das funktioniert noch nicht mal richtig. Und hier haben wir ja so ein Beispiel jetzt gehört. Und das kann man ja auch zusammenbringen mit, wie werden eigentlich die Impftermine vergeben? Das ist ja ganz beispielhaft, dass sich Eventim angeboten hat, das für die staatliche Seite zu übernehmen. Es hat sich ein Bundesland, ich glaube Schleswig-Holstein breiterklärt, zu sagen, ja, wir machen das über Eventim. Und dort lief es dann auch als einziges Bundesland. Überall sonst ist ein Server, keine Ahnung. In Hessen waren sie total überrascht, dass es mehr Anfragen nach Impfterminen gab, als Hessen Einwohner hat. Weil einfach jeder, der glaubte, er hätte Berechtigung, es 10.000 Mal versucht hat, da anzurufen und dann klappt es alles nicht. Also hier ist es doch noch. Naja, die ein oder andere Lücke zu füllen. Gut, dass man das bei Tornschuhen schon mal hingekriegt hat. Vielleicht kriegen wir sowas auch bei wichtigen Sachen bald mal hin. Und vielleicht steht da nicht nur der Preis im Mittelpunkt. Bekloppt ist es trotzdem. Und bekloppt ist auch, wir schließen den Podcast heute mit bisschen Philosophie. Wir sind ja hier angekommen in einer neuen Welt, wo wir uns viele Fragen stellen, Antworten suchen. Und dank zweiter Weise gibt es noch Fernsehen, wo man sich ein bisschen Zeit nimmt, die eine oder andere Frage zu klären. Beispielsweise Gerds Goebel in Kulturzeit. Wir greifen zurück auf den Jahresrückblick 2020. Gerds Goebel eröffnet ihn wie folgt.
Hegel, dessen 250. Geburtstag in diesem Jahr gefeiert wurde, definiert die Philosophie als ein Erfassen der Zeit in Gedanken. Reicht ihnen das? Auch Bilder und Symbole müssen ja eingefangen und interpretiert werden. Und dann zunehmend nicht nur Gedanken, sondern vor allem auch Daten. Um unsere Gegenwart philosophisch zu erfassen, ist heute anderes und mehr nötig als damals. Für uns ein Grund, bei Kulturzeit heute, statt eines klassischen Jahresrückblicks, zu versuchen, unsere Gegenwart unter heutigen Bedingungen philosophisch zu bestimmen. Warum philosophisch? Weil in diesem Jahr Philosophie vielleicht das erste Mal seit Jahrzehnten eine zentrale Rolle spielte, als es darum ging, die Gegenwart nicht nur zu verstehen, sondern auch Gesellschaft und Politik gut zu steuern.
Auf welchen Philosophen haben wir 2020 so krass gewartet, dass er uns endlich erklärt, wie wir das alles mal steuern sollen? Ich weiß nicht genau, woher er diesen Eindruck hat.
Markus Gabriel, oder? Nein, wir sind ja schon in der Märzausgabe zu dem Schluss gekommen. Die Philosophen haben gerade relativ wenig zu sagen. Also eigentlich waren uns die parkünen Gedanken von Agampen dann noch lieber als das, was die Philosophen sagten, wie Krise als Chance, jetzt aber mal Kapitalismus anhalten, Welt steht still, neue Resonanzräume tun sich auf. Irgendwas hat nach See auch noch der Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung erzählt. Also das war ja alles richtig dürftig, was die Philosophie geliefert hat. Und diese großen Denkräume, die sich dort auftaten, die waren irgendwie mal für so einen Nachmittag da. Man könnte auch noch mal ein Buch lesen, aber eigentlich wollte man wissen, wann machen dann die Geschäfte wieder auf? Und es ist überhaupt nicht der Fall. Also mir fällt nicht eine einzige philosophische These aus dem Jahr 2020 ein, die durch Corona jetzt entstanden ist. Also ich habe ja auch diese ganzen Leute, auch zum Teil mit ihnen ja auch gesprochen, wie Precht oder Flasspöler. Wo ist das? Also der Verweis darauf, dass man Kamus noch mal lesen sollte. Ja, das hat eigentlich geschadet, würde ich auch sagen. Aber sonst ist doch eigentlich von den Philosophen so gut wie nichts gekommen. Auch das Covid-Buch von Slavoj Ciesek ist relativ dürftig. Ich würde sagen, das war eines der schlechtesten Jahre für die Philosophen überhaupt.
Ja, vor allem die Moderation beginnt mit Verweis auf Hilgel. Der ist nun wirklich schon eine Weile tot. Er kann uns zu Corona wenigstens sagen. Erfassen der Zeit in Gedanken. Ja, dann noch mal hinterherzuschieben, auch Daten. Reicht ihn das nur das in Gedanken festzuhalten, sonst nicht auch in Daten festzuhalten? Also hätten wir gerne letztes Jahr, glaube ich. Ich glaube, wir hätten gerne mal ein bisschen mehr Daten festgehalten zu Corona. Ich sehe immer nur Beschwerden darüber, dass wir so gar nichts wissen über Corona. Wer hat Corona und gibt das über die App bitte weiter? Niemand. Also die Uni Frankfurt macht zwar viele Tests, aber die gibt ja kein QR-Code, wo du das in deine App einträgst oder so. Sondern die ruft dich an und dann weißt du halt, was Corona ist. Dann musst du selber deinen Leuten Bescheid sagen. Diese Steuerungsfantasie finde ich auch immer noch beeindruckend, dass man das noch so machen kann. Dass man sagt, wir wollen ja auch die Gesellschaft steuern, hat er ja genau so gesagt. Ich dachte, das hätten wir schon lange abgelegt. Also Lumans Angebot, Steuerungsfantasien hinsichtlich, es gibt ja die einheitliche Vernunft und die muss man nur richtig lenken. Erstens, also durch ein Gespräch klappt das nicht. Auf Konsens muss man auch nicht warten. Und diese einheitliche Vernunft, die gibt es auch nicht, sondern hier prallen ja nun wirklich verschiedene Rationalitäten aufeinander, die nicht mehr unter einem Hut zu kriegen sind. Die einen wollen Profit, die anderen wollen die 40 Prozent Zustimmung bei den Wählern über die Ziellinie erholen und nichts passt mit irgendwem zusammen. Also in der Ansicht ist das schon ziemlich komisch und mit Verweis auf Daten ist jetzt ein bisschen weit her, aber passt so unserem Thematisierung. Ich habe bei Heise am 19.1.Text gelesen, dass der Citizen Score in China gerade sehr wackelt. Also da stand Chinas soziales Kreditsystem ist nicht mehr im Plan der Social Credit, von dem wir so häufig sprachen, denn er ist tatsächlich überfrachtet worden. Die Chinesen wollten zu viel. Die haben, stand im Text, werden jetzt mittlerweile die Auswertung gemacht von diesen 38 verschiedenen Modellen, die man in verschiedenen Regionen so macht. Und man hat eigentlich überall durch die Bank festgestellt, ja, diese Form des Kredits, also dass man alles runterbrechen kann auf ein Kredit, funktioniert nicht, wenn man sie zu überfrachtet. Also wenn man schon ist, barot über die Straße gegangen, mit ein, nimmt in so eine Kalkulation, kommt am Ende kein sinnvolles Ergebnis raus. Und mittlerweile, und das ist sozusagen, könnte auch ein Todesstoß sein, die Menschen haben Angst vor Missbrauch des Systems. Das ist ja eigentlich gestaltet worden, um Vertrauen zu schaffen, wo zwischenmenschliches Misstrauen herrscht. Alle sind ohne Geschwister aufgewachsen in der eigenen Kindpolitik und sind nur in Konkurrenz miteinander, vertrauen sich nicht und sagen dann, okay, dann nehmen wir halt den gemeinsamen Gott, dieses Kreditsystem. Und jetzt haben allerdings, das ist ja die Nachrichtentour, Agentur Xenua daraus ermittelt, 70 Prozent Zustimmung zur Aussage, ich habe Angst vor Missbrauch durch dieses System. Und das heißt natürlich echt, das funktioniert dann einfach nicht. Also in der Hinsicht sind wir hier weder mit Philosophie, noch mit Daten irgendwie weitergekommen 2020. Wenn, dann ist es doch auf allen Ebenen irgendwie ein bisschen anders. Naja, Aussage Nummer zwei, Scobel hier.
Corona hat gezeigt, was wir sonst gerne verdrängen, wie verletzlich wir sind.
Stimmt für die Krankheit, aber wir haben ganz schön viele politische Probleme, die man auch mal hätte thematisieren können, ausgeblendet letztes Jahr. Beispielsweise der extreme Reichtum, der sich angesammelt hat, unter den Superreichen und gestern, erstaunlicherweise, hat sich unser Bauminister, der ja auch der Innenminister ist, Horst Seehofer, mal geäußert zum Thema bauen und wohnen, denn es handelt sich ja damit um das wichtigste Problem der Gegenwart. Ich dachte, stimmt, aber letztes Jahr nix zugehört dazu. Es war einfach nur, alle bleiben mal zu Hause und ach so, es ist zu teuer. Also wir blenden auch ganz schön viele Themen aus, während wir die ganze Zeit, ja klar, unser Körper steht jetzt irgendwie im Mittelpunkt der Thematisierung, aber so im Großen und Ganzen fehlen uns doch so ein paar Probleme, die wir nun wirklich ausgeblendet haben.
Ja und vor allem erinnere ich daran, dass so was ja schon mal dann versucht wurde anzusprechen. Im April, als dann auch noch alle Politiker in ihrem Homeoffice interviewt wurden und wenn immer solche Fragen dann aufkamen und man sagte, sollte man nicht jetzt vielleicht auch zugleich mal über Klimawandel nachdenken und über Ungleichheit, war dann ja von Politikern von CDU bis Habeck zu hören, jetzt ist nicht der Zeitpunkt.
Genau.
Und dann muss man mal sagen, nee, jetzt ist aber sehr wohl der Zeitpunkt.
Genau und wir haben nun das Ende von Corona wirklich vor Augen und ich finde es sehr bedeutsam, dass am 19. wir zum einen einen extrem guten Bundeshaushalt hatten, weil man festgestellt hat, die Firmen haben das Geld gar nicht gebraucht, also 5 Prozent Wirtschaftswachstumsmise nur und natürlich Megabürokratie, weshalb das Geld nicht abgeflossen ist, aber wir haben sehr viele Staatsschulden aufgenommen letztes Jahr, die gar nicht gebraucht wurden, die immer noch als Geldberg im Bundeshaushalt liegen und am 26. also vor drei Tagen hat Helge Braun plötzlich im Handelsblatt davon gesprochen, dass wir vielleicht die Schuldenbremse mehrere Jahre jetzt nicht anwenden können, wo man sich fragt, was weiß der eigentlich, was wir nicht wissen? Was weiß die Regierung eigentlich gerade, was wir nicht wissen, dass selbst die CDU plötzlich kommt und sagt Schuldenbremse jetzt mal ganz langsam erst mal? Weil das ist ja nun wirklich Perspektive der nächsten drei vier fünf Jahre, die da aufgemacht wurde, wo es heißt, da brauchen wir erheblich mehr Geld. Und da kann ich mit so einer Aussage wie eben, ja, jetzt wissen wir ganz schön, was uns so verletzt. Also da würde ich doch mal klar widersprechen. Wir wissen gerade ganz schön wenig darüber, was unsere Probleme eigentlich sind.
Zumal es wurde bisweilen ja so getan und das war in einigen Berichten jetzt aus Kulturzeit oder so zu vernehmen, als würden wir jetzt mal, wie es dann heißt, Verwundbarkeit, Vulnerabilität, all das würden wir jetzt einmal merken. Und wir hätten jetzt auch wieder, es würden sehen, dass der Tod mehr in unserem Leben stattfindet. Flasbole hat auch, ob ich jetzt noch mal so was bei Landsetzer, da muss ich sagen, nee, das ist doch Unsinn. Jeder Mensch hat Freunde, Bekannte, Verwandte. Und jeder Mensch hat auch mit dem Tod schon eine Begegnung gemacht. Weil irgendwelche ihm nahestehenden Menschen gestorben sind, hat Erfahrungen gemacht mit Menschen, die sehr krank sind, die vielleicht nicht mehr gesund werden oder irgendwann nach langer Therapie wieder gesund werden oder nur noch so halbgesund sind. All das kennt man doch aus seinem Umfeld. Also ich habe da manchmal den Eindruck, dort sitzen Menschen, die keine anderen Menschen kennen. Aber es ist doch nicht so, als hätte man keine Erfahrung mit Krankheit sonst gemacht. Ja, mit fünf Jahren vielleicht noch nicht. Da wird einem das so ein bisschen ausgeblendet. Und dann sagt man, nee, die Opa können wir jetzt grad nicht besuchen. Aber danach ist man doch damit konfrontiert und weiß, wie Menschen aus dem Leben gerissen werden durch irgendeine Diagnose. Wir werden durch die ganzen Vorsorgen, die wir machen sollen, immer wieder daran erinnert, wie sterblich wir sind, wie leicht es passieren kann, dass wir einen Tumor oder sonst was haben. Es stimmt doch auch einfach nicht, dass der Tod findet in unserem Leben sehr wohl statt.
Genau, es ist allerdings ein großes Tabu in Deutschland. Sterben lernen sind jetzt so die Buchtitel, die erscheinen. Und man muss einfach sagen, pro Tag sterben in Deutschland 700 Menschen an Lungenkrankheiten, die nicht Corona sind. Also das ist total gängig. Damit haben Intensivstationen sehr viel zu tun. Und selbst beim Krebs 500 Tote am Tag, Herz-Kreislauf-Schwäche 1000. Also Corona hat, glaube ich, nur an 3-4 Tagen seit Corona gibt mal Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen als Todesursache abgelöst, wenn man jeden Tag sich anschaut. Aber es ist immer wieder erstaunlich, dass wir 55.000 Tote Corona-Tote haben. Und daneben allerdings 20.000-30.000 tote Menschen, die einfach nur sterben, weil sie sich im Krankenhaus infizieren mit Keimen, die es nur im Krankenhaus gibt. Also diese Gewichtung ist doch schon deutlich irgendwie. Und die zeigt, hier wird ganz schön viel gestorben in Deutschland. Wir sind auch mal jetzt. Also jetzt kommen wir auch in das Alter, wo wir über die Verlängerung der Lebenserwartung nicht mehr mehr Bevölkerungswachstum hinbekommen, sondern jetzt ist das ausgereizt. Das ist auch eine ganz interessante Stufe, dass wir, das war nämlich die letzten 70, 80 Jahre so, dass über die Länge der Leben Deutschland gewachsen ist. Und jetzt ist das aber ausgereizt. Und jetzt sterben die Menschen. Und jetzt kommen wir in so einen rollenden Prozess des Sterbens hinein, wo Menschen altersbedingt sterben und Deutschland auch wirklich schrumpft. Also so viel Zuwanderung, 400.000 plus im Jahr haben wir nicht netto, um das jetzt auszugleichen. In deren Sicht ist das jetzt auch eine Zäsur, diese zwanziger Jahre, die jetzt beginnen. Das weiß man noch nicht genau, weil die Verdichtung, die Urbanisierung, derzeit noch extrem krasser verläuft. Das heißt, du kannst in der Eifel oder im Thüringer Land, kannst du schon Grundstücke kaufen, wo die Fläche, Kaufpreis und die Mietpreise in den Großstädten ungefähr gleich sind. Also es fällt wirklich komplett aus dem Rahmen mittlerweile. Na ja, Wolfgang Eilenberger war zu Gast und erinnert hier an einen Umstand, bei dem ich sage, vielleicht aber auch nicht.
Ich denke, mit dieser Corona, mit der Pandemie-Erfahrung ist zumindest wieder klar geworden, dass wir wirklich Teil der Natur sind, wie Herr Wohllebend das sagte. Es ist eigentlich ein Skandal, das sagen zu müssen. Es ist das Offensichtlichste von allem.
Es ist eigentlich das Selbstverständliche.
Dennoch ist unsere Lebensform darauf konzipiert, das uns vergessen zu machen. Es ist natürlich auch eine Kränkung, dass so ein Mikrowesen, ein ganz kleiner Partikel in unserer Existenz, die gesamte globale Welt fast zum Stillstand bringt. Auch da sehen wir, wie vernetzt, wie verkettet alles Leben auf der Welt ist.
Ja, so, es ist klar, alles ist irgendwie miteinander verkettet und die Natur spielt auch eine Rolle. Die Erlösung, die uns jetzt aus der Pandemie raushilft, sind synthetische RNA-Stränge. Das hat so wenig mit Natur zu tun wie... Und mir fällt kein Beispiel ein, weil ich weiß nicht, was so weit weg ist von der Natur.
Das ist für mich auch überhaupt schleierhaft, wie man so was behaupten kann. Das ist ja Unsinn. Also jeder weiß, wenn er Schmerzen hat, dann kann man entweder sagen, ich halte die Schmerzen aus oder ich nehme Chemie zu mir. Und alles Homeopathische und so, das ist Unsinn. Also ich habe einen befreundeten Arzt, der sagte immer, Wolfgang, Natur ist dreckig. Lass es. Man muss die reine Chemie nehmen. Damit kann man den Körper gesund machen. Und natürlich höre ich auf den Arzt.
Ja, wir sind erstaunlich gut, was Chemie angeht. Es gibt sehr viel Skepsis bei Medizin, aber es ist wirklich Wahnsinn, was wir, wenn wir es erst mal synthetisieren und so weiter, damit erringen. Ich finde auch die Schnelltests. Wir machen, also wir unterwerfen uns die Natur vollständig, wenn wir mit absolut billigen Schnelltests, die wir immer zur Verfügung haben, plötzlich die Natur, die sich absolut unsichtbar gemacht hat, vor uns sichtbar machen. Alle Corona-Viren auf der Welt, die gerade zirkulieren, wiegen irgendwie zwei Gramm insgesamt. So, absolut unsichtbar. So, und trotzdem kriegen wir das hin. Und das ist eine Überlistung von Natur. Es gibt allerdings eins, wo man sagen kann, vielleicht hat er recht. Das ist aber so romantisch nur zu sehen. Wir hören das mal im Clip aus den Nachrichten, dass man sagen muss, auch hier stimmt es gerade nicht.
Marktforscher beobachten, dass der Umsatz von Bio-Lebensmitteln in der Corona-Pandemie bundesweit gewachsen ist, um 20 Prozent. Weil Menschen hofften, sich nicht so schnell anzustecken, während sie sich gesund ernähren.
Wir sehen das besonders, dass in der Panikzeit, nenne ich das, März, April, es ganz, ganz stark nach oben ging. Der zweite Grund ist Vertrauen. Die Menschen suchen zusehends nach Vertrauen in dieser schwierigen Zeit. Und Bio strahlt Vertrauen aus.
Okay, wir finden zurück zu Natur, weil wir jetzt im Supermarkt mehr Bio kaufen. Aber dieses Bio ist zwingendermaßen, damit wir es akzeptieren, hochgradig verarbeitet, hochgradig krass mega hygienisch verpackt. Wir trauen uns es nur, mit einem SUV abzuholen. Das hat nichts mit Natur zu tun, im Sinne von Oh, hier ist ja ein Apfel vom Baum gefallen, den esse ich jetzt mal. Also davon sind wir noch weiter entfernt als jemals, dass wir uns so sehr auf Natur einlassen, dass wir uns das trauen. Sondern wir machen um alles einen Bogen. Und den Kicker fand ich eigentlich, dieser letzte Clip hier.
Hätten wir eine Sache noch zu den Bio-Sachen. Die Leute hatten mehr Zeit zum Kochen. Das war ja etwas, was man überhörte, wir backen und kochen jetzt viel. Und dann entscheidet man sich eher für solche Produkte. Dadurch fällt all das Fertigzeug, was man so kaufen kann, weil man mal schnell noch was essen will. Spät Feierabend gehabt und jetzt möchte man nicht noch drei Stunden der Küche verbringen, das fällt weg. Und deswegen hat man natürlich sich auf solche Produkte konzentriert.
Genau. Und finaler Kicker ist dieser.
Und Frau von Reticker sprach, glaube ich, ein sehr wichtiges Thema an. Das Thema von ich und wir, von Eigenbesitz und kollektiv. Aus meiner Sicht das zentrale Thema der nächsten Jahre. Weil wir die letzten 30 Jahre in einer Art neoliberalen Ich-Blase gelebt haben, in der das Eigentum, das Ich, die Selbstverwirklichung, die zentralen Werte unseres Lebensverhältnisses waren. Und wir jetzt spüren, dass die Probleme, die wir als globale Gemeinschaft sehen, nicht per Ich zu lösen ist, sondern dass eine Gemeinschaft, vielleicht sogar eine globale Gemeinschaft, sich diesen Problem annehmen muss. Das heißt, das Kollektiv kommt zurück. Und das ist auch nicht nur eine gute Nachricht politisch.
Ja, klingt alles richtig, ist aber völlig falsch, würde ich sagen. Erst mal erstaunlich, dass er noch mal hier sagt, ja, das Eigentum der Wanderer so neoliberal. Genau diese Eigentumsideologie vertritt er selbst im Interview, das er mit Tilo geführt hat in diesem Jahr. Da sagt er noch mal, dass er gegen die Mietpreisbremse ist, weil er sagt, da würde man eingreifen und vergleicht das Ganze dann mit Stalin, der Leuten nur noch eine Kugel währte. Also sehr absurd das Ganze. Und ich würde sagen, dass gerade diese Eigentumsideologie, die dazu geführt hat, dass wir jetzt so einen Immobilienboom haben, sodass sich die Leute keine Häuser geschweige, oder keine Häuser leisten können und auch keine Mietwohnungen leisten können, das ist ja nicht einhergegangen mit einer neoliberalen Selbstverwirklichung. Das heißt, da hat sich vielleicht ein Prozent selbst verwirklichen können, aber Leute, die sich kein Haus, keine Wohnung leisten können, können sich gar nicht selbst verwirklichen. Und dass das immer so zusammengedacht wird und dass daraus gleichzeitig folgt, dann irgendwie eine Kollektivierung, vor der er dann aber natürlich als liberaler Philosoph wieder wahren muss. Da weiß ich gar nicht, welche Vision hat er denn da. Es ging einfach nur darum, dass Leute vielleicht überhaupt die Chance bekommen zur Selbstverwirklichung. Und diese Chance wird gegeben, wenn das Portemonnaie etwas voller ist und wenn auch günstiger Wohnraum zur Verfügung steht.
Ja, und diese zweite Dimension, wir kommen jetzt vom politischen Ich zum Wir, weil wir feststellen, wir schaffen es nur gemeinsam. Das genau das Gegenteil war. Ich will nicht wissen, wie viele Bürgerinitiativen, Vereine, auch wie auch immer, also Organisationen auf niederser Zugangsschwelle, die allerdings eine gewisse Stetigkeit, Menschen kennen sich, Menschen finden so einen geselligen Umgang miteinander. Wie viel davon einfach nicht mehr da ist, wenn wir sagen, okay, Lockdown ist vorbei, wir sind alle geimpft. Das muss ja alles neu gegründet werden. Also wir sind von organisierter Politik ganz weit weg. Wir haben noch die organisierte Politik. Klar, wir können alle Bundesliga spielen und im Fernsehen irgendwie die Bundesregierung gucken. Aber als politische Wesen wurden wir doch ganz schön ausgeknipst, weil das eben alles verboten wurde. Wenn man so zuspitzt, kann man auch sagen, die Bundesregierung hat im März 2020 alle Bürgerinitiativen in Deutschland verboten. Dürfen sich nicht mehr treffen, nur noch über Zoom und so weiter. Während die Bundesregierung immer weitergemacht hat, die ganzen Ministerien und so, da geht kaum einer ins Homeoffice.
Bundespressekonferenzen.
Ehrlich, Bundespressekonferenzen finden weiterhin statt. Als Veranstaltung vor Ort, da geht man einfach so hin. Und dann, dann Da wird dann diskutiert, ob man jetzt mal Zero-Covid.
Macht, finde ich das total amüsant so was. Und in der Ansicht sind wir ganz weit weg vom politischen Wir, wir wissen gar nicht mehr, was das ist und dass es jetzt einen Aufschwung gibt, da müsste man schon sehr hinbiegend irgendwie einen Sturm auf den Reichstag als organisiert und zielgerichtet oder sowas hindeuten. Das ist kein Wir. Wir müssen ja jetzt auch mal daran denken, wenn wir geimpft sind, wenn wirklich diese großen Lockerungen kommen, dann ist auch erst einmal gar keine Zeit, sofort im Wir zu denken und das hat auch gar nichts mit schlimmem Egoismus zu tun, sondern auch mit einem gewissen Selbsterhaltungstrieb, dass natürlich ganz viele Leute erst mal gucken, wo bleiben sie, bekommen sie einen neuen Job, können sie beim Alten bleiben, funktioniert das Geschäft noch, muss sich das Restaurant jetzt irgendwie noch schnell verkaufen, weil das sich nicht so für mich entwickeln wird, dass ich davon bald wieder richtig leben kann oder wie werde ich meinen Schulden berglos? Das heißt, das sind ganz individuelle Fragen, mit denen Menschen sehr allein gelassen werden und wo sich nicht gerade mal so schnell so ein solidarisches Wir produzieren lässt und wo es verpasst wurde, das hat ja Federer ganz schön herausgestellt, nämlich da, wo man Ich glaube, man wirklich sehr gut hätte die Menschen, die jetzt nicht in Arbeit sind, motivieren können, zu sagen, gut, wir machen jetzt diese Schnelltests, wir machen diese Datenerhebung, wir versuchen wirklich reibungslose Prozesse hinzubekommen. Da hätte man ein Wir konstituieren können, dass sich vielleicht dann auch über die Pandemie-Zeit hinaus in irgendeiner Weise gesellschaftlich gefestigt hat. Aber ich hab eher den Verdacht, das ist so eine ganz schlimme Geschichte, die gibt jeder gegen jeden, dass jeder versucht, irgendwie da sich durchzusetzen. Und mir graut es schon davor, dass wenn jetzt erst mal die Risikogruppe und die sehr Alten geimpft sind, und damit auch die Bundesregierung im Prinzip in Toto, dass man dann sagt, wie das ja, glaube ich, schon von der Jungen Union laut wurde, so jetzt sollen sich aber die Jungen mal nicht mehr so anstellen. Jetzt sollen die mal wieder raus an die Wirtschaft. Und jetzt muss mal alles wieder gelockert werden. Denn irgendwer muss ja auch den 80-Jährigen dann den Kaffee servieren. Und da würde ich sagen, da werden noch große Verwerfungen auf uns zukommen. Also von einem schönen Wir ist da nicht auszugehen.
Ja, vor allem zählen jetzt immer alle so auf dieses Argument. Mit der Mutation kriegen wir dann eigentlich eine Herdenimmunität noch hin, weil da müssen sich ja dann 80 Prozent impfen lassen. Mein Haushalt besteht aus fünf Personen. Drei davon sind in einem Alter, für die es keine Impfung und keine Impfstrategie gibt, sondern für die Durchseuchung das angezielte politische Programm ist. Es gibt keine Impfung für unter 12-Jährige gegen Corona. Und wenn, dann gibt es das vielleicht mal in drei Jahren oder so, um das dann als Kinderkrankheit auszumerzen. Aber derzeit ist es einfach hier haben wir war nicht eingeschlossen in die Studie. Können wir nicht so sagen. Deswegen gilt jetzt erst mal impfen ab 16, glaube ich. Und es wird dann nochmal, es gibt jetzt Studien, die beschleunigt werden, um ab 12 zu impfen. Aber dann ist da Sense. Also die Kinder in Deutschland werden hier einfach gerade dann durchseucht, wenn die locker wegkommen. Denn wir kommen nicht zu dieser harten Immunität. Und ich freue mich auch, wo ist die Diskussion darum? Jetzt die ganze Zeit über Schulen wird diskutiert, wird diskutiert. Und nächstes Jahr ist hier gezielte Durchseuchung aller Schulkinder in Deutschland. Und das finde ich schon so ein bisschen fragwürdig so insgesamt. Naja, abschließender Gedanke heute. Wir können ja doch noch mal klein ganz kurz dieses Thema aufwerfen. GameStop. Was ein Short ist und so weiter, das ist gar nicht so schwer zu verstehen. Müssen wir jetzt gar nicht thematisieren. Menschen sind halt in eine Wette eingegangen, die sie trotzdem auflösen müssen. Also Menschen wurden gezwungen Aktien zu kaufen, auch wenn der Preis, also da spielt Preis keine Rolle. Man ist dann einfach gezwungen, eine Aktie zu kaufen.
Wir müssen vielleicht ganz kurz sagen, was Gamestop ist, weil nicht alle werden es mitbekommen haben. Also Gamestop ist ein Geschäft. Dort kann man 1700 Filialen gibt es weltweit. Dort kann man Computerspiele kaufen. Natürlich ist das jetzt nicht ein boomender Markt, da die meisten Gamer inzwischen streamen. Das wird alles runtergeladen. Da gibt es jetzt nicht mehr Leute, die CD-ROMs kaufen oder auf anderen Dach treiben.
Das ist ja eine neue Xbox und so gar nicht mehr dabei.
Genau, deshalb dachte man, dieser Laden wird keine große Zukunft haben. Dann gab es aber jemanden, der im August meinte, na ja, wenn der sich neu aufstellt und ein bisschen einen Online-Shop ausbaut, ist da noch Potenzial. Das Ganze stieg dann etwas. Die Aktie war bei 14 Dollar etwa angelangt im Dezember. Aber Hedgefonds-Manager sahen das anders, sagen, ist schon überbewertet. Wir wetten darauf, dass die Kurse richtig fallen, dass das eigentlich eine lahme Ente ist, dieses Unternehmen. Und daraufhin haben sich bei Reddit in diesem Forum Gamer und andere Nerds, auch Elon Musk-Fans und was weiß ich, also einen bunten Haufen zusammengetan und gesagt, ja, die können ja mal dagegen wetten. Was ist denn, wenn wir uns jetzt als Community zusammenschließen, als Schwarm und sagen, wir kaufen jetzt diese GameStop Aktien und wir treiben jetzt den Preis nach oben und ein Höhepunkt war am 28.01. da war diese GameStop Aktie mal kurz über 400 Dollar. Und das bedeutet dann, dass bei den Hedgefonds-Managern die Rechnung nicht aufgegangen ist und die müssen dann auch immer wieder mehr zukaufen. Wenn das im Wohlstand für alle wäre, würde ich das mit Ule mal so ein bisschen erläutern, wie es geht. Aber jedenfalls hat man also einen Börsenhype organisiert über Reddit und das ist ein neues Phänomen. Das ist erstmal sehr, sehr bemerkenswert.
Genau, weil da nämlich Menschen Aktien kaufen, nicht weil sie an diese Aktie interessiert sind oder das Geschäftsmodell unterstützen, sondern einfach nur weil sie wissen, das mache ich jetzt gerade nicht alleine und dadurch entsteht so ein gewisser Happening-Effekt. Es gab in Deutschland mal ein Selbstmord von jemandem, dem Ratiofarm-Chef, der Milliarden und Milliarden verloren hat, weil er Aktien kaufen musste, obwohl sie hundertfach teurer waren als der Preis, mit dem er gerechnet hat. Da gibt es ja diesen schönen Short-Vertrag. Also man verkauft heute schon mal eine Aktie, die man gar nicht hat, für 10 Euro, in der Hoffnung, dass sie in einer Woche, wenn man sie dann wirklich übergeben muss, nur 8 Euro kostet, weil wenn sie dann nur 8 Euro kostet, hat man ja 2 Euro Gewinn gemacht. Nur wenn sie dann 80 Euro kostet, muss man sie trotzdem kaufen. Man hat sie zwar nur für 10 Euro vertickert, aber man muss sie plötzlich für 8 mal so viel. Wenn der Kurs jetzt von 15 auf 400 steigt, dann weiß man, da gehen auch mal Milliardäre dran Pleite. Das hatten wir mit dem Mäkel oder so, hieß er. Der hat sich dann tatsächlich vor den Zug geworfen. Als Milliardär hat er sich umgebracht, weil er sich verzockt hat, damals bei VW, als VW zwischenzeitlich das wertvollste Unternehmen der Welt war. Kürze Momente, irgendwann vor 10 Jahren. Und ich wollte das noch mal kurz aufwerfen, weil es jetzt eine ganz tolle Pointe gibt. Heute, am 29. das gleiche Spiel wird gerade mit Bitcoin gemacht. Klar, nicht über so einen Shorthebel, aber bei Bitcoin gibt es gerade einen Nachfrageboom, angeleiert über diese Netzwerkeffekte durch Reddit und so weiter. Und wer führt das gerade an, während der ein oder andere Aktienhändler selbst sagt, ich sperre mich einfach gegenüber den kleinen Aktienhändlern von Reddit, also die können kein Business mehr über mich machen, woaufhin AOC, also Alexander Othocasio-Cortez, auf Twitter schreibt, das ist ja unmöglich, dass hier plötzlich die Kleinen von der Börse Ferngehalt hatten, damit die Milliardäre ihr Profit meidermacht. Dann Ted Cruz glaube ich drüberschreibt, I fully agree. Und dann AOC wieder drüberschreibt auf Twitter, ist zwar schön, dass wir hier einer Meinung sind, aber ich kann mit dir nicht zusammenarbeiten, weil du mich noch vor zwei Wochen töten lassen wolltest durch einen Mob im Parlament. Also solche Verdrehungen mittlerweile, aber diese Bitcoin-Sache wird gerade von Elon Musk, also dem reichsten Menschen der Welt. Der reichste Mensch der Welt stellt sich jetzt an die Spitze dieser Netzwerkbewegung, wo Menschen mit kleinen Beiträgen viel Wirkung entfachen, weil er in seiner eigenen Twitter-Bio einfach nur Bitcoin reingeschrieben hat. Das hat er irgendwann vor fünf Stunden oder so gemacht. Jetzt liegt der Bitcoin-Kurs gerade bei 37.000 Dollar.
Und Elon Musk ist eben das Vorbild für viele in der Reddit-Place, was damit zu erklären ist, dass Elon Musk gegen diese Short-Salar kämpft er ja an, weil die ja schon mehrmals versucht haben, gegen sein Unternehmen zu wetten. Und dann hat er sich da legendäre Twitter-Kriege geleistet. Man muss mal noch über dieses Shorten mal sprechen, weil das als sowas generell Böses angesehen wird. Also die haben vielleicht auch eine ganz nützliche Funktion, kann man sagen. Was allerdings wirklich skandalös ist, ist, dass diese kleinen Aktionäre, anders kann man sie ja nicht nennen, dass die jetzt verdrängt werden, indem man ihnen sagt, ne, ihr dürft jetzt die Aktie hier nicht mehr kaufen. Das ist über Apps wie Robinhood. Da kostet das keine Gebühr, Aktien zu kaufen. Und jetzt hat man die einfach dort ausgeschlossen. Also offenbar gab es sehr starken Druck von der Wall Street, von sehr, sehr mächtigen Leuten, dass man so jetzt reagiert hat. Aber man kann hier mal sehen, wenn der Markt wirklich mal freigeliebt wird, kommt sofort das Kapital und sagt, naja, also so hatten wir uns das aber nicht vorgestellt. Also wir finden Freiheit immer gut, wenn sie zu unseren Gunsten ausgeht.
Also es ist kein rechtsstaatlicher Vorgang, das muss man sagen. Das sind hier chinesische Verhältnisse, der Umgang mit Börsen und Aktienlinien. Linnea, ich bin gleich da. Ich bin gleich da. Linnea, warte noch fünf Minuten, mach mal die Tür zu. Langweiliges Pandemie-Opfer hier. Gut, damit haben wir den Januar so weit abgehandelt. Hier nochmal Grüße an alle ins neue Jahr. Wir sind ja eigentlich die Letzten, die das machen, glaube ich. Im neuen Jahr begrüßt.
Ein gutes neues Jahr und der Hoffnung, dass es allen am Ende des Jahres dann sehr viel besser auch geht. Nervlich. Also man merkt doch, das Nervenkostüm ist ein bisschen in Mitleidenschaft gezogen. Jetzt von diesem Lockdown, der sich nochmal verlängert. Und man weiß noch nicht so genau, wie schnell wird dann jetzt dieser Impfstoff produziert, den wir haben wollen und und und. Aber wir können noch auf den Salon blicken. Wir sprechen ja über ein Buch, bei dem wir vielleicht sogar ein bisschen anknüpfen können an diese GameStop Geschichte. Nämlich da geht es ja ganz stark um die Finanzialisierung, dass nicht mehr realwirtschaftliche Belange eine Rolle spielen. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass man sagt jetzt GameStop, das ist auch eigentlich 400 Dollar wert, sondern man sagt naja, vielleicht 14 Dollar. Aber andere sagen, nee, noch nicht mal zwei Dollar, sondern wir haben hier reine Erwartungen, Spekulation, noch nicht mal mehr Erwartungen, sondern es ist einfach nur die Erwartung, dass andere es erwarten und man guckt, wie lange es funktioniert. Und damit sind wir eigentlich bei Stolen, bei einem Buch von Grace Blakely, das es schon auf Englisch eine Weile gibt. Du hast, glaube ich, auch auf Englisch gelesen. Es gibt es jetzt auf Deutsch, ist bei Jacobin erschienen und darüber werden wir sprechen. Sie macht das. Diese Finanzialisierung des Kapitalismus beschreibt sie anhand von Großbritannien. Aber das ist natürlich ganz leicht übertragbar auf die Wall Street und auch auf Deutschland.
Genau. Ich habe es mir schon besorgt, allerdings noch nicht gelesen. Das mache ich jetzt, denn ich habe sehr viel Zeit mit einem unfassbar guten Buch verbracht, nämlich dem von Barack Obama.
Ich hatte es befürchtet.
Viele fragen sich jetzt, hey, wieso, was ist daran so gut und so. Das Ding ist, er liest es selbst. Und es sind ja viele Zitate drin, Desmond Tutu oder wie er heißt. Wenn Obama das einfach nachmacht, wie er glaubt, dass Desmond Tutu mit ihm gesprochen hat, ist das wirklich spektakel. Also ich kann euch nur empfehlen, ein 700 Seiten dickes Buch liest man nicht, sondern das konsumiert man nebenher, während man die Natur erlebt oder wie auch immer. Und die englische Version hat Barack Obama selbst gelesen. Und es ist das best gelesene Buch überhaupt. Ich könnte es jetzt vergleichen mit wie Rufus Beck Harry Potter gelesen hat. Nur da fehlt dann so... Ich finde, Harry Potter kann man noch mal gut selber lesen und dann den Kindern vorlesen, wie auch immer. Da ist das auch ein Spektakel, dass der Rufus Beck das so gut macht. Aber in dieser Art und Weise schauspielerisch an die Aufgabe heranzugehen, ein Buch vorzulesen, ist wirklich bemerkenswert gelungen. Das sieht man sonst selten. Es ist ja doch immer mehr so eine Computerstimme, wo man sich fragt, irgendwann machen es die synthetischen Stimmen, und dann braucht man das nicht mehr, dass das irgendwelche Schauspieler machen. Und Obama hat es wirklich ausgereizt. Der hat da wirklich ein Anliegen gehabt, dieses Buch, so gut wie geht, zu performen auf allen Ebenen. Und ich werde ein, zwei Ausschnitte mal mitbringen, damit man versteht, was ich meine. Und ansonsten noch mal kurz eine innerliche Einschätzung dazu. Und ansonsten gucken, also ich bin sehr gespannt, was jetzt die Woche noch, also was diese Woche jetzt an GameStop, Bitcoin-Texten so entsteht. Ich glaube, da ist eine gewisse Tiefe drin, die wird bestimmt noch mal schön aufgeschlüsselt.
Ich habe ein paar kleinere Texte noch und auch ein Buch, ich habe einen Ratgeber gelesen, ein Lebensratgeber. Jetzt wirst du verblüfft sein. Ich lese ein Thema. Lebensratgeber. Ist das das neue Buch von Andrea Kivikivel oder was? Nein, natürlich nicht. Ich habe einen Lebensratgeber gelesen, der 350 Jahre alt ist und von Grazian stammt. Warum habe ich den jetzt gelesen? Ich habe eben das Gedicht eingespielt von Berthold Brecht und du hast etwas irritiert reagiert, verwischt die Spuren. Was will er da eigentlich von uns? Es gibt ein sehr bekanntes Buch von Helmut Leten. Ich habe es hier, glaube ich, auch schon mal erwähnt. Verhaltenslehren der Kälte. Da geht es darum, wie man sich in den zwanziger Jahren verhält zu dieser neuen technischen urbanen Wirklichkeit. Und die Idee ist, man wird zu einer kalten Persona, lässt nichts an sich herankommen, verpanzert sich. Der setzt sich dann mit Brecht, Ernst Jünger, Karl Schmidt und so weiter auseinander. Und auch Brecht hat diese Idee der kalten Persona, das wurde da in diesem Gedicht beschrieben, dass man noch nicht mal mehr auf der Straße dann die Eltern grüßt. Und jetzt muss man aber sagen, das haben die in den zwanziger Jahren sich nicht zum ersten Mal selbst ausgedacht, sondern damals wurde ein Buch rezipiert, nämlich das Handorakel für die Welt um Weltklugheit, so hieß das zu erwerben, von Grazian. Das war ein Buch, das damals auch bei den großen Herrschern, Königen auf dem Tisch lag, weil man da lernen konnte, wie hat man sich in der Öffentlichkeit zu verhalten. Und dieses Buch ist in den zwanziger Jahren neu rezipiert worden. Und dann gab es auch eigene Handorakel, die die verfasst haben und dann die sie sich gehalten haben. Und jetzt, in den neun zwanziger Jahren, ist dieses alte Handorakel von Hans Ulrich Gumbrecht neu übersetzt worden und bei Reclam erschienen. Also man knüpft hier wirklich an die Alten Zwanziger an. Und dieses Handbuch habe ich gelesen und da sind sehr schöne Thesen drin. Und ich kann sagen, das ist eigentlich auch so ein Handbuch. Wie verhalte ich mich in den sozialen Medien?
Ich bin ja mal skeptisch, wenn jemand sagt. Wie Hannah Arendt sagte, oder Hegel. Ich meine, die sagten bestimmt nichts zu Corona. Aber die sozialen Medien, warum nicht? Ich bin gespannt. Sehr gut. Sehr gut. Dann habt eine tolle Woche. Und nächste Woche im Hausalarm.
Alles klar. Alles Gute. Bis dahin.